[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est un événement qu'on ne voit jamais
ou presque un couronnement de Rennes ou
de roi d'Angleterre il y en aura pas eu
entre le 2 juin 1953 et ce 6 mai 2023 70
ans après sa mère Elisabeth II Charles
III devient aujourd'hui roi d'Angleterre
et pas que finalement il devient le roi
les images les images de Londres où nous
serons tout au long de cette journée
poursuivre pour suivre et bien ce
couronnement bonjour à tous évènements
exceptionnels ce samedi nous vivons
ensemble le couronnement du roi Charles
sur le Figaro live celui que l'on a si
souvent appelé Prince sera
officiellement roi dans quelques heures
et nous ne raterons rien de cette
journée à Londres capitale du monde
aujourd'hui
capitaine du monde tellement de père
Dieu qui seront rivés sur sur cette
capitale les meilleures spécialistes
sont sur ce plateau pour des crypter ce
moment Sarah le coeur bonjour bonjour
Thibault pour ma liste au TV Mag vous
savez que vous allez vivre un moment
d'histoire aujourd'hui c'est notre
premier couronnement quasiment à tous je
pense sur le
en 1953 bonjour Jean merci d'être avec
nous et je me souviens que j'ai vu le
film projeté à l'Olympia avant que ça
devienne un musical et c'était
extraordinaire parce que la reine avait
voulu que le film que la cérémonie soit
télévisée pas par mégalomanie pour que
les
sujets les plus mal logés éloignés de
Londres dans le commonwealt dans le
Royaume-Uni puisse avoir l'impression
d'être invité à Westminster alors vous
avez vu en direct à l'Olympique je l'ai
vu en léger décalé comme c'était
extraordinaire et la version en couleur
a été envoyé particulièrement le soir
même au Canada en Australie ce qui fait
qu'Elizabeth iI est devenu la reine de
l'image et elle est restée on en parlera
justement avec Sarah qui est là pour ça
Georges précise que vous faites paraître
ce bouquin aux éditions Perrin Charles
Camilla et Diana le voici vous êtes
l'historien des dynasties européennes
Renault Girard bonjour Renaud bonjour
nicker international au Figaro j'emploie
souvent le mot exceptionnel des fois je
me dis que c'est un peu galvaudé là
c'est un événement exceptionnel quand
même
oui parce que c'est un événement qui
semble un peu anachronique si vous
voulez un pays qui fait une cérémonie
d'autres fois qui reprend en fait pas
tout à fait pareil mais de manière pas
très éloignée la cérémonie du
couronnement de l'arène d'Angleterre en
faisant un pari assez simple la
cérémonie du gourmand la reine
d'Angleterre avait été très populaire
non seulement en Angleterre mais dans le
monde entier comme la rap les gens
descarts et donc
il les anglais parce qu'évidemment que
le gouvernement a été associé à tout ça
a fait le même pari c'est-à-dire qu'au
moment où l'Angleterre est
je dirais pas au plus mal mais n'est pas
au mieux de sa forme en fait le brexit
apparaît comme avoir été une
erreur stratégique ou il y a beaucoup de
dissension de problème sociaux c'est pas
le seul pays la France aussi mais il y a
des problèmes sociaux en Angleterre
voilà où ce où le rayonnement de
l'Angleterre diminue année après année
il y a cet événement il y a donc ce pari
de refaire ce qui avait marché avec la
reine d'Angleterre il est trop tôt on
verra les foules dans l'onde et les
trotteaux pour dire si ce pari est
réussi ou pas et bien justement Renaud
la foule dans l'ombre on va aller
demander à ceux qui sont plus proches
Timothée delaime pour Le Figaro et sur
place Timothée vous pourrez raconter à
vos petits-enfants que ce jour-là vous
étiez à Londres
bonjour Thibault bonjour à tous
effectivement je pourrais le raconter à
mes petits-enfants et beaucoup de
personnes ici pourront également leur
raconter à leurs proches ils sont
nombreux très nombreux dans les rues de
Londres et aux abords en tous les cas de
du palais de Buckingham à 7 rendus ici
pour espérer évidemment apercevoir la
silhouette de Charlotte III également
des membres de la famille royale tout à
l'heure vous le voyez sur ces images je
me trouve actuellement
Trafalgar Square c'est cette grande
place qui donne sur l'avenue du mal
laquelle donne sur Buckingham Palace
certains et bien ce sont levés taux très
tôt ce matin comme par exemple cette
dame qui me disait qu'elle s'est levée à
4h du matin elle est partie de Rochester
à 45 km de Londres pour venir ici et
espérer et bien apercevoir Charles III
une grosse ferveur ici malgré une petite
pluie qui commence à s'abattre depuis
quelques minutes mais une pluie qui n'a
pas a pas de raison de l'ardeur des
Britanniques qui continuent d’influer en
nombre ici sur cette place trafalgoire
qui est en train de se remplir à vue
d'oeil merci Timothée le 2 juin 1953 il
avait plus aussi Jean des quartiers vous
qui êtes un spécialiste de la royauté
des dynasties européennes est-ce que
vous êtes un peu ému là je vous demande
un sentiment pas une analyse je trouve
ça fantastique parce que il y a
l'événement politique international
le fait que ce soit le sixième souverain
du Royaume-Uni le Royaume-Uni existe
depuis 1922 c'est-à-dire après la
Première Guerre mondiale avec l'État
libre d'Irlande l'Irlande du Nord aussi
et puis c'est le
62e monarque couronnée à Westminster ce
qui est quand même extraordinaire comme
62 et d'autre part il y a ce roman
d'amour
stupéfiant longtemps méconnu caché mal
interprété et si vous voulez pardon mais
si j'ai consacré un livre notamment à
cela c'est parce que on a eu longtemps
uniquement la version de Diana ce qui
n'était pas tout à fait la vérité parce
que Diana s'exposait médiatiquement
c'était l'inverse de Camilla il faut
tout de suite dire que la liaison entre
Camilla et Charles n'est pas du tout ce
qui est affirmé Diana qu'elle n'y a été
marié s'était rencontré en 71 bon
Charles on lui fait épouser Diana on va
pas revenir dessus elle ne cesse de le
critiquer de le dénigrer lui n'a jamais
critiqué Diana ni publiquement ni en
privé ça a été on le sait un cauchemar
et la liaison avec Camilla a repris
qu'après la naissance de Harry en 1985
il y a donc une histoire politique
internationale on dit souvent oui le roi
d'Angleterre souverain du Royaume-Uni
n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir il faut par
exemple préciser qu'aucune loi ne peut
entrer en application s'il ne l'a pas
signé il ne va pas approuvé et
Elizabeth II comme
successeur renvoyait souvent les
documents au gouvernement pour dire je
ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
expliquez-moi mieux etc donc c'est très
très important derrière se fasse unique
alors je voudrais vous dire aussi que
c'est la seule ville au monde à mon avis
où le cheval
restait aussi important et on va voir
les carottes tout à l'heure on va en
parler
2762 qui pèse 4 tonnes et qui est très
inconfortable
c'est ça et voilà dans les chevaux il y
aura le cheval que le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron avait offert
à la reine pour
la presse sont
le cheval qui avait été offert par la
France car on sait combien la reine
était experte en équitation cavalerie et
elle a même dit je termine là-dessus
lorsque le 9 avril 2005 elle a organisé
le mariage de Charles et Camilla dit que
le couple avait franchi des obstacles
comme dans un grand steople Chase star
Lecoeuvre combien de personnes vont
regarder la télé dans le monde
aujourd'hui la télé et internet et les
écrans parce que on dit souvent que en
1953 c'est la première fois que la télé
a dépassé la radio est-ce que c'est
aujourd'hui la première fois
télévisé majeur
parce qu'en fait oui pour la première
fois c'était un événement télévisé bien
sûr et pour la première fois les caméras
étaient à l'intérieur de l'abbaye de
Westminster et ça c'était une demande
d'Élisabeth qui allait à l'encontre de
celle de Winston Churchill qui qui plus
à les caméras à la à l'intérieur de
l'abbaye et Elisabeth II a tenu tête et
c'est comme ça que les caméras se sont
glissés à l'intérieur et il y a un seul
instant et ça je trouve ça incroyable
qui sera pas filmé c'est l'onction bien
sûr ça va être le moment sacré la
rencontre avec Dieu quelque part et
c'est ce seul instant qui ne sera pas
filmé devant les caméras de la BBC c'est
assez incroyable
vexé disait mais je ne vois pas pourquoi
les caméras de la BBC verrez mieux que
moi il était furieux et alors ça c'est
vrai on verra nous nous verrons mieux ce
qu'il se passe devant notre écran que
les gens qui sont
10e rang ou 12e rang ou 20e Rangers
extraordinaire la présence de caméras de
télévision dans une dans un édifice
Westminster qui représente aujourd'hui
957 ans de couronnement c'est absolument
inouïe le choc
technologique il y a 200 caméras
aujourd'hui entre the mâle l'avenue et
l'abbaye de Westminster on va à l'écran
ça va être évidemment très très
impressionnant est-ce que c'est une
forme de divertissement dans des cas ce
qu'on veut la monarchie britannique et
la seule qui offre je dirais un
spectacle dans le bon sens du terme avec
les défilés les chevaux les traditions
c'est vrai les monarchies européennes
Suède Norvège Danemark sont beaucoup
plus sobre d'ailleurs il n'y a pas de
sacre ni à proprement parler de
couronnement il y a une prestation de
serment il peut y avoir une influence
religieuse plus ou moins mais rien de
comparable à ce qui se passe à
Westminster qui est une abbaye c'est
1000 ans d'histoire depuis Guillaume le
Conquérant c'est c'est fascinant voilà
l'intérieur de cette abbaye de
Westminster on a vu des personnalités on
a vu Katy Perry
demain au concert qui est prévenu
qu'il y avait tous les grands comédiens
et madameson
des bonnes Fry etc
et je me tourne vers Renault Girard il y
a aussi des personnalités politiques
est-ce que je demande à Jean descart
c'est un événement de divertissement
est-ce que c'est un événement politique
géopolitique aujourd'hui alors c'est un
événement politique regardez tiens
pendant qu'on parle de ça John Kerry
visiblement avec l'ancien Premier
ministre je vois pas très bien les deux
profils je crois connaître l'ancien
Premier ministre conservateur
Cameron
et oui c'est un événement politique et
géopolitique politique
parce que cette témoigne si vous voulez
de l'unité des
îles britanniques donc de ce royaume qui
est fait disait dans des cas depuis 1922
de l'Angleterre des pays de Galles de
l'Écosse de l'Irlande du Nord
c'est provinces ont même ce qu'on
appelle un First ministère
ils seront tous présents bien sûr
c'est l'union du royaume et géopolitique
c'est comme Justin Trudeau pardon je me
trompe non il est premier Canada mais il
y a des forces ministère des provinces
c'est un peu comme les chefs des Landers
en Allemagne que vous voulez voilà mais
ils ont davantage de pouvoir encore donc
en Écosse et au pays de Galles et
d'ailleurs en Irlande du Nord aussi
après
c'est un système qui fonctionne bien
après les accords du vendredi saint la
paix en Irlande du Nord en 1997 et puis
c'est un événement géopolitique parce
que
c'est la volonté de la Grande-Bretagne
de continuer à régner si vous voulez
influencer par ce spectacle par cette
tradition très ancienne
le monde entier
il faut voir que
la reine Victoria a régné sur une grande
partie du monde sur sur l'Inde notamment
et il y a je dirais une double influence
aujourd'hui entre l'Angleterre
Westminster et son ancien empire double
influence d'abord parce que là vous avez
ça va être regardé partout y compris en
Inde au Canada et en Australie etc mais
parallèlement le Raj britannique c'est à
dire l'ancienne domination
Victoria a été impératrice des Indes et
bien l'orage britannique a donné les
trois plus importantes fonctions
politiques en Angleterre aujourd'hui
enfin au Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui qui
sont
premiers ministres du Royaume-Uni qui
est un indien
doux
le Premier ministre le First Minister de
l'Écosse
et le maire de Londres les trois qui est
les deux derniers étant originaire du
Pakistan
les trois si vous voulez plus
importantes fonctions politiques
de des Royaumes-Unis aujourd'hui vient
de lancer un Rav de britannique donc il
y a une sorte de double
influence entre vous avez d'une part la
tradition mais vous avez aussi une
intégration si vous voulez des anciens
éléments de l'Empire britannique dans
cette tradition millénaire on retourne à
Londres Timothée delhayme est avec
Amaury coûtant C ce sont nos envoyés
spéciaux pour pour Le Figaro tiens
parlez-nous un peu de un peu de
l'ambiance vous êtes à Londres depuis
hier est-ce que vous sentez une
atmosphère particulière Timothée
alors c'est un petit peu coupé
ouais ça a un petit peu coupé Thibault
mais je devine votre question vous me
demandez bien quelle est l'ambiance ici
sur place à Maury ça fait une heure et
demie deux heures qu'on se promène ici
sur cette place du trafalgoire et sur
cet avenue du mal avenue du mal qui est
d'ailleurs fermé parce qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de monde ce matin oui
effectivement Timothée en déjà il y a à
peu près 1h30 on a essayé d'y rentrer la
police a demandé aux gens d'arrêter
d'avancer parce que trop de monde en
fait rentrer que l'avenue ne peut pas
comprendre autant de gens lorsqu'on
discute un peu avec les gens on a pu
discuter on se le racontait en antenne
des gens qui sont levés à 4 5h du matin
même certains qui sont venus des la
veille pour pouvoir assister espérer
entre apercevoir la silhouette de
Charles III qui devrait passer juste
derrière nous dans un trajet pour aller
vers Westminster abais également on peut
penser aux personnes que nous
interviewons hier qui ont dormi parfois
même qui était là depuis deux jours et
qui ont dormi dans des tentes pour
espérer encore une fois apercevoir un
membre de la famille royale sur l'avenue
du mal qui donne sur le palais de
bouquins quelque chose d'assez
significatif à Maurice c'est qu'il y a
du monde qui vient de Londres des mondes
qui vient de toute l'Angleterre de tout
le Royaume-Uni mais également de tout le
Commonwealth effectivement encore hier
on a même pu voir des gens qui venaient
du Canada du Canada français mais
également de de Guinée et du Nigéria qui
venait parce que il faut le rappeler
finalement Charles III et le souverain
britannique mais également le souverain
de 13 royaumes du Commonwealth et donc
pour eux c'est également un nouveau chef
de l'État qui va changer un mot à Maury
également parce que c'est vrai que vu de
France le on sait que sur ce type
d'événements le dispositif de sécurité
est toujours extrêmement important il y
a toujours une certaine tension autour
de ce genre de choses c'est vrai qu'ici
nous n'avons ni été fouillé ni palpée
c'est quelque chose assez qui peut
paraître assez étonnant vu de France en
tout cas c'est vrai que pour un Français
je pense qu'il y a deux choses qui sont
étonnantes déjà c'est la ferveur des
gens qui viennent pour
applaudir un souverain ce que l'on ne
connaît plus en France mais également
effectivement la légèreté du système de
sécurité j'ai pu me promener comme ça
j'avais un sac à dos personne ne m'a
fouillé les policiers ne sont pas armés
encore ce matin en descendant de l'hôtel
un policier m'a souhaité une bonne
journée parler très calmement avec les
gens véritablement c'est un dispositif
très léger mais pourtant l'ambiance est
bonne fin et on le sent aucune menace
qui pèse sur nous-même si effectivement
tout à l'heure sur cette place du
trafalgarounou nous nous trouvons des
militants anti monarchie en protesté et
6 ont été arrêtés par la police
britannique merci Amaury écoute en ces
pervers voilà Thibault pour ces quelques
éléments d'atmosphère et d'ambiance ici
depuis la place du Trafalgar à Londres
merci Timothée merci à Maurice Timothée
de nous trouver
un anglais vous nous ferez profiter de
votre accent j'en suis sûr ou des
Français parce qu'il y a des Français
qui sont allés voir ce couronnement ça
fascine beaucoup les Français et à ce
sujet je voudrais rappeler que
sans entrer dans des polémiques que l'on
connaît en 1901
un cinéaste de génie un pionnier Georges
Méliès a eu l'idée de filmer le
couronnement d'Edouard 7 le fils de la
reine Victoria mais il l'a reconstitué
en studio avant l'événement parce qu'il
voulait absolument puisque la télévision
n'existait pas que les Français puissent
assister à cette cérémonie et Edouard
VII avec beaucoup d'humour a dit c'est
bien simple quand j'en ai regardé je
croyais m'y être en 1901 Méliès
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il avait compris
que les Français étaient nostalgique de
la qui avait une mission
très profonde en France le sont-ils
vraiment Renault certains ah je pense
qu'il y a non mais je pose d'abord il y
a une on le voit bien
Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron au début en 2017 disait
que les notes Français avaient une
nostalgie de du roi et ben évidemment
qu'il y avait une loi qui continue c'est
pour ça que vous avez c'est pour ça
qu'en fait toutes les histoires de la
monarchie britannique intéressent la
presse qui peuvent française sur les
premiers consommateurs
et il y a effectivement
ce système qu'il faut reconnaître est
très fort c'est à dire que toute la
gloire va à un homme sans pouvoir c'est
à dire que le système britannique est un
système qui dissocie la gloire et le
pouvoir et c'est très simple c'est à
dire que l'homme qui a le pouvoir je
crois que c'est Oscar Wilde qui disait
ça est un petit monsieur avec un chapeau
melon c'est lui qui a le pouvoir
mais la gloire et donc va au chef d'État
qui n'a pas le pouvoir et toute
l'adoration populaire qui fait l'union
du
l'union du peuple britannique et bien
elle va au roi et quand il y a des
moments tragiques comme
les bombardements de Londres par les
Allemands en 1940 et quand le roi qui
représente la nation décide alors que le
gouvernement lui dire on va vous envoyer
au Canada en vous environ en Écosse pour
vous protéger et qui dit non je reste
avec mes sujets et qu'il sort dans
Londres bombardé et que l'on le voit au
milieu des ruines de Londres un impact
considérable
c'est l'homme qui incarne la gloire de
l'Empire de ce qui était encore l'Empire
britannique et dans la difficulté il est
là au milieu de ces sujets et c'est ça
qui fait la force de cette monarchie de
comparatif hasardeux ça me fait penser à
ce que peut faire le présent Hélène ski
en Ukraine même s'il est parois il sort
dans les rues de Kiev il a toujours
voulu montrer qu'il restait à Kiev ah
bah c'est très important c'est c'est le
même type de message effectivement le
président ce qui est tout à fait
évidemment instruit de l'histoire et
c'est quelque chose et ce qui on lui
proposait c'était pas son gouvernement
c'était les États-Unis qui lui ont
proposé de s'exiler et de partir de Kiev
pour avoir la vie sauve et il a dit il a
eu cette formule incroyable ce n'est pas
d'un taxi dont j'ai besoin mais de
munitions et donc là il a vraiment
incarné comme président élu et sa
popularité a beaucoup grandi mais si
vous voulez dans dans la Résistance
britannique de 1940 vous avez en fait
vous avez Churchill et vous avez vous
avez un couple et vous avez le roi et il
joue très bien ensemble et justement
ces Churchill évidemment qui fait la
politique de résistance et qui organise
et qu'il pense d'ailleurs mais c'est le
roi qu'il incarne et évidemment sur
shield va pousser sans arrêt le roi en
avant et la famille Royal on sait par
exemple que l'épouse du roi a été très
sympathique à l'égard des Français
libres de De Gaulle etc c'était la Queen
marine voilà la reine mère la reine mère
d'Elizabeth elle a été la science
d'arrêt dorloter ses pauvres français
libre qui représentaient une France
occupée à l'époque et donc cette cette
monarchie a joué dans les moments
difficiles de du Royaume-Uni un rôle
très important bien sûr le célèbre Queen
Mum qui est morte à 101 ans était très
lié à une de mes tentes elle venait la
voir dans un grand château dans le
Périgord à un moment où quelques agités
avaient l'intention d'enlever la reine
mère dans les années 70
et je me souviens que la reine mère est
arrivée il y avait des problèmes de
sécurité d'installation de ces gardes du
corps de scottlander etc il est arrivé
avec un verre de Jean bien tassé 6h30 du
soir en disant un matin Simone je ne
croyais rien Hitler et Staline mon raté
est morte à 100 ans et ses obsèques ont
été si j'ose dire l'un des moyens avec
lequel la reine a retrouvé de la
popularité qu'elle avait perdu après
Diana etc l'un des moyens cette cette
journée de couronnement qu'on va
évidemment mettre en parallèle avec
d'autres grands événements Sarah
peut-être comparer les audiences on peut
alors par rapport au couronnement de
1953 et à d'autres la mort de Lady Di
les funérailles d'Elizabeth II est-ce
qu'on peut faire des parallèles oui
alors la mort de Lady Di c'est un record
dans le monde c'est ça représente 2
milliards de téléspectateurs bon aussi
faut dire que l'événement était tragique
surprise évidemment donc il y avait
plusieurs dimensions qui expliquent ce
chiffre
dernièrement les funérailles de de la
reine d'Angleterre c'est en septembre
jusqu'à 200 milliards de téléspectateurs
ont regardé cet événement donc vraiment
colossal et dans en France on est plutôt
autour de 7 millions et demi de
téléspectateurs 8 millions et les
mariages jusqu'à 10 millions environ
pour à peu près ce qui est énorme pour
apprendre l'argent que la France était
le principal vous avez utilisé le mot
consommateur de ce genre d'événements
dans les autres pays en Allemagne par
exemple on va pas suivre ce couronnement
comme on le fait en France
Elisabeth II aimait beaucoup la France
son premier voyage en tant que princesse
héritière en 1947 est en France avec
Philippe et ensuite après 1950 son
premier voyage en tant que reine chef
d'État et pour la France aussi où avec
avec Charlotte III voilà donc c'est très
intéressant il y a une un lien
formidable et rappelons l'inauguration
du tunnel sous la Manche avec le
président Mitterrand qui était
littéralement fasciné par Elisabeth II
tout ce qu'elle savait tout ce qu'elle
ne pouvait pas dire faut Renaud le sait
encore mieux que moi je veux dire la
reine était le dernier chef d'État en
fonction qui était né qui était devenue
reine au moment où Staline était encore
à Moscou et elle a découvert que autour
d'elle des anciens agents britanniques
étaient devenus des agents de l'Est et
de Moscou l’œil de président français
entre effectivement la France et
l'Angleterre qui est une très ancien
d'autant plus que la propre devise de la
monarchie britannique et nous allons le
voir j'imagine est écrit en français
enfin il y a deux devises
Dieu est mon droit voilà Dieu on va le
voir dans l'abbaye de Westminster et on
a droit c'est la loi c'est les les
premiers qui sont là c'est le Parlement
Dieu et mon droit donc c'est du français
la devise britannique est écrite en
français
soit en est-ce que c'est
beaucoup plus ancien parce que la
monarchie effectivement britannique avec
Guillaume le Conquérant et donc et
d'ailleurs vous avez plusieurs articles
très intéressants dans le Figaro
là-dessus la plupart
des mots sur tous les mots savants
anglais viennent du français alors entre
temps ils ont beaucoup changé de sens
par exemple
even par exemple
eventuallet ça veut dire finalement en
anglais et ça veut dire éventuellement
en français voilà l'impression que vous
êtes en train d'essayer de vous
approprier cette cérémonie en tant que
Français à m'en faire Renault Gérard oui
ben c'est ce que c'est pour ça que
le côté spectacle c'est la seule c'est
le seul État qui offre
tel rassemblement de spectacles dans des
monuments fascinants les carrosses les
chevaux j'y reviens les uniformes de la
garde c'est vrai que d'ailleurs
j'interroge Sara là-dessus Jean c'est un
couronnement un peu plus sobre là il y
aura moins de monde quand
la reine là on est passé à 2200 invités
ah oui avec Charles III on dit que la
monarchie va passer à l'eau et au pain
sec
vous avez 40 cm pour s'asseoir dans
Westminster en 1953 donc c'était très
serré là on donne un peu plus de place
et la cérémonie durera moins longtemps à
l'époque c'était trois heures un peu
plus de trois heures ça va être deux
heures oui mais il n'aurait pas été
question de supprimer tout ça aurait été
atteindre l'essence même de la fonction
de spectacle de la monarchie est
importante
tout à l'heure l'abbaye de Westminster
ces images en direct les chefs d'État
pas tous d'ailleurs tiens Renault j'en
profite parce que comme vous prenez la
parole Joe Biden ne sera pas là il
perpétue la traduction la tradition des
présidents américains qui ne vont pas au
couronnement d'un roi ou du drame
d'Angleterre il faut quand même
comprendre que les États-Unis
d'Amérique se sont forgés la lutte
contre la monarchie celle de George de
Troie en l'occurrence
et mais il y a quand même
des liens très très proches entre les
États-Unis et le Royaume-Uni
certains britanniques même disent trop
proche c'est un Britannique
le critique en disant que Royaume-Uni
serait devenu le coup d'œil c'est-à-dire
le caniche des États-Unis en politique
étrangère suivant les États-Unis dans
tout ce qu'ils font notamment par
exemple dans les choses les plus
catastrophiques comme l'invasion de
l'Irak en 2003 par exemple
mais ils sont ils sont très proches mais
effectivement les États-Unis sont
profondément une république et une
république faite contre la monarchie
britannique précisément voilà nous nous
sommes nous ça donc c'est un peu
différent il y a pas de il y a pas de
nostalgie aux États-Unis pour pour la
monarchie qui n'a jamais d'ailleurs
existé sauf la monarchie anglaise tandis
qu'il y a une il y a une nostalgie comme
je l'ai dit je pense en France pour
notre monarchie qui a existé pendant les
Capets pendant
800 ans
[Musique]
Joe Biden n'est pas là Jill Biden sa
femme sera bien présente on va à Londres
on retrouve Timothée Timothée on vous a
lancé un défi vous l'avez relevé vous
êtes avec un anglais un anglais déguisé
qui ressemble presque Elton John
absolument Thibault avec un anglais et
déguisé en anglais qui sait lui aussi le
véto qui a pris le train de ce matin
depuis Yorkshire pour venir ici espérer
à percevoir et bien le roi Charles III
pourquoi est-ce si important pour vous
d'être là aujourd'hui ouais
extraordinaire
un couronnement de mon vivant donc voilà
c'est pour ça que je suis ici
[Musique]
le roi Charles III qu'est-ce que la
famille royale signifie pour vous
ça fait partie de notre réalité ça fait
partie de notre identité c'est ce qui
fait que l'Angleterre et l'Angleterre
c'est comme la poste
c'est anglais et moi j'adore et c'est
très important pour moi c'est tout
j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas surpris
par le nombre de personnes qui est
venues aujourd'hui
mais bon comme je vous disais moi je
savais qu'il y aurait qui aurait du
monde et là c'est vrai qu'on arrive même
pas à passer dans la rue
ou alors il fallait se lever vraiment
très très tôt là je suis très fabule
espoir j'ai pas l'impression que je peux
sortir d'ici
donc ouais ouais c'est super ouais moi
je suis ravi ravissé puis je serai ravi
aussi de pouvoir prendre une bière mais
là il est un petit peu tôt peut-être
quel est votre programme vous allez et
bien fêter le couronnement du roi
Charles III pendant tout le week-end
[Musique]
après la fin de la cérémonie il a
peut-être un petit cocktail ou deux même
et puis juste m'amuser et puis je pense
que vers 8h je vais aller me coucher
parce que je serai complètement explosé
voilà beaucoup d'enthousiasme Thibault
et ici sur cette place du du trafalgore
avec ses anglais qui sont là et qui
attendent maintenant d'apercevoir le roi
Charles III qui ont soif aussi
visiblement et vous irez bien ce petit
costume Renault Girard là non vous
seriez bien là-dedans oui la bière aussi
là peut-être pas effectivement aussitôt
le matin mais nous sommes audition nous
mettons alors à l'heure anglaise est-ce
que j'en déclare Charles III va être un
souverain sobre est-ce que nous avons
affaire à un couronnement sobre est-ce
que le Royaume-Uni va devenir sobre avec
ce roi oui bah écoutez compte tenu de la
situation économique de l'inflation et
de son parcours personnel d'un homme qui
a été contre le gaspillage qui était le
pionnier d'un certain environnement
d'une certaine logique c'est le
président du qui a eu un AVC donc vous
l'avez vu il n'hésitez pas à Renaud dès
que vous voyez des dirigeants des
dirigeants importants vous nous les
signalez il faut préciser que si vous
voulez charles est un homme qui a été un
pionnier partout je prends l'exemple il
a lutté par exemple contre le dictateur
roumain chez Cook qui voulait détruire
des monastères en Roumanie qui voulaient
faire abattre des arbres dans les forêts
des Carpates enfin ils Charles s'est mis
à protéger tout ce qui pouvait y compris
les vampires Roumanie bon c'est un homme
parfait je vous coupe les gens il me
semble que Renaud il s'agit de Jil Biden
c'est un symbole important quand même
Renault est-ce que en 1953 la femme de
Dyson hower était venue je suis pas
certain là on essaie
qui a été venu parce que d'abord c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué et beaucoup plus
long de venir à l'époque bien sûr des
États-Unis
ou en Alaska ou je ne sais pas où à
Terre-Neuve je crois il fallait
s'arrêter faire du carburant on va faire
du carburant etc c'était très long et
donc c'était pas du tout ça
d'aller d'aller l'ambassadeur des
États-Unis certainement évidemment était
présent mais je suis pas sûr que la
femme d'alsanoër d'ailleurs le président
Noël n'a jamais mis en avant en avant
son épouse c'est à dire c'est pas une
tradition de mettre en avant les épouses
dans la république américaine il y a eu
un peu Jacky Kennedy avec André Malraux
etc mais normalement
dans la présidence américaine les
épouses jouent pas ne jouent pas à grand
rôle
l'épouse de Truman on a on la
connaissait à peine Eisenhower non plus
un voyage de presse avec ladybug la
femme voilà et puis et voilà et la femme
de Trump est restée très très discrète
la femme de bouche aussi de George elle
accompagné son mari mais on ne met pas
en avant aux États-Unis
la femme du président puisqu'on a
d'autres personnes à mettre en avant
notamment le vice-président là on a une
femme aux États-Unis
ou évidemment le secrétaire d'État qui
sont des trois personnes
mentionnées les trois fonctions
mentionnelles à Constitution des
États-Unis le secrétaire d'État le
vice-président et le président
on va retourner à Londres avec le
spécialiste du Figaro en haut de
Lagrange vous êtes sur place
correspondant permanent à Londres vous
vivez
oui ben voilà voilà c'est comme ça
Renault que je vous attendez moi
houblon chapeau melon
avec avec grand plaisir
Arnaud j'imagine que depuis plusieurs
jours
Londres l'Angleterre Royaume-Uni bas au
rythme de ce couronnement où je me
trompe parce que les Anglais s'y
intéressent tant que ça
alors justement c'est un peu
contradictoire il y a eu des sondages
disant qu'en fait
il y avait peut-être 10% des
Britanniques qui s'y intéressaient
vraiment bon alors après tout dépend
comment la question est posée
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que vous y êtes
intéressé beaucoup pas beaucoup bon en
tout cas montrant qu'il n'y avait pas
forcément un intérêt démesuré pour le
couronnement on dirait 10% de quasiment
70 millions de personnes ça fait déjà du
monde il y a du monde à Londres
non il y a quand même un vif intérêt
mais c'est paradoxal que d'une part
c'est évidemment le le premier
couronnement que verront la plupart des
Britanniques puisque le précédent était
il y a 70 ans c'est quand même un
événement exceptionnel c'est pas comme
s'il y en avait eu un il y a 10 ou 15
ans ou 20 ans donc ça évidemment ça
suffit ça m'intérêt fort par contre
enfin en revanche c'est vrai que Charles
est connu des Britanniques depuis quand
même fort longtemps c'est moi qu'on
puisse dire donc il y a pas d'effets de
surprise il est roi depuis quelques mois
depuis septembre dernier on n'est pas
comment 53 ou il y avait une jeune reine
de 25 ans que que personne ne
connaissait vraiment où il y avait cet
effet de surprise et de curiosité donc
évidemment qui a un fort engouement et
qui a du monde sur le mal il y a tous
ces gens qui quand vous en avez parlé
Timothée et au milieu d'eux il y a tout
cela mais c'est un peu voilà c'est un
peu mixte comme mixé comme sentiment
un dispositif de sécurité très important
qui est mis en place est-ce que c'est
inquiète les les Anglais est-ce que
c'est un club les Londoniens nous par
exemple en France on a ce sujet autour
des Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent la
sécurité la sécurité est-ce que pour un
événement comme ça c'est l'un des sujets
majeurs Arnaud
non enfin oui bien sûr c'est une
préoccupation majeure je crois qu'ils
ont mobilisé à peu près 11000 policiers
pour l'événement alors il disait que
c'était il y avait dans la presse on dit
que c'est la plus grande opération de
policière enfin de sécurité depuis
chaque fois c'est toujours la plus
grande ou la plus importante donc là je
ne sais pas ce qui est certain c'est que
c'est il y a des enjeux évidemment il y
a la famille royale et mais il y a aussi
tous ces dignitaires étrangers qui sont
là donc c'est un c'est un enjeu
important mais ce qui est assez
impressionnant quand vous êtes sur le
mal et ailleurs les le service de police
à l'anglaise enfin le le la culture
anglaise de de du maintien de l'ordre de
la sécurité et quand même
assez détendu à ces calmes donc il y a
pas de nervosité sauf évidemment à
certains endroits s'il y a tout à coup
un problème alors là apparemment il y a
eu par exemple vous savez il y avait il
y a des protestataires du des
anti-monarchistes du mouvement
République notamment qui ont protesté et
le leader Graham Smith que j'avais vu il
y a 15 jours aurait été arrêté bon voilà
mais
sinon il n'y a pas cette espèce de
tension peut-être qu'on peut voir dans
d'autres pays ils font ça de manière
assez j'allais dire relax si vous me
permettez le mot donc voilà
des questions on a très peu parlé des
questions people je me tourne vers Sarah
un peu il va quand même y avoir des un
sujet aujourd'hui avec le prince Harry
qui sera là sans être là il est là bien
sûr et sans Meghan Markle qui a décidé
de ne pas venir voilà qui est sûrement
un soulagement d'ailleurs pour la
famille britannique elle était venue au
funérailles de la reine en septembre
dernier mais là elle a décidé de se
mettre en retrait et bien sûr ça va
alimenter les journaux people la presse
les tabloïdes britanniques qui raffolent
de ces histoires intra-familiales
est-ce que ça intéresse les Britanniques
peut-être cette question people autour
de la venue du prince Harry et avec un
autre mouton noir le prince Andrew
également c'est ça
oui bah alors oui comme disait Sarah ça
intéresse toujours c'est ces histoires
et à risque un vrai feuilleton qui
évidemment est une manne pour le pour
les tabloïdes et d'ailleurs qui sont
pour certains en guerre avec Harry et
Megane et il y a eu cette évidemment ce
froid et énorme créé par le à la fois le
dire cette double rafale tirée par les
le couple Sussex avec le la biographie
évidemment le suppléant la biographie
d'Harry et puis aussi les documentaires
Netflix donc depuis évidemment ça se
passe moyennement bien parce que William
et camilia en ont pris pour leur gratte
Charles a été un peu plus épargné donc
il y a cette feuille de compromis qui a
été trouvé c'est-à-dire Harry vient
seulement je crois que Mégane indiquait
qu'elle restait ouvert en Californie
parce qu'il y avait l'anniversaire de
leur fils bon il est certain que c'était
mieux que méga ne soit pas là il était
quand même assez difficile d'imaginer
carry ne viennent pas alors évidemment
tout le monde va scruter savoir est-ce
qu'il est au quatrième au cinquième rang
grande question aussi est-ce qu'il va
enfin je n'ai pas moi la réponse encore
est-ce qu'il va apparaître ou non au
balcon tout à l'heure lors de la
traditionnelle séquence du balcon après
après les cérémonies le recours à
Buckingham le retour à Buckingham voilà
il y a tout ça Andrew allait me dire
c'est un peu réglé lui voudrait sans
arrêt il revient la charge il devait
revenir comme membre active de la
famille royale mais pour le moment
Charles vous pose une fin de nous
recevoir il y a même demandé de quitter
sa résidence de Windsor pour une
résidence plus plus modeste donc je
crois que la charge là dessus n'a pas du
tout envie de le remettre en scène
[Musique]
l'écart votre avis sur cette question
Harry n'est plus vraiment dans le
protocole dans l'entourage proche de la
famille royale c'est ça
il faut se rappeler qu'il est parti en
pleine pandémie avec son épouse pour les
États-Unis que
l'enfant archi est né aux États-Unis et
que c'est la première fois que pour un
souverain britannique régnant en arrière
petite enfant ne n'est pas en territoire
britannique et puis je vous dirais que
quand on pense à ça confession dans son
livre lorsqu'on consulte un
psychanalyste ou un psychiatre l'usage
en tout cas il n'est pas recommandé de
révéler au monde entier le résultat de
la consultation et donc s'il va
continuer à se plaindre je pense que
ça serait très mal pris au vu du succès
de ce livre dans le monde entier
suppléant parce que ça a été en
plusieurs fois il y a d'abord eu une
interview à la télé américaine voilà
chez alors il y a déjà une toute
première chez Oprah Winfrey quand ils
sont arrivés aux États-Unis et puis
récemment il y en a eu une à la
télévision britannique et à la
télévision américaine et il y a bien sûr
eu le livre qui a eu un succès
phénoménal dans le monde entier et
notamment en France un 200 000
exemplaires vendus chez Fayard ce qui a
un joli succès
maintenant il peut pas continuer à se
plaindre en permanence il y a un nouveau
livre qui sort Meghan Markle au vu de ce
succès prépare le sien comme ça
une spécialiste pas du divorce oui la
congédié d'accord
c'est vrai que du divorce la elle a
congédié son mari avec une simple lettre
bon quelquefois
ça m'avait ça m'avait intrigué et toi
une simple lettre bon et
je crois en voie de bagues aussi mais
c'est pas ça c'est une spécialiste elle
a fait sa carrière
toujours essayer de réussir d'ailleurs
dans le show-business
elle réussissait pas mal pas
extraordinairement
le mariage
évidemment lui a donné une stature
mondiale et là il continue et c'est elle
qui a emmené le prince Harry qui ne
semble pas avoir une très très forte
personnalité quand on voit qu'il raconte
le nombre de pauvres type en sandales
qu'il a tué en Afghanistan ça fait
vraiment ça fait vraiment pas digne d'un
officier britannique mais elle l'a
emmené dans ce business qui marche de
manière donc à l'américaine on fait le
plus d'argent possible avec la
télévision avec le livre avec l'édition
et donc c'est une firme c'est une firme
américaine qui est là pour faire de
l'argent c'est à dire pour ça qu'ils ont
quitté
le cadre de la monarchie britannique qui
est un peu austère un peu rigide pour
aller en Californie ou et où l'argent
est roi évidemment il leur train de vie
qui écoutent eux et ils ont une
bénéficient plus de vie et sans doute
plus confortable que le train de vie
qu'ils auraient eu en Angleterre mais là
effectivement on peut dire que Mégane
Markle a formidablement réussi Charles
regardez je vous l'avais annoncé un peu
tôt le voilà avec ça président de
la commission alors non alors président
de la commission il est président du
Conseil européen c'est la Commission
européenne qui sera également dans la BU
de Westminster on a toujours pas vu
arriver le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs Jean allez-y
j'ajoute que au moment des cérémonies du
Jubilé de diabète 2 beaucoup de gens au
Royaume-Uni avaient été choqué devant
une équipe de télévision suivi d'une
équipe de télévision pardon je vous
coupe genre Renault un commentaire sur
cette image quand même parce que
on peut dire que la première dame
française
alors il n'est pas effectivement en
jaquette mais je crois que c'était dans
le protocole enfin ils ont dit qu'on les
hommes pouvaient être en costume on peut
remarquer que la première dame française
est très élégante
donc les gants de je dirais de de bon
aloi
et je pense que le Président de la
République
à raison il était pas obligé il aurait
pu envoyer
sa première ministre ou ministre
d'affaires étrangères
mais
je pense que président de la République
est conscient qu'il faut essayer de
consolider le lien avec l'Angleterre on
a
perdu ce lien économique de la faute des
Anglais pas du tout de notre faute avec
le brexit mais il reste la coopération
en matière de défense qui est très
importante il faut savoir que bien que
l'Angleterre soit partie du Marché
Commun de la de l'Union européenne
l'Angleterre est notre principal
partenaire en matière de défense sont
les accords de Lancaster House qui ont
été signés par Nicolas Sarkozy et par le
Premier ministre Cameron qui fait que
les Anglais et les Français ont des
unités d'intervention ensemble ont une
coopération même sur le plan nucléaire
extrêmement proche
le principal partenaire
en matière de défense et malgré les
crasses qui ont pu être faites à la
France je pense par exemple la locus
c'est à dire discuter dans le dos de la
France
c'est cet accord entre les Anglais les
Australiens les Américains derrière le
dos sans prévenir Emmanuel Macron sur
pour la livraison de sous-marins à
l'Australie oui la France avait signé un
contrat de sous-marin avec l'Australie
et puis ce qu'on parle de prévenir
Macron du tout il a appris par la presse
ils ont fait un autre accord derrière
son dos ce qui était vraiment
une élégant vraiment une élégant ma
matière de relation et inamicale même je
dirais en matière de relation
internationale mais
le naval Group a été indemnisé Macron a
pardonné et
ben Emmanuel Macron conscient de
l'intérêt à long terme de la France et
l'intérêt long terme de la France est
continué à être une alliée en termes de
défense avec avec la Grande-Bretagne on
va les meilleures relations avec la
Grande-Bretagne et c'est pour ça qu'il a
fait l'effort de venir et je pense qu'il
a eu raison
je vous ai coupé j'en décarres
tiens oui allez-y non non je suis
absolument d'accord avec ce que Renault
vient de dire je trouve que
c'est un spectacle exceptionnel et c'est
ça qui fascine le monde le côté pionnier
d'Elizabeth II de extraordinaire
vraiment
la télévision qui lui permet je le
répète de devenir la reine de l'image
jusqu'au bout dans des endroits très
reculés quand il y avait des téléviseurs
que quand quelques cafés quelques hôtels
enfin c'est extraordinaire la façon dont
Elisabeth II avait accompagné à la fois
la tradition et tous les changements je
veux dire c'est la même personne qui
impose la télévision qui décore les
Beatles et qui s'amusent que Marie
couinte raccourcisse les jupes dans le
Swinging London des années 60 c'est
assez formidable comme ouverture
d'esprit
sur la tasse avec la cuillère
de la cérémonie d'ouverture des JO en
2012 à Londres et que personne n'était
au courant
est extraordinaire cette famille royale
elle s'est récente moderne en tout cas
ceux qui sont présents aujourd'hui ils
se sont construits façonnés autour de la
télé et des médias et bien sûr dès qu'il
y a des fiançailles une naissance et
bien il s'affiche devant les caméras on
le sait on connaît cette image devant
les maternités Diana fait Kate Middleton
il présente et bien le futur roi et bien
sûr ses frères et sœurs au monde entier
il y a une dimension sacrée genre on en
a pas parlé dans ce dans ce couronnement
il y a une dimension sacrée ah oui il y
a une dimension sacrée alors il y a
quelque chose qu'il faut préciser c'est
que le l'huile du sacre et quelque chose
d'important ce sacreme dont seront moins
le roi Charles III et la reine Kamiya
est une un exemple extraordinaire
tradition disons qu'il y a un pharmacien
qui est aussi un pasteur en retraite qui
s'appelle Mark rutton qui a préparé
depuis plus de six mois l'huile du sacre
selon une recette qui remonte au XVIIe
siècle et depuis le 2 juin 1953 c'est à
dire depuis le sac elle couronnement
d'isabeth II le reliquat de cette huile
sacrée était conservée dans un simple
flacon de parfum entreposés dans une
boîte et cacher soigneusement dans
l'abbaye de Westminster alors le sacrem
je le rappelle remonte au début de la
chrétienté c'est un mélange d'huile
d'olive de Myr de sésame de rose de
jasmin et cette huile d'olive a été
pressée à Bethléem lieu de naissance de
Christ et les olives qui rentrent dans
sa composition viennent de deux Olivet
du mont des Oliviers monastères de
l'Ascension et église
Sainte-Marie-Madeleine et ça c'est très
important parce que c'est un hommage à
l'héritage orthodoxe du père de Charles
III le prince Philippe qui était né
prince de Grèce un corps fou en 1921 et
qui était de religion orthodoxe il avait
été contraint de se convertir évidemment
au protestantisme pour épouser Elisabeth
mais il était resté jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie en avril 2021 très attaché à la
religion orthodoxe et sa mère la
princesse sadis de Grèce était devenue
religieuse orthodoxe elle avait fondé
une religion une congrégation religieuse
orthodoxe elle avait aussi sauvé de
nombreux Juifs pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale elle repose au monastère
du monde des oliviers et elle a
profondément ouvert Charles maintenant
Charles III je dirais
au monde et qui s'est rendu sur la tombe
de sa grand-mère paternelle en janvier
2020 et on peut dire que c'est un lien
personnel du de Charles III avec
l'orthodoxie rappelant qu'il s'est rendu
au mont Atos et tout de même le reste de
l'Empire de Byzance cette religion
orthodoxe qui était toujours fascinante
et qui abrite plusieurs monastères dans
cette huile
va être conservé dans un au mois de mars
dans la fameuse ampoule du sac en forme
d'aigle d'or aux ailes déployées et ça
s'inspire d'une légende selon laquelle
la Vierge Marie serait apparue Thomas
Beckett le célèbre Opel anglais que
c'était opposé en roi Henri II
d'Angleterre il y a quelque chose
extraordinaire dans ces traditions des
siècles face aux modernisme si vous
voulez de la présentation par la
télévision
il y a en fait effectivement il y a la
gloire la para la parat le sacré le
sacré le 5ème pour le chef d'État pour
le roi alors que en France
le chef d'État
à la fois
incarne le pays
et sa stabilité et son unité et le
pouvoir politique au jour le jour et
donc c'est une grande différence et ces
différences se marquent
par l'homme qui a le pouvoir en
Angleterre c'est le premier ministre
vous avez vu il a une il a une maison
assez modeste le disturning
on peut faire des conférences des
grandes on a l'impression que c'est une
rue comme les autres ils sortent dans la
rue et parle dans la rue en fait ce sont
les escaliers voilà voilà exactement et
ça c'est exprès c'est parce que tout
l'apparent et la gloire doit rester avec
le monarque qui a donc et qui en plus la
dimension sacrée à l'occasion de ce
couronnement il faut rappeler que le
monarque britannique et chef de l'Église
anglicane oui voilà pas de séparation de
l'Église et de l'État en Angleterre
comme comme chez nous et et et mais un
pouvoir qui est beaucoup plus modeste
nous nous sommes un peu si vous voulez
entre les deux c'est à dire un
Emmanuel Macron qui est le chef d'État
qui peut
vous en parler Renaud vous collez aux
images politiques qui est en train de
s'installer dans l'abbaye de de
Westminster aux côtés de Brigitte Macron
nous ne savons pas exactement à quel
rang il est c'est très important le
placement dans cette abbaye de
Westminster Jean Jean descart alors on
parle de cette religion et Renault vient
de le préciser
Charles III le chef de l'Église mais
quand une petite nuance on va essayer
d'ouvrir cette cérémonie à d'autres
religions oui et ça fait partie des de
l'état d'esprit du roi Charles III qui
s'est énormément informé sur toutes les
religions du monde tous les courants
spirituels et qui tenaient à ce que des
représentants de ces religions soient
présentes alors on connaît l'importance
si vous voulez des religions de l'Inde
de l'islam etc dans ce qui a été composé
l'Empire britannique notamment donc je
trouve que c'est une volonté de
rassemblement assez formidable en même
temps quelque chose d'important à la fin
de la cérémonie les dirigeants de chaque
religion
viendront saluer le roi
il y a aussi on peut dire que le fait ça
va être une révolution qu'il ne veut pas
vivre à Buckingham ça sera son bureau il
voudrait continuer à vivre avec
clarensaus ça vous le voyez pendant
qu'on en parle vous voyez c'est
dirigeant des autres religions qui
s'avancent dans Westminster il a
toujours été très ouvert et tous ces
voyages ses lectures
se sont tournés vers cette
connaissance des autres c'est une des
grandes qualités de du nouveau souverain
Sarah c'est important pour le royaume
pour le roi de coller à ces sujets c'est
ça d'essayer de d'être en phase avec eux
ça c'est une question d'image ils en ont
besoin bien sûr pour odorer l'image faut
rappeler la popularité aussi de Charles
à l'instant où on parle bien sûr dès
l'instant où ça où sa mère est morte
elle a grimpé effectivement puisqu'il
est devenu roi et il reste en dessous de
celle de et William il est plus
populaires de la famille britannique au
Royaume-Uni en plus
dans l'ordre 80% d'opinion favorable
pour Elisabeth bon voilà ensuite vient
la princesse Anne la princesse royale
est très populaire et elle est très
proche de son frère et c'est un élément
important peut-être important pour lui
et ensuite donc qui a été William avant
lui à 55% d'opinion favorables le roi
Charles III il y a eu une image forte
cette semaine avec qui était William
qu'ils ont ils ont pris le métro La
Elisabeth line pour se rendre dans un
pub et le prince William c'est lui-même
service à bière enfin voilà ça fait
partie aussi de toute cette
communication autour de la famille
royale et ça contribue à renforcer cette
popularité auprès des Britanniques
Elisabeth line dont la reine Elizabeth
II avait supervisé les travaux elle
était descendue dans le chantier très
profond dans le sous-sol de Londres avec
une robe qui était assortie à la tenue
des ouvriers
heures et deux minutes nous sommes en
direct pour suivre le couronnement du
roi Charles III vous voyez arriver les
principaux dirigeants les invités
dans cette abbaye de Westminster le roi
qui doit s'élancer de Buckingham en
direction de Westminster dans 17 minutes
maintenant ce sera le premier grand
moment le moment fort de ceux de ce
couronnement est-ce que c'est pas un peu
anachronique chronogirard ce qu'on va
voir là pendant près de deux heures
c'est totalement
la chronique ce n'est pas du tout
dans l'esprit moderne où on essaie de
lisser les différences ou
l'individualisme prime sur tout le reste
là il y a pardon Renaud je vous coupe
parce que c'est une image importante
arrivée d'un d'un carrosse alors il va y
en avoir deux des carrosses celui-ci
c'est le c'est le le moderne le Diamond
et parce que le cheval existait
évidemment
du temps de Guillaume le Conquérant qui
a conquis l'Angleterre
à cheval on avait mis des chevaux sur
les drakars les bateaux qui sont allés
sont partis de Saint-Valery-sur-Somme
pour aller donc conquérir l'Angleterre
et ça marque la tradition ça marque ça
marque si vous voulez
Milan sur des Carla dit
Milan de monarchie britannique et de
couronnement à Westminster aucun pays au
monde n'a cette tradition n'a cette
stabilité institutionnelle alors il y a
eu des coups de canifs il y a eu
Cromwell aussi ils ont avant nous
d'ailleurs ils ont décapité leur roi il
y a eu des révolutions etc mais c'est
quand même un régime et un régime
parlementaire qui remonte à Jean sans
Terre donc à 1215 par là
c'est montrer que c'est le plus vieil la
plus vieille organisation politique du
monde encore vivante et ça ça peut être
et la plus vieille aussi démocratie
démocratie du monde puisque le Parlement
est le plus ancien du monde et donc
c'est aussi un motif un moyen un
instrument d'influence et je pense que
le gouvernement le parti au pouvoir qui
est le Parti conservateur en est tout à
fait conscient d'utiliser cet instrument
d'influence dans le monde après que les
Anglais ont perdu de leur faute et de la
faute il faut le dire du Parti
conservateur et de Cameron en
particulier après que les Anglais ont
perdu l'influence énorme qu'ils avaient
au sein de l'Union européenne puisque
en fait dans l'Union européenne
l'anglais
avait dès le début des années 2000
remplacer le français comme langue de
travail et d'ailleurs c'est resté
aujourd'hui les Anglais ne sont plus
dans l'Union européenne mais l'anglais
reste la langue de travail donc ils
avaient une influence énorme
auxquelles ils ont renoncé de manière un
peu incompréhensible
et donc il n'y a plus d'influence
vraiment
au sein de l'Europe continentale mais
ils veulent garder une influence par
leur prestige par la force de leurs
institutions par leur ancienneté par ce
spectacle par cet appareil par cet
apparat ils veulent garder une influence
mondiale et évidemment qu'une cérémonie
comme cela c'est les regarder par 2
milliards de personnes même si c'est un
milliard et demi contribua à contribuera
à renforcer l'influence
britannique dans le monde je vous
rappelle que nous sommes en direct et
que nous suivons l'installation pour
l'instant des invités dans l'abbaye de
nous avons vu ces derniers instants des
personnalités politiques manuel Macron
notamment accompagné sa femme Brigitte
on a vu également Jill Biden la première
dame américaine qui n'est pas
accompagnée de son mari Joe Biden on a
vu des personnalités des chanteurs des
chanteuses Sarah alors il y a un concert
parce qu'il n'y a pas que le
couronnement lui-même il y a un concert
demain soir demain soir dans les jardins
de Winsor pour pour fêter ce
couronnement et alors il faut le dire
Charles pardonnez-moi l'expression mais
il s'est pris quelques râteaux pour ce
concert parce qu'il y aura aucun artiste
britannique sur la scène
Adèle Ed Sheeran harry Styles Robbie
Williams Kylie Minogue toutes ces
personnalités ont refusé et même Elton
John alors Elton John officiellement ne
veut pas interrompre sa tournée
européenne officieusement il est c'est
un proche d'Harry et Mégane donc il a
choisi son camp donc c'est pour ça qu'il
ne sera pas
là et les autres ils sont soit entourées
c'est le cas d'Adèle qui était à Las
Vegas à la Résidence là-bas bon elle
aurait pu l'interrompre après tout
harry Styles étant vacances avant sa
tournée mondiale voilà personne n'a
voulu faire le déplacement la société
moderne c'est l'argent c'est
vous avez raison là
j'ai mes rendez-vous c'est
l'individualisme roi l'argent roi
parce que des Américains ont cachetonné
demain Katy Perry Lionel Richie qui ont
eux accepté de venir et il y aura texac
le groupe britannique a révélé Robbie
Williams mais sans Robbie Williams
et les Spice Girls ont refusé de se
reformer pourtant ça avait fait grandir
quand elles avaient rencontré Charles il
y a quelques années puisque elles
avaient transgressé l'étiquette en
faisant une bise au prince Charles et ça
avait fait beaucoup de bruit dans la
presse
on connaît pas non le montant de
un cachet tous pour
vous êtes voilou est-ce que ça fait
polémique pourquoi les artistes
britanniques ne veulent pas participer à
ce concert en hommage au roi Charles III
alors là j'avoue que j'ai pas tellement
de lumière sur ce volet là bon je pense
que ce concert oui en effet c'est un peu
surprenant parce que l'événement
l'événement est de taille voilà donc ça
fait un petit peu bizarre quand on voit
le casting après je pense que ce concert
de manière ce qui sera important ça sera
aussi un moment d'émotion certainement
parce que William je crois de rendra un
hommage à son père et ça c'est un moment
assez attendu je sais pas quel moment du
concert ça sera donc toute manière ça se
veut quand même une fête aussi populaire
donc voilà mais après
ce qui est étonnant si vous voulez c'est
ce que ce qu'on disait un peu tout à
l'heure c'est que à la fois il y a un
engouement pour cette monarchie mais on
sent bien aussi qu'il y a une question
générationnelle on voit bien que que
chez les jeunes évidemment il y a
beaucoup moins d'adhésion après les
jeunes peuvent vieillir et tout à coup
se trouvait plus enclin à célébrer la
monarchie mais donc c'est le grand défi
aujourd'hui pour cette monarchie c'est
ce moderniser et et rassembler au-delà
encore une fois des des générations et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que je
crois que ces gens d'écart qui en
parlaient tout à l'heure les anglais
sont très très forts pour ça ils ont un
souci et là dans tout ce qu'on va voir
là dans les deux trois heures qui vont
suivre dans le souci du détail des
symboles ils font passer des messages ça
a été évoqué les messages sur le côté
multiconfessionnel maintenant la
Grande-Bretagne donc avec ces dignités
religieux qui sont invités pour la
première fois pour la première fois
aussi et bien des textes vont être plus
en écossais gaélique en irlandais
gaélique en gallois et là aussi la
monarchie va envoyer des messages à tout
le royaume pour pour montrer peau pour
servir l'unité du royaume dont on sait
qu'elle est un peu un peu malmenée de la
même façon Charles a voulu qu'il y ait
moins de l'ordre ou de dignitaires ou de
pairs associés à cette cérémonie et plus
de gens de la société civile donc il y a
il y a cette volonté de de modernisation
tout en s'inscrivant évidemment dans une
continuité très forte comme les images
le montre et donc on est on est entre le
entre l'anachronisme et puis une volonté
quand même de se tourner vers 21e siècle
même si certains pensent que évidemment
c'est plutôt William qui qui modernisera
cette monarchie et que Charles est de ne
pas non plus la révolutionner même sa
sœur la princesse Anne que vous avez
écrit tout à l'heure a dit ça une
télévision canadienne il y a quelques
jours elle a dit je n'attends pas de
gros changements de durant le règne de
Charles
et on regarde en même temps ces images
de ce carrosse le Diamond jubilé state
coach qui transportera le roi vers
Westminster pour la procession du roi et
le retour ce sera la procession du
couronnement ce sera dans un autre
carrosse on va tout vous expliquer
visiblement ce carrosse se prépare
peut-être que le roi est déjà monté
dedans on n'a pas bien vu à travers les
vitres Arnaud il y a quand même une
polémique malgré tous les efforts du roi
visiblement pour
apporter plus de sobriété dans ce
couronnement il coûte cher ce cet
événement ou pas
oui alors il y a une polémique c'est
vrai qu'il y a cette volonté évidemment
le roi et le Palais a pris un prix acte
de la crise du bout de la vie qui est
ici donc il y a une volonté de réduire
les coûts il n'y a que par exemple que
8000 invités dans la vie aujourd'hui et
pas 200300 ils ont dit qu'ils
réutilisaient des vêtements utilisés
lors d'autres cérémonies enfin il y a
des tas de choses comme ça il y a quand
même une polémique le coût est estimé
entre 50 millions de livres et 100
millions de livres c'est pas Buckingham
c'est engagé à donner la somme plus tard
donc il y a évidemment des gens qui
disent mais c'est beaucoup trop cher
pour un seul homme et un seul jour mais
le palais fait remarquer qu'il y a aussi
tout un coup de pouce économique qui est
donné au pays on sait par exemple que
les pubs attendent 150 millions de
chiffre d'affaires parce qu'ils vont ils
sont autorisés à à rester ouvert plus
tard l'industrie hôtelière prévoit un
milliard peut-être de rentrer donc il y
a évidemment le coût de ces événements
mais il y a aussi ce qui rapporte en
terme d'image et de retomber économique
pour le pays
Arnaud pendant que vous parlez une fois
de plus ces images qui arrivent nos
Girard les anciens premiers ministres
britanniques je vois Cameron
blairson non on ne voit pas Boris
Johnson
l'illustrate d'ailleurs Nelly stress
je ne sais pas si Theresa mais bon alors
en tout cas il y en a quelques-uns je le
dirai si vous le permettez que
l'archevêque a de la concurrence côté
couvre-chef oui c'est vrai
je vais vous proposer de retourner à
Londres à Londres avec Timothée delaime
et
son temps
qui vient de on voit vous voyez Charles
oui le voilà tiens le Boris Johnson et
le stress c'est derrière lui il me
semble-t-il lui il n'est pas en
redingote bonheur
est en redingote
[Musique]
on reste avec ces images c'est le
Morning Jacket en fait il est toujours
un peu avec la voyez le col de chemise
qui dépasse sur la ligne c'est du Boris
Johnson dans le texte on reste avec ces
images mais on va faire un tour à
Londres Timothée delhem est-ce que
l'ambiance monte parce que d'ici 5
minutes le cortège s'élancera ce fameux
carrosse avec le roi à l'intérieur on
l'a vu entrer dans le dans le carrosse
le cortège c'est l'entrée il passera pas
loin de vous visiblement
ouais tout à fait Thibault a quelques
mètres juste derrière moi vous voyez
cette foule qui est qui s'amasse en fait
contre les les barrières les barrières
de cette de cette artère que et bien
Charles III va emprunter d'ici quelques
minutes maintenant avec évidemment la
reine concert Camila et puis les autres
membres de la famille royale qui
suivront départ 11h20 heure française
10h20 anglaise de ce cortège parce qu'il
y a évidemment une heure de de décalage
horaire ici à Londres et vous me
demandiez bien si l'ambiance était en
train de monter c'est en train
effectivement de monter petit à petit
avec les premières houras qui commence à
se faire entendre tout à l'heure voilà
peut-être y a-t-il eu certaines
personnes qui sont passées sur la route
c'est vrai que les anglais sont plutôt
de bonne humeur alors on voyait par
exemple hier lorsque des toilettes
publiques et bien été
était en train d'être disposé le long de
la route et bien il y avait des hourras
voilà qui s'est levé de la de la foule
lorsque également les policiers
passaient bien des hourra également qui
s'est levé donc voilà une une bonne
humeur une bonne ambiance ici qui se
ressent assez nettement même si je vous
le disais tout à l'heure la pluie
également tombe sur les rues de Londres
une pluie assez fine donc voilà pour le
moment en tout cas elle l'a pas et bien
altérer les les ardeurs des Londoniens
l'ambiance qui commence à monter et on
attend ici deux pieds fermes le roi
Charles III qui doit arriver d'ici
quelques minutes il va passer il va
traverser cette cette place travelgar et
ensuite se rendre traverser le le
quartier whitef all vous savez c'est le
le quartier des ministères qui se trouve
donc juste derrière moi pour arriver sur
cette sur cette abbaye de Westminster
oui c'est ça dont le chef d'État
va être Charles III donc les pays du
commonweez vous avez vu passer le voilà
Jamaïque vous avez la Nouvelle-Zélande
qui arrive et
on a eu l'Australie le camélia
je sais pas les connaissait mieux ça je
pense que c'est la Nouvelle-Zélande avec
des étoiles
temps idéal à Londres temps idéal pour
un couronnement il pleut ne vous
plaignez pas Timothée Timothée
car vous me disiez tout à l'heure avant
qu'on prenne l'antenne que vous avez
rencontré il y a 40 ans ce prince
Charles qui est-il Charles vraiment bah
écoutez déjà pour rappeler des
circonstances
j'apprends qu'il venait en France avec
leurs marnes button pour rendre hommage
à la mémoire de pilote de la Royal Air
Force qui s'était caché après avoir été
obligé de vous couper ici snack le
Premier ministre actuel du du
Royaume-Uni est en train d'entrer dans
l'abbaye Westminster je vous laisse
continuer on parliez de Charles et donc
il vient avec leur demande button dans
un train spécial la gare du Nord etc et
moi je dis à la conférence de rédaction
à louer Powell c'est si on demandait un
entretien au prince de garde c'était
avant son mariage avec Diana mais elle
était déjà dans le paysage et tout le
monde me dit mais vous êtes fous
faudrait l'autorisation de la reine du
cabinet du premier ministre enfin tas de
choses j'ai fait une chose très simple
j'ai pris la meilleure téléphonique de
Londres j'ai appelé Buckingham Palace
par l'Anglais j'ai demandé à parler à
son officier de presse j'ai eu pas
demandé à parler à la reine directement
non j'ai eu affaire à un Australien qui
avait un accent un peu de crocodile et
qui m'a dit très gentiment d'envoyer mon
passeport par fax et mes questions et 24
heures après j'avais la réponse vous
êtes attendu tel jour et je suis parti
avec le photographe François Angèle
excusez-moi vous corriger vous étiez pas
avec Mao de Battle parce que bon battle
a été assassiné en 1970 par l'IRA par
les indépendantistes irlandais donc ça
devait être quelqu'un d'autre que Maud
battle parce qu'il était mort
1970 et là vous parlez juste avant le
mariage avec avec je veux dire on
parlait déjà de Camilla c'est une de
Diana il n'était pas marié non non en
1970 si vous voulez
donc on a pas parlé du mariage de
Charles 12 ans 11 ans avant son mariage
mais ça devait être l'autre une autre
personnalité militaire
et donc
il est accueilli d'une façon charmante
et puis on commence l'entretien et voilà
pour résumer que les Balkars les
projecteurs tombent en panne mon
magnétophone à cassette fait des
confettis j'ai envie de jeter le
photographe et les techniciens dans la
tour de Londres le prince Charles me dit
que vous avez un problème monsieur
lecard j'ai dit mon Seigneur c'est
à la fois asincourt et Waterloo pas
musée il me dit est-ce que c'est du
matériel français j'ai eu dit non
Monseigneur tout est japonais alors il
me dit très gentiment ah mais alors
l'honneur est sauf ça m'aurait dit le
roi François 1er a pas vu et le miracle
est arrivé que le laboratoire du Figaro
Magazine a réussi à sortir une double
page où j'arrange ma cravate ou je suis
pas vraiment bien mais ce qui compte
c'est que Charles soit très bien et
personne n'a cru mon cher Renaud y
compris Hélène de Turckheim à l'époque
que j'avais simplement téléphoné avec
une gamme et est-ce qu'il parlait bien
français alors très bien avec un accent
charmant et j'ai rencontré sa mère
Elisabeth fallait bien français
oui vous avez raison de le préciser on
va mettre ces images en plein écran on
va enlever nos bobines parce que la
seule qui compte désormais c'est celle
du roi Charles III qui s'élance donc
de Buckingham Palace escorté de
c'est militaire qui vont l'encadrer
devant derrière dans ce Diamond jubilé
state coach on reste avec ces images et
on écoute Timothée delaime vous êtes
avec Amaury racontez-nous autour de vous
pendant que nous voyons le carrosse du
roi Charles III sortir de Buckingham
Palace
[Applaudissements]
oui Tibo le carrosse qui sort de
Buckingham Palace quelques centaines de
mètres d'ici vous entendez également les
cloches des églises qui sonnent pour ce
début de cortège ici on attend
impatiemment l'arrivée du roi certains
l'attendent impatiemment pour la clamer
d'autres et bien n'ont pas hâte de le
voir en tout cas ils sont pas forcément
favorables à à son couronnement on a
croisé Amaury des militants républicains
not my King pas mon roi aboliche de
monarchie également c'est banderoles à
bollir la monarchie vous avez pu
discuter avec eux vous pouvez aussi
également que vous ont-ils dit à Maury
effectivement on peut les voir ils sont
derrière nous hein placés dans le
l'emplacement juste derrière là ce qu'il
regrette c'est une monarchie qu'il juge
injuste et d'ailleurs la première chose
qui qu'ils m'ont dit lorsque j'ai
expliqué que j'étais français c'est il
faut s'inspirer des Français cette
monarchie ne nous représente pas leur
argument c'est évidemment le coût que
représente la monarchie et le coup que
représente le couronnement alors que le
roi va passer on entend d'ailleurs les
acclamations derrière nous alors que et
le coût de la vie est très important
j'ai discuté également avec Bryan qui a
qui est venu du Kent à quelques heures
de Londres qui est venu pour
regretter qu'il y a une monarchie en
France on sait que le sentiment
républicain progresse notamment chez les
jeunes est-ce que ce sentiment
républicain est amplifié par la figure
de Charles III qui fait peut-être moins
l'unanimité que que celle de sa mère et
les abeilles 2 est-ce que vous avez ils
vous ont répondu également sur ce sur
cette question effectivement c'était
d'ailleurs l'un des premiers arguments
la reine était une figure tutélaire elle
a toujours été là c'est ce que m'ont dit
en tout cas les républicains alors que
Charles III il pense que c'est le moment
de passer à autre chose il regrette au
fond cette figure de Charles III tout en
espérant pas la figure de William ce qui
est le cas d'un certain nombre de
personnes même anarchistes qui sont ici
merci Amaury voilà le le carrosse qui
qui est en train d'arriver on entend la
les applaudissements nourris et les
cloches qui sautent de plus en plus fort
ici dans les dans les rues de Londres le
cortège qui va passer sur cette place
Trafalgar et si quelques secondes
2 km et
290 m entre Buckingham et l'abbaye de
Westminster genre Descartes quand vous
voyez ces images
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
alors écoutez je trouve ça très émouvant
le dire aussi qu'il y a une petite
touche comment dirais-je française
une attendue un cheval qui avait été
offert par le Président de la République
pour le jubilé enfin de la reine pour
son anniversaire un cheval qui s'appelle
fabuleux de Maucourt
avait été offert donc par le président
français c'est un cheval de la Garde
républicaine
et le ce cheval sera dans la cérémonie à
quel endroit exactement je ne sais mais
je trouve ça très sympathique il sera
sans doute à côté d'un des patrons des
maîtres d'équipage de cette cavalerie
voilà le carrosse
se plaignait
en 2014 pour le jubilé de diamant alors
il a des
des options assez intéressantes caméra à
360 degrés pour ne rien manquer de la
procession vitre électrique
climatisation et suspension hydraulique
ça c'est pour le confort
il y a du luxe vraiment dans les dans
les détails une couronne au sommet du
carrosse cultée dans une pièce de bois
voilà toutes ces dorures sur ce carrosse
extrêmement moderne même les poignées de
porte elles sont ornées de 24 diamants
et 130 saphir il y a même elle recèle il
recèle ce carrosse également d'un
contrepoid de l'horloge de Big Ben et
des fragments d'avion de chasse Spitfire
et Hurricane à propos de la guerre de 40
je crois que j'en décale est tout à fait
raison avec ce symbole du cheval offert
par le Président de la République
puisque la France était tellement
éternellement reconnaissante à l'accueil
qui a fait l'Angleterre c'était
Churchill en l'occurrence à la France
libre au général de Gaulle en lui
donnant immédiatement des locaux des
moyens des finances pour agir et la
famille royale britannique elle-même
participant accueillant les Français
libres et participants d'ailleurs au 1er
défilé des Français Libres le 14 juillet
donc
une reconnaissance
en fait éternelle il y a d'ailleurs une
sculpture de général de Gaulle à
l'intérieur même au centre même de
Londres une reconnaissance éternelle
à l'Angleterre d'avoir accueilli la
France Libre aussi généreusement il faut
voir que les États-Unis ont attendu
septembre 1944 pour reconnaître le
général de Gaulle
voilà ces images sur le mal
et la procession du roi voilà ce n'est
pas encore la procession du couronnement
faisait son du couronnement ce sera au
retour
procession raccourcis j'en décarres
parce que il n'y a que deux kilomètres à
l'époque lors de
du couronnement de la reine elle avait
fait le tour de Londres 8 km il fallait
la montrer au londonien aujourd'hui avec
les écrans il y a plus besoin
de tradition et de modernité qui est
très britannique je dirais dans le fond
c'est un c'est un résumant un résumé de
ce tempérament très ouvert et en même
temps attaché à des traditions voilà je
salue florentin Colomb qui vient de me
rejoindre sur ce plateau journaliste
service économie mais surtout ancien
correspondant à Londres pour le pour Le
Figaro tiens vous qui êtes resté pendant
plusieurs années à Londres
une émotion un sentiment qu'est-ce que
ça vous fait de voir ces images
florentin c'est le la grande tradition
de la monarchie britannique avec le
faste là peut-être à son paroxysme
puisque des couronnements il y en a pas
tous les 15 jours non 70 ans oui j'ai
vécu plusieurs événements au royaume le
mariage du Prince William des Jubilés
les funérailles de la reine et les
abeilles donc ce genre d'événements où
on voit Londres complètement pavoisé des
gens dehors la garde à cheval des
carottes etc c'est vraiment le
savoir-faire si on peut dire de la
monarchie britannique pour
monter des espèces de superproduction en
mondiovision qui qui projette un
sentiment de puissance et de glamour si
on peut dire de la monarchie britannique
qui connaissait bien l'ombre quel est le
parcours racontez-moi à la un pas c'est
un parcours très relativement court un
Buck Palace jusqu'à Westminster Abby
c'est très proche donc le parcours fait
une sorte de triangle il prend
traditionnellement cette avenue le mal
qui est l'avenue bordée d'arbres et le
long du de Saint-James et Spark en face
de Buckingham Palace que le cortège est
en train de remonter ensuite il arrive à
trafalgers square qui est l'une des
places centrales de Londres et puis il
tourne
et descend white roll pour arriver
jusqu'à Westminster high donc en tout ça
fait vous aviez la distance tout à
l'heure je sais pas deux kilomètres 280
ces images donc de ce carrosse le
Diamond jubilé state coach on va changer
de carrosse en cours de route pour le
retour ce ne sera pas le même ce sera un
carrosse ancestral dans lequel le roi
Charles et la reine Kamila tient on
couronne un roi mais en couronne une
reine et ça c'est une surprise mine de
rien ah bah c'est une relative nouveauté
bien sûr on avait couronné la Queen Mum
aussi le célèbre épouse de George VI
c'est très important parce que ça va
stabiliser un peu plus le couple royal
après tout ce que l'on a vécu tout ce
que l'on sait si vous voulez camilia qui
a été la femme la plus détestée la
méchante femme qui ne pouvait pas faire
ses courses sans être insulter par ses
voisines dans les supermarchés etc on a
été excessivement je trouve injuste avec
elle parce que quand on connaît c'est ce
que je me permets de rappeler dans mon
livre La
c'est pas tout à fait et bien qu'on
avait que la version de Diana à cette
époque maintenant on est un peu éclairé
sur la réalité c'est donc une revanche
formidable alors ce qu'on peut rappeler
parce que c'est tout de même assez
fantastique c'est que
l'arrière arrière-grand-père de Charles
avait eu une liaison avec l'arrière
grand-mère de
Camilla c'était même pas triste dans le
genre si vous voulez romance qui se
répète etc il y a est devenu après avoir
été la femme la plus méchante
l'épouse nécessaire c'est ce que
Elisabeth II a très bien compris et le 9
avril 2005 quand elle organise et
cautionne si je puis dire le mariage de
Charles et de camilia qui ont connu donc
des drames des divorces la mort de Diana
tout ce que l'on sait
elle les compare à des fier coursier
c'est un compliment de la part de
diabète de l'époque des chevaux de
compétition en disant ils ont couru à
steople Chase et ont eu beaucoup
d'épreuves mais d'ailleurs on peut
rajouter que c'était pas évident c'était
pas gagné d'avance parce que Camila
serait reine puisque pendant très
longtemps depuis son mariage avec
Charles on avait dit qu'elle pourrait
être qu'elle pour avoir le même statut
en somme que que le duc dédimbourg le
prince Philippe qui n'a jamais été
couronné ça ça remonte à un autre
usage dans la famille royale quand le
souverain est une femme son mari n'est
pas couronné roi pour éviter qu'il y ait
un risque qui lui fasse de l'ombre et on
pensait que vu le passif si on peut dire
de Camilla dans l'opinion britannique il
aurait été peut-être un peu
forcé de d'annoncer dès le départ
qu'elle serait la reine des des
Britanniques et donc pendant longtemps
on a maintenu
l'ambiguïté sur la question et c'est peu
avant sa mort que la reine Elizabeth a
décidé que Camilla serait reine consort
mais aujourd'hui on dit même tout
simplement la reine Kamiya
alors ce qu'on voit c'est ces images
est-ce que on se dit que la famille
royale est un soft power pour le
Royaume-Uni vous voyez ce que je veux
dire il y a pas vraiment ouais mais elle
influe elle
elle est partout aujourd'hui sur tous
les écrans du monde et donc le
Royaume-Uni est partout sur tous les
écrans du monde
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
un problème en Occident de société qui
se dissolvent plus ou moins ou qui se
divise ce problème en Europe même aux
États-Unis il faut adhérer à quelque
chose ensemble il faut on ne peut fonder
une société que sur une adhésion commune
et là ce que
témoigne on voit ses foule je ne sais
pas combien il y a de monde combien de
monde
derrière la télé mais c'est
l'adhésion si vous voulez à une histoire
glorieuse il faut le dire parce que
l'Angleterre est une soit glorieux
une adhésion
des principes Dieu et mon droit la loi
britannique l'église anglicable une
église comme le chef de l'Église
agricane est ouvert puisque il a vous
l'avez dit pour la première fois accepté
de recevoir les autres religions les
représentants des autres religions et
donc
évidemment c'est pas très grave c'est
pour ça que
c'était une
[Musique]
guerre sur le coup de la natation ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas des techniques
pertinentes
mais n'importe quoi
pardon on a député
sur place parce que le roi passe tout
proche de lui ah on vient de perdre
l'image on va la retrouver dans un
instant j'en suis sûr Timothée on va
venir vers vous avec vos images
racontez-moi le roi passe près de vous
oui tout à fait Thibault vous entendez
les hourra là qui commencent
sérieusement à bonté sur cette place
trafalgoire le roi et qui passe juste la
dans quelques mètres alors il est encore
d'ici quelques mètres pardon à quelques
mètres d'ici voilà je vais y arriver il
était encore un peu plus loin peut-être
est-il arrêté par la foule je n'ai pas
les les images que vous avez que vous
avez depuis Paris en tout cas les hourra
qui commence à monter sérieusement et si
vous le voulez bien je vois là j'allais
dire je vous rappelle quand il passe
vraiment ça y est c'est le cas vous
entendez les hurailles il semble qu'ils
soient à quelques mètres maintenant de
nous voilà et évidemment les portables
qui sont de sortie parce que les
Britanniques sont en train évidemment de
photographier ce moment historique de
prendre des films vous voyez certains
qui ont sorti le le costume avec l'Union
Jack le drapeau qui est là qui est
brandi et beaucoup d'acclamations au
moment où le roi Charles III s'apprête à
passer dans une ambiance vraiment
festive ici voilà on sent que certains
commencent à l'apercevoir et voilà
maintenant que les houras nouveau une
nouvelle salle de d'inclamation au
moment où je où je vous parle c'est tout
à fait imminent maintenant
je viens de récupérer les images on les
met à nouveau en plein écran ces images
du mouvement en plateau évidemment
alors que vous me confirmez florentin là
on passe ou alors c'est quoi le ou qui
connaissait bien long Londres à la oui
alors c'est vraiment on est sur trois
sur le car square c'est l'arrivée du mal
du mal le le haut de cette avenue donc
on a vu la procession a pris un certain
temps quand même pour parcourir je sais
pas 1 km 1 km oui à peine 1 km depuis
Buckingham Palace et là la procession
contourne tourne autour de Trafalgar
Square pour rentrer dans white hall qui
est la grande avenue où sont situés la
plupart des ministères britanniques et
redescendre on voit Big Ben au fond
en perspective donc le carrosse le
cortège va vers big ben puisque l'abbaye
de Westminster est situé un petit peu à
droite de Big Ben donc on a encore pour
quelques minutes enfin le roi est
attendu d'ici 25 minutes
11h52 bon une vingtaine
moins d'une vingtaine de minutes donc
pour parcourir ces quelques centaines de
mètres qui restent donc c'est vraiment
le lieu de toutes ces processions
officielles c'est là aussi qu'il y a le
cénota c'est à dire le mot monument aux
morts des des deux guerres mondiales
donc c'est le l'endroit de toutes les
cérémonies c'est là que dès que passe et
puis lorsqu'il y a des mariages ou des
événements des célébrations à
Westminster abbé les cortèges royaux
passent traditionnellement toujours par
là je salue Paul Thomson qui vient de
nous rejoindre bonjour Paul
vice-président du parti des
conservateurs britanniques à Paris je
demande toujours avant l'analyse le
sentiment lorsque vous voyez ces images
des merveillement je verrai et de fierté
aussi parce que ça représente déjà beau
donc il est en effet esthétique
indéniable et
le fait de
devoir un peuple rassemblé
et quelque chose de
très positif je trouve et ça repose sur
une très longue histoire ce qui ce qui
n'est pas rien donc il y a aussi un
sentiment de fierté qui
fait partie du de l'ensemble est-ce que
pour vous il y avait peut-être plus
d'habitude on se dit en tant que
Français on voit pas tout ça est-ce que
c'est anachronique ces images
pas du tout parce que
c'est une image importante pardon je
vous coupe l'arrivée du prince Harry
dans cette abbaye de Westminster c'est
forcément l'une des images les plus les
plus attendues de cette journée et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour saluer
Pascaline Podevin qui est chef de
service Culture à Madame Figaro
Pascaline je vous interroge tout de
suite parce que ce couronnement c'est
aussi un moment people là c'est une
image importante l'arrivée de William de
Harry pardon alors l'arrivée de Harry
oui que je vois alors l'arrivée de Harry
effectivement c'est une image très
importante parce que le prince Harry
c'est un peu le paria de ce couronnement
c'est le parieur de la famille royale
depuis qu'il a en 2020
on pourrait dire avec la famille royale
suite au Mexique quand il est parti
s'installer aux États-Unis avec sa femme
mega Markle mais surtout il y a eu
depuis les révélations qu'il a faites
dans son livre de mémoire le suppléant
qui ont été assez accablantes pour la
famille royale davantage pour le prince
William que pour le prince Charles mais
du coup il vient il ne vient paraît-il
que 24 heures en Angleterre il ne sera
que 24 heures sur le sol britannique
pardon il va être relégué au troisième
rang
3e même plus loin alors on pensait 10 ce
matin le Daily Mail je crois à parler du
troisième rang apparemment il est
possible qu'il n'apparaisse pas sur les
photos officielles qui ne soient pas sur
le balcon tout à l'heure lorsque la
famille royale va saluer la foule donc
voilà c'est vraiment c'est quand même le
fils cadet du roi il se devait d'être là
mais il est la seule sans sa femme sans
ses enfants
vraiment avec un rôle dans l'ombre
il est arrivé seul évidemment et moins
protocolaire que les autres après il
était encadré de ses cousines j'étais
Béatrice qui était toutes les deux avec
leur conjoint toutes les deux avec leurs
conjoint et lui marchait seul et c'est
vrai que rien que ça le fait qu'il
marche seul pour entrer dans cette
cérémonie quand même très officielle il
a pas eu il a pas militaire
mais on le voit marcher seul et même et
se les puisque sa femme est restée chez
lui et c'est ça ça dit quelque chose
évidemment cette image ça montre qu'il
n'est pas intégrée dans le dispositif
royal à part entière si vous voulez
puisqu'il vient mais c'est lui qui l'a
décidé hein elle aurait eu sa place son
épaisse
donc donc une image oui en effet qui
restera et qui montre ce statut que vous
avez décrit ouais pas le Thompson est-ce
que les Britanniques aujourd'hui
attendaient cette image
je pense qu'ils étaient au courant que
il serait là et que il serait là sans
son épouse et son attitude sera scrutée
est-ce qu'on va particulièrement faire
attention à son comportement où il sera
placé est-ce que ça intéresse les
Britanniques
à la marge oui mais ce n'est pas quand
même le cœur du sujet aujourd'hui donc
il y a le côté
un peu comme vous avez dit qui qui
intéresse certaines personnes mais c'est
un sujet très secondaire par rapport au
au courement lui-même je pensais tout ce
que représente le couramment faut
ajouter quand même que il était
inconcevable qui ne soit pas parce qu'il
y a eu un suspense pendant quelques mois
ira-t-il ira-t-il pas il avait reçu
l'invitation il avait déjà le temps pour
répondre c'est quand même le fils du roi
qui est couronné aujourd'hui son second
fils et c'est quand même le 5e
héritier dans l'ordre du succession au
trône donc on peut pas imaginer qui est
les numéros 7 8 10 et 12 etc et pas le
cinquième ça aurait été quand même une
tâche incroyable donc il était important
qu'il soit là il le fait de façon plus
ou moins digne il est là il remplit son
rôle strict au sensus et stricto sensu
et voilà
c'était important que ce soit là
absolument votre avis j'en décares sur
cette image que nous venons de voir du
prince Harry arrivant seul dans cette
abbaye doit être ministère alors que
c'est presque voler la vedette à la
procession vous avez vu on a cette image
la procession du roi de Buckingham
l'abbaye on a interrompu l'image au
moment de l'arrivée du prince Harry
écoutez je trouve ça assez pathétique en
fait c'était prévisible
après avoir ouvert si je puis dire un
bureau des pleurs et des récriminations
comme il l'a fait on ne peut pas fonder
toute une vie là-dessus et dire que
c'est toujours la faute des autres etc
etc je trouve bien qu'il soit là
j'espère pour lui qu'il va pouvoir
trouver un autre mode d'existence plutôt
que de se plaindre en permanence il va
pas pouvoir continuer à déverser ses
réclamations c'est très mauvais pour son
esprit et pour sa santé et son équilibre
personnel sûrement même s'il a vécu des
moments difficiles mais on sent
tellement qu'il y a derrière tout ça des
réclamations à base d'argent à base de
d'accord et de contrat avec des sociétés
de production de télévision et autres
que c'est un peu déplacé on retourne à
Londres Timothée délai alors qu'on suit
et on continue de suivre ces images de
la procession du roi vers l'abbaye de
Westminster dans ce carrosse moderne
celui-ci le Diamond jubilé state coach
Timothée vous êtes avec un Britannique
déguisé lui aussi sous la pluie mais
heureux on l'imagine
c'est c'est exactement ça vous avez bien
résumé la situation Thibault sous la
pluie vous le voyez certainement à nos
cheveux la pluie qui ça y est s'abat sur
la rue de Londres mais qui n'a pas eu
raison et bien de la joie de des
Britanniques qui viennent d'apercevoir
le roi Charles III et qui est passé
juste devant eux c'est le cas de cet
homme c'est votre cas vous avez aperçu
le roi Charles III tout à l'heure du FC
de King euh
on a pu apercevoir le carrosse la
procession avec enfin par derrière tout
les parapluies bon c'est un peu
difficile à voir mais pas pas grave
parce que toute façon la journée est
géniale une expérience unique et je
pourrais dire à mes petits-enfants que
j'étais ici que j'ai vu ce qui se
passait et j'ai vu le nouveau roi
pourquoi était si important pour vous de
venir à Londres aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui fait que l'Angleterre ou la
Grande-Bretagne et la Grande-Bretagne
toute cette cérémonie on est les seuls à
savoir faire ça au monde le roi et
fantastique la famille royale aussi moi
je voulais montrer mon soutien au
nouveau roi et qu'il règne longtemps
qu'est-ce que le roi Charles III
signifie pour vous
la famille royale c'est vraiment la
raison de l'identité de l'existence de
ce magnifique pays
on pourrait parler de l'économie on
pourrait parler de tout ce que ça
rapporte au pays bien sûr qu'il y a un
coût pour cette cérémonie aujourd'hui un
coup important mais vous voyez les les
foules les gens qui sont déplacés des
quatre coins du monde pour faire la fête
avec nous c'est juste extraordinaire
c'est c'est génial
et voilà je peux pas vous dire plus que
ça
on va
regarder un petit peu le la procession
repassée tout à l'heure ensuite on
cherchera un écran et puis ce soir en
revenant à la maison je vais le regarder
je vais enregistrer bien sûr voilà et je
vais passer un bon moment devant la télé
qui est sur le point de débuter et que
les Anglais ne vont pas manquer de
regarder à la à la télévision merci
spectateur nous dire que seuls les
Anglais savaient faire ça c'est vrai
c'est une spécificité anglaise personne
n'organise d'événements comme ça on peut
comparer quoi des grands événements
sportifs mais sinon ça n'est pas que je
pense que c'est un peu exagéré de dire
ça en France il y a des grands
événements même pour le décès de pasteur
ou de Victor Hugo il y avait des défilés
des journées de deuil national avec des
défilé absolument
somptueux à Paris et à l'époque de la
royauté en France il y avait quand même
aussi une
faste de la cour à laquelle et un peu
partout dans la pays auquel beaucoup de
gens ont participé donc les anglais sont
assez doués en la matière c'est vrai
mais je ne dirais pas qu'ils ont
exclusivité totale pour ça florentin
vous avez été correspondre à Londres
alors j'ai lu que cette événement
s'appelle golden Horde et que pour un
exemple et funérailles de la reine
s'appelait London Bridge c'est des
événements qu'on prépare longtemps à
l'avance tout est calibré ou presque
bien sûr parce que la monarchie a le
temps long on devrait elle est plus que
millénaire donc
tout est prévu tout est organisé
justement les problèmes dans ce système
c'est les l'imprévu ce sont les
événements inattendus on parlait de ce
qui s'est passé avec le prince Harry
tout à l'heure ça en fait partie donc un
couronnement un mariage royal et même un
décès ça se prépare des années à
l'avance un couronnement le dernier
c'était il y a 70 ans donc on
s'inspire d'un d'un rituel millimétré on
le on l'adapte aux besoins en fonction
des circonstances là la cérémonie est un
petit peu réduite celle à laquelle on va
assister par rapport à celle qui avait
vu Elisabeth de couronnée en 1953
mais évidemment puis c'est une opération
aussi de maintien de l'ordre il y a
environ 9 10 000 policiers déployés dans
Londres
le la canalisation des foules est
toujours très très bien organisé à
Londres pour éviter qu'il y ait des
bousculades etc donc
en effet c'est des événements très très
bien préparés et puis
montrer à la planète entière en
mondialisation le carrosse vient de
s'arrêter face à la porte ouest de cette
abbaye de Westminster Jean descart c'est
le moment important de ce couronnement
que nous allons vivre maintenant ça
commence dans 12 minutes maintenant oui
parce que si vous voulez il y a une
vedette entre guillemets dans ce
couronnement que l'abbaye de Westminster
c'est un monument extraordinaire
représentant Milan d'histoire près de 60
monarques britanniques ont été
couronnées mais c'est beaucoup plus que
cette magnifique cathédrale de style
gothique maintenant c'est aussi un
panthéon
pour prendre un équivalent français
puisque de grandes gloire
britanniques ils sont enterrés ce sont
des scientifiques comme Newton ce sont
des écrivains comme Charles Dickens des
artistes des vedettes comme Laurent
saliver et c'est aussi un monument de la
mémoire de la Première Guerre mondiale
avec le tombeau du soldat inconnu qui a
été aménagé du soldat britannique
inconnu en 1920
après que le roi George V est fourni
énormément de soutien aux Français dans
la terrible bataille de la Somme ça a
été une sorte de Verdun pour les
Britanniques donc
Westminster est un univers absolument
fascinant dans je dirais dans tous les
courants religieux spirituels
politiques artistique il y a bien sûr
des souverains qui sont inhumées par
exemple la reine Elizabeth première la
fille d'Henri VIII etc donc un monde
extraordinaire vous avez vu Pascaline le
prince Harry est bien au troisième rang
voilà le prince Harry est au troisième
rang à côté de l'époux de la princesse
Eugénie je crois il est resté assez
proche de sa cousine la princesse
Eugénie donc on peut comprendre se
positionnement mais oui ce qui me frappe
moi c'est de le voir au même niveau que
le prince Albert de Monaco oui troisième
rang aussi je crois donc alors que quand
même c'est le fils du roi bon voilà
c'est symbolique une polémique aussi sur
le les habits est-ce qu'il est vrai que
alors il y a un protocole strict vous me
confirmez par exemple le violet est
interdit oui le violet le rouge sont
interdit je crois parce que c'est la
couleur des rois la couleur de l'armée
sur les chapeaux ou la tiare c'est ça
oui alors je crois que
théoriquement les les membres féminins
de la famille royale doivent porter pour
t'aider tiers jusqu'ici on leur a
demandé un peu de réduire la voilure je
crois que certaines ont insisté pour le
porter quand même quant au chapeau
et pour quant au chapeau c'est bon il y
a ce qu'on appelle en Angleterre les
fascinators s'échappeaux c'est bibi 13
architecturé très très grand très
grand
spectaculaire là je crois qu'on en a un
un exemple notamment au niveau de la
famille royale et des invités donc là on
reste au fil de la tradition
les images en direct de l'abbaye de
Westminster le carrosse s'est arrêté
devant la porte ouest et le roi doit
rentrer théoriquement si on suit le
protocole à 11h53 il est 11h51
j'en écart protocole millimétré là on va
pas se tromper
c'est un minimum je pense que moi je
vais noter pour ma rencontre avec le
prince de Galles à l'époque et 40 ans
qu'il était très précis et très ponctuel
qui n'aimait pas du tout les gens en
retard et je pense que la reine
elle-même était une femme une grande
ponctualité on s'interromp un instant et
on s'imprègne de l'ambiance dans cet
abbaye de Westminster au moment où le
roi Charles III
entrera pour être couronné
[Musique]
symbolique la religion va être mise en
avant parce que le roi et le
représentant de l'église Henri Ivan le
chef de l'Église en ville le chef de
l'Église absolument
[Musique]
l'apport de Henri VIII l'histoire de
l'Angleterre
[Musique]
et la liturgie est très riche et plus
regardée hier soir
l'ordre de la c'est une sorte de masse
c'est très proche de la literie
[Musique]
on n'a pas vu donc l'empreinte
chrétienne est vraiment marquée même si
on marque le respect pour d'autres fois
aussi et des représentants d'autres
seront présents
dans la cérémonie
voilà le roi Charles III qui entre il
n'est pas encore couronné j'en déclare
en sortant de l'abbaye dans deux heures
il aura une couronne sur la tête oui et
pas n'importe quel cool erreur couronne
pardon les couronnes d'ailleurs qui
selon les
usages doivent être portés aussi pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture du Parlement il y
a toute une série alors il y a des
joyaux
il avait d'ailleurs remplacé sa mère se
souvient pour une ouverture du Parlement
avec des bijoux qui sont des joyaux
extraordinaires qui ont quelquefois fait
des polémiques par leur origine
étrangère bien entendu mais enfin c'est
extraordinaire c'est joyeux qui sortent
de la Tour de Londres c'est c'est
fascinant avec je dirais des des
histoires fabuleuses à l'image qui a été
William florentin qui rentre après le
roi je rappellerai que la reine
Elizabeth II avant son couronnement par
sa conscience professionnelle porter sa
couronne au petit déjeuner prenez ces
exambacon avec sa couronne et s'amusait
beaucoup le prince Philippe mais parce
qu'elle voulait que ça soit parfait ne
pas avoir l'air embarrassé ça aurait été
épouvantable mais il y a plusieurs
couronnes alors celle-ci il me semble
que c'est la Queen Maryse Crown il y en
a plusieurs la sainte Edward et
l'impériale oui c'est une pièce de plus
de 2 kg 2 kg 200 qui symbolise la
responsabilité du souverain elle ne sera
sainte en principe que une seule fois
par Charles III dans son règne elle a
été longtemps
serti de pièces précieuses de pierre
précieuse qui était loué à leur
propriétaire on les achetait pas
tellement c'était cher et on les rendait
après et le roi George V de
l'arrière-grand-père de Charles III a
été le premier à la coiffer le 22 juin
1911 dans sa forme actuelle avec
440 joyaux des rubis des saphirs des
topazes etc et
seul le monarque en fonction et
l'archevêque de Canterbury le joaillier
de la couronne bien sûr ont le droit de
poser les mains sur cette emblème
majeure de la royauté britannique
on voit la seconde couronne dans une de
celle dont vous parliez qui est qui est
en train d'arriver mais là c'est la
sainte Edwards Crown il me semble devant
est l'épée aussi et on va voir le temps
de détailler tout ça parce que il sera
couronné mais on lui présentera aussi
tous les joyaux de la couronne ça c'est
la tradition
c'est intéressant aussi je de noter que
alors là on voit Camilla arriver avec
les satresne et ses pages tout à l'heure
quand on a vu le roi Charles III à
l'entrée de boitier derrière lui on
notera la présence de Georges futur roi
d'Angleterre mais aussi le printemps le
fils aîné de William ne vend qui fait
partie donc des pages qui tiennent on le
voit là derrière voilà je pense que
c'est important de noter ça parce que je
fais la comparaison avec les obsèques de
la Reine Elizabeth
il est derrière à gauche très sérieux
trading avec son petit costume toujours
adorable en même temps c'est ce que
j'allais dire et je pense que c'est
important de noter sa présence et la
présence de William et Kate évidemment
pour la dimension émotionnelle de la
cérémonie je fais le parallèle avec les
obsèques d'Elisabeth II voilà et les
obsèques d'Elizabeth II ont été vraiment
chargés en émotion c'est vraiment un
moment qu'on soit bien sûr anglais ou
même qu'on soit étranger on ressentait
quelque chose il y avait beaucoup
d'émotions je me demande si le
couronnement aura cette même dimension
et je pense ça peut être quelque chose
d'assez froid d'assez symbolique d'un
peu de tortueux et je pense que la
présence de cet enfant des membres de la
famille ajoutent ce petit supplément
d'âme qui est nécessaire à la cérémonie
la présence du troisième fils de William
alors lui je crois qu'il est pas prévu
au programme et petit il a 5 ans
il a 5 ans il est pas toujours Louis oui
je crois qu'il est un petit peu dissipé
des fois
de la reine c'est un truc comme Charles
en 1955 il avait 4 ans
mais Louis c'est vrai que bon ça apporte
aussi beaucoup de dames parce que les
gens trouvent très mignon même quand il
fait ses grimaces et ses bêtises mais je
pense que là ça m'a vraiment autre chose
à faire que de le gérer
oui on a aperçu aussi donc juste
derrière le roi Charles le prince de
Galles le prince William avec Kate on
les voit on va les revoir à l'écran dans
quelques minutes je pense habillé dans
un dans un apparat dans lesquels on les
a jamais vus donc là on voit qu'ils
apparaissent ici en tant que successeur
direct du roi Charles
et dans l'appareil qui s'y est à cette
fonction en fait de de prince héritier
direct le premier tout le monde ou
presque avant le roi et la reine sauf
les futurs rois voilà une façon de
montrer que
c'est la ligne et qui entre là dans la
cathédrale de l'abbaye de Westminster
pardon donc le roi Charles mais juste
derrière son fils le prince de Galles et
la princesse de Galles
et ce n'est pas un petit détail
pittoresque ça va l'assurance même de la
monarchie
pour renouvellement
des générations qui est prévu qui est
représente l'unité du du pays avec une
dimension très humaine on fait très
attention à respecter cette tradition là
est-ce qu'il y aura des ajustements des
touches de modernité des préférences ou
non le couronnement se fera exactement
de la même manière qu'il y a 70 ans
exactement de la même manière qu'il y a
500 ans
honnêtement je ne sais pas capable de
répondre la question peut-être que
Monsieur legar est-ce que c'est
exactement la même chose qui a 500 ans
ou pas non il y a une définition non ne
serait-ce que sur le plan de la lumière
et le sur le plan vestimentaire et sur
le plan du contexte politique et
européen et le dérouler sera-t-il le
même mais c'est quand même je le répète
cet endroit cette cathédrale c'est 957
ans de couronnement donc d'histoire
britannique au sens large se fabuleux
c'est vraiment un témoignage unique sur
le plan monumental
non je crois que si c'est modernisé dans
le sens où de la même manière que la
procession était moins longue que celle
d'Elisabeth je crois que là c'était 2 km
celle d'Elisabeth c'était 8 là je crois
que la cérémonie a été raccourcie il y a
certaines étapes qui sont un peu qui ont
été annulées par exemple je crois qu'on
présentait aux souverain dans les
précédents couronnement des lingots d'or
pour moi cette étape on a dit on m'a
peut-être évité en période d'inflation
la Grande-Bretagne su blime l'inflation
plus 10% par souci de d'essence on va
peut-être éviter il y a des choses comme
ça il y a trois femmes dans le clergé
pour la c'est la première fois donc
plein de petites choses comme ça les les
vêtements ont déjà été portés les
couronnes ont déjà été portées il y a
une sorte comme ça de souci de recyclage
entre guillemets toutes ces choses font
moins d'inviter aussi toutes ces choses
font que ça modernise un peu la
cérémonie genre une question de nos
internautes vous avez peut-être la
réponse pourquoi Kamila entre avant
Charles
on le sait franchement pour ce protocole
je ne suis pas compétent est-ce que
c'est une disposition
exceptionnelle compte tenu du
statut qui a eu camilia dans la vie de
Charles elle est son épouse légitime
depuis 2005 elle est la reine comme l'a
voulu Sa Majesté Elisabeth II vous c'est
tout ce qu'on peut observer
cette cérémonie qui sera présidée par
l'archevêque de kanterbury chef de
l'Église d'Angleterre
la princesse Charlotte je crois qu'ils
étaient juste derrière à confirmer mais
je crois les avoir aperçus et qui vont
aller s'installer avec leurs parents qui
ont donc s'occuper d'eux il y a des
symboles extraordinaires
l'archevêque de Canterbury doit remettre
roi ce qu'on appelle l'épée de
l'offrande c'est une épée pour servir le
bien et se défendre des combattre le mal
et la garde de l'épée est ornée de
feuilles de chêne et de gland en diamant
et en émeraude c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et
le Furon en cuir recouvert d'or et lui
aussi const de pierrerie disposait en
motifs floraux évoquant l'Angleterre les
cosses le Pays de Galles et l'Irlande
c'est-à-dire les États les nations les
peuples constituant le Royaume-Uni
sachez que ces robes portaient par le
roi et la reine sont les robes d'État
alors le roi Portel porté par Georges VI
en 1937 et la reine qui a mis la porte
la robe fête pour Elizabeth II ça c'est
un signe supplémentaire de la confiance
que a eu Elisabeth II dans le mariage
qu'il fallait absolument organiser de
Charles avec Camilla florentin vous qui
avez vécu au Royaume-Uni qui avait vu ce
que penser les les Britanniques de la
reine cabinet est-ce que ça vous
surprendre la voir là ici comme ça non
ça ne surprend pas parce que c'est
l'aboutissement de cette très longue et
tumultueuse relation entre Charles et
Camilla mais aussi entre ce couple royal
et le princier à l'époque et les
Britanniques elle a été en effet à i
puis maintenant elle est elle a vraiment
con le coeur des Britanniques depuis que
Charles est devenu roi à succéder à sa
mère Camilla est un peu considéré comme
la nouvelle grand-mère de la nation si
on peut dire donc ça me surprend pas
qu'elle soit là c'est assez logique ils
sont arrivés chacun de leur côté parce
que
je vous coupe à Barentin on va suivre le
début de ce couronnement dans l'abbaye
de Westminster on reste avec vous pour
tout vous expliquer et on se retrouve
dans un instant je viens non pour être
servi mais pour servir
Jésus-Christ l'amour de Dieu et la
communion de l'Esprit Saint soit avec
vous et avec votre esprit
alléluia le Christ est ressuscité il est
vraiment ressuscité alléluia
chers amis nous sommes réunis pour
rendre hommage aux dieux tout-puissant
et pour célébrer la vie de nos nations
pour prier pour Charles notre roi
pour exprimer notre reconnaissance pour
la vie qu'il a passé au service de cette
nation des royaumes et du Commonwealth
et pour être témoin dans la joie de son
couronnement de son onction alors il est
sacré et consacré au service de son
peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Dieu garde le roi Charles
[Musique]
ici le roi Charles votre roi s'ennuie
doute c'est à lui que vous tous ici
réunis aujourd'hui est devenu rendre
hommage et offrir service êtes-vous prêt
à en faire autant Dieu garde le roi
Charles
[Musique]
je vous présente
votre roi s'ennuie doute c'est à lui que
vous tous ici réunis aujourd'hui est
devenu rendre hommage et offrir service
êtes-vous présent faire autant Dieu
garde le roi Charles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre roi s'ennuie le doute
c'est à lui que vous tous et s'y réunis
aujourd'hui est devenu rendre hommage et
offrir service êtes-vous prêts à en
faire autant Dieu garde le roi Charles
[Musique]
tu cliques tu ever mind for of the Lord
la loi et à l'Évangile de Dieu règle de
toute vie et de tout gouvernement de
préinscription
recevez ce livre qui est ce que ce bas
monde offre de plus précieux
qui est ici et la sagesse ici la loi
royale
ici les oracles vivants de Dieu
Majesté
l'église établit de plein droit dont
vous jurerez de maintenir la
Constitution est attachée à la véritable
profession de l'Évangile et se faisant
veille à promouvoir un environnement où
les personnes de toutes confession et de
toute croyance peuvent vivre librement
le serment du couronnement existe depuis
des siècles et est inscrit dans la loi
voulez-vous bien prêter ce serment
je le veux bien
de gouverner les peuples du Royaume-Uni
de Grande-Bretagne et d'Irlande du Nord
vos autres royaumes et les territoires
auxquels ils appartiennent ou se
rattaquage selon leur loi et leur
coutumes respectives
dans la mesure de votre pouvoir à ce que
droit justice et miséricorde soit dans
tous vos jugements j'y vais
dans toute la mesure de votre pouvoir à
préserver les lois de Dieu et la
véritable profession de l'Évangile
préserverez-vous dans toute la mesure de
votre pouvoir la religion protestante et
formée établie de plein droit dans le
Royaume-Uni maintiendrez-vous et
garderez vous un violet la constitution
de l'Église d'Angleterre s'adoptrine
sans culte sa discipline et son
gouvernement tel qu’établit de plein
droit de plein droit en Angleterre
conserverez-vous aux évêques et au
clergé d’angleterre ainsi qu'aux églises
qui leur sont confiées tous les droits
et privilèges qui leur reviennent ou
leur reviendront en vertu du droit
je le promets
tout ce que j'ai ici promis je le ferai
et je le tiendrai avec l'aide de Dieu
par souscription et déclaration à prêter
le serment Saturne de déclaration
d'adhésion je suis disposé
en présence de Dieu être un protestant
fidèle et que conformément au sens
véritable des actes juridiques
garantissant la succession protestante
au trône je respecterai et maintiendrait
les 10 actes dans la pleine mesure de
mes pouvoirs conformément au droit
Charles II vient de prêter serment nous
restons avec ces images en plein écran
pour vous faire vivre ce couronnement du
roi avec la Bible qui lui a été présenté
c'est le premier objet qui lui est
présenté le premier cadeau au roi dans
ce couronnement Pascaline ça nous a un
peu surpris il semble hésitant pas
forcément tout savoir de ce qu'il doit
faire oui c'est souvent le cas avec le
roi Charles serait qu'on se souvient de
ce stylo là qui le stylo réfractaire au
monde ciné je ne sais plus quel document
peut être le temps après la décéder
Isabelle II
c'est vrai que parfois on le sent un
petit peu à côté de pas de l'événement
mais de la de la tradition de tout ce
qu'il faut du chemin tracé alors que
pourtant il y a eu beaucoup de
répétitions
oui mais en même temps il faut quand
même reconnaître que c'est la première
fois qu'il est couronné oui il a pas
l'habitude qu'il fait pas ça
il y a eu des répétitions mais c'est
tout un rituel qui est complexe et donc
c'est normal qu'il soit assisté et puis
avant de signer il a peut-être peur de
tomber encore sur un stylo qui fuit on
vient de le voir ça a marché cette fois
ce qui est quand même remarquable aussi
une table c'est le l'importance de la
religion dans cette cérémonie donc
évidemment Charles et le chef de
l'Église anglicane donc on voit
entremêler les deux institutions que
sont l'église et la monarchie le pouvoir
le pouvoir
exécutif en fait le pays en même temps
on peut se poser des questions sur
l'anachronisme ou non de ce genre de
cérémonie alors que seulement moins de
5% des Britanniques se disent chrétiens
pratiques et alors justement pas le
Thomson vous qui est un conservateur
britannique est-ce que ça vous étonne de
voir une cérémonie qui sera ouverte il y
aura d'autres confessions alors oui
l'église handicale est évidemment au
coeur de cette cérémonie mais on s'ouvre
à d'autres religions lors de ce
couronnement
je pense que tout à fait normal et
ce n'est pas vraiment nouveau dans ce
sens que
cette unité d'être pas le cas en 1953
mais depuis il y a eu une reconnaissance
des apports de
groupe venus de l'étranger dans la
société britannique à l'occasion de
jubilé de la reine par exemple 13
explicité et qui ont été vraiment été
mis de de l'avant genre oui
on peut redire on doit redire que
ouvert à tous les courants spirituels
tout seul dans le fils fut envoyé non
pour être servi mais pour servir
fais-moi la grâce de trouver dans ton
service une parfaite liberté dans cette
liberté la connaissance de ta vérité
accorde-moi d'être une bénédiction pour
tous tes enfants de toutefois et de
toute conviction afin qu'ensemble nous
puissions découvrir les voies de la
douceur et être conduits sur les chemins
de la paix par Jésus-Christ notre
Seigneur AMEN
[Musique]
de la croyance durant cet homme très
croyant on est obligé d'être croyant
quand on est roi disons que c'est un
homme qui est très intéressé par tous
les courants spirituels et qui a qui
s'est documenté d'une façon remarquable
il avait été initié à la lecture
parkmam ça leur mère ils adorait ce
qu'elle lui conseillait et puis il a
beaucoup voyagé je rappelle qu'il s'est
intéressé particulièrement à la religion
de son père le prince Philippe n'est
prince de Grèce en 1921 Corfou donc la
religion orthodoxe était essentielle et
le roi Charles bien avant aujourd'hui a
fait un séjour au mont Atos qui est le
dernier morceau de l'Empire de Byzance
où il a étudié la vie dans les
monastères
étudier la vie des orthodoxes et la
respecter c'est un hommage à son père
d'une certaine façon le duc d'Édimbourg
avait dû se convertir pas la religion
anglicane pour épouser la princesse
héritière en 1953 merci beaucoup Jean
des gars merci de nous avoir accompagné
sur le début de ce couronnement je
rappelle que on peut retrouver votre
livre Charles Camilla et Diana toutes
les bonnes librairies chez Perrin merci
Jean je tente vers vous me parliez
antenne juste avant de
cette musique du compositeur choisit
c'est ça le compositeur qui est
très connu pour les
mélomanes c'était un compositeur de
l'époque elisabethen qui avait
particularité d'être catholique elle
était contesté à l'époque à cause de
cela mais la Reine Elizabeth la protéger
alors que ces questions religieuses
étaient très sensibles et donc
effectivement choisi de
pièces de ce compositeur parce qu'il y a
un autre qui arrive plus tard je pense
être un petit clin d'oeil quand même à
la communauté catholique
d'une hypothèse de ma part mais ça me
paraît semblable on va vraiment dans un
instant
un moment tout à fait particulier pour
nous Français nous allons écouter le
Premier ministre britannique
prendre la parole et réciter un texte de
la Bible
tout à fait
symbolique justement de ce côté
écumanique de cette cérémonie puisque le
Premier ministre riche sunac est
hindouiste
pratiquant donc on voit comment cette
intégration subtile et habile en fait de
toutes les fois du royaume et réalisé
dans cette cérémonie et
c'est important aussi de voir que le
chef de l'exécutif larichissounac
participe à cette cérémonie religieuse
de couronnement du souverain
dans s'imprègne à nouveau de l'ambiance
dans cette abbé de ouest Minister cette
religion cette cérémonie religieuse pour
le couronnement du roi Charles III
[Musique]
dans la splendeur céleste jette un
regard favorable sur ton serviteur
Charles notre roi et fais-lui grâce de
tant de sagesse et d'amour que nous et
tout ton peuple puissions vivre dans la
paix la prospérité et l'amour mutuel
pour ta gloire éternelle
toi qui avec le Père et le Saint-Esprit
règne en maître sur toute chose Dieu a
maintenant et dans les siècles des
siècles Amen
du premier chapitre de l'épître
colossien
c'est pourquoi nous aussi depuis le jour
où nous en avons oui parlait nous ne
cessons de prier et de demander pour
vous que vous soyez en plis de la
connaissance de sa volonté en toute
sagesse et intelligence spirituelle pour
marcher d'une manière digne du Seigneur
lui plaire à tous égards portant des
fruits en toute bonheur et croissants
par la connaissance de Dieu
est en fortifié en toute force selon la
puissance de sa gloire pour toute
patience et conscience
avec joie
rendant grands-pères qui nous a rendus
capables de participer au lot des saints
dans la lumière
qui nous a délivré du pouvoir des
ténèbres et nous a transporté dans le
royaume du fils de son amour
[Musique]
nous avons la rédemption la rémission
des péchés qui est l'image du Dieu
invisible
premier-né de toute la création
ont été créés toutes choses les choses
qui sont dans les cieux et les choses
qui sont sur la terre les visibles et
les invisibles soit trônes ou seigneurie
aux principaux thèses ou autorités
toute chose ont été créées par lui et
pour lui
et lui est avant toute chose
et toute chose subsiste par lui
parole du Seigneur nous rendons grâce à
Dieu
qui vient de s'exprimer le Premier
ministre britannique images tout à fait
étonnante pour nous Français florentin
oui ça montre quand même l'intégration
au cœur de la société britannique et au
plus haut niveau de la Société Botanique
puisqu'on a pour la première fois un
premier ministre d'origine indienne
évidemment il est britannique et
hindouiste dans sa foi qui est donc le
chef du gouvernement le chef de
l'exécutif mais nommé par le roi a
Charles et qui participe à cette
cérémonie
de couronnement nommée par le roi après
des élections oui évidemment il faut le
préciser oui
mais c'est quand même symboliquement
plus que symboliquement officiellement
le roi qui désigne qui nomme le Premier
ministre en fonction du résultat en
effet de
Parlement il se voit toutes les semaines
et donc on a ce premier ministre
hindouiste qui lit un extrait de la
Bible donc de soit chrétienne pour
participer au couronnement du roi
Charles vue de France Bolton ça nous
étonne nous qui sommes dans une
République laïque avec une séparation
stricte de l'Église et de l'État
une vraie différence là ah oui
aux antipodes on pourrait dire mais il
faut aussi comprendre que l'Église
anglicane quelque chose de très
particulier et honnêtement elle a une
dimension religion civile un peu comme
dans neuromes antiques ou la
religion
avait pour fonction de souder la société
le christianisme était mal vu au départ
parce qu'il était considéré comme un
ferment de
déstockage de la société
et donc
effectivement de religion civile écoutez
l'évangile de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ ou selon le fameux gloire à
Toi Seigneur
Jésus vient Nazareth où il avait été
élevé
selon sa coutume il entra dans la
synagogue le jour du sabbat et se leva
pour lire
on lui remis le livre du prophète Esaïe
ayant ouvert le livre il trouve à
l'endroit où il était écrit
l'Esprit du Seigneur est sur moi parce
qu'il m'avait pour annoncer la Bonne
Nouvelle pauvre il m'a envoyé pour
guérir ceux qui ont le cœur brisé pour
annoncer au captif la délivrance et aux
aveugles le recouvrement de la vue pour
renvoyer libre ceux qui sont meurtriers
pour prêcher l'année de grâce du
Seigneur
et le remis ton ministre et sa cycle
avait les yeux fixés sur lui et il se
mit à leur dire cette aujourd'hui que
s'accomplit cette parole que vos
oreilles ont entendu
évangile du Seigneur
louange à toi au Christ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ian
[Musique]
isme c'est précisant tu vois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a une cérémonie particulière du
gospel
et un nouveau un autre gage de la
modernité en tout cas l'effort de
modernisation de cette cérémonie
l'effort de mozartisation passe beaucoup
par la musique donc il y a ce cœur de
gospel il y a aussi des shortbox Grecs
qui sont chantés durant la cérémonie ça
c'est un hommage au père de Charles III
le roi Philippe qui était né à Corfou
il y aura aussi des musiques composées
par Andrew Lord Weber le célèbre
compositeur de comédie musicale et je
crois aussi un morceau composé par
Patrick Doyle qui est l'un des
compositeurs qui a travaillé sur la
quatrième volet de la saga Harry Potter
oui ok chrome
et nous couronnons un roi pour servir
ce qui est donné aujourd'hui
bénéficie à tous
[Musique]
les pauvres les oppressés seraient
libéré où les aveugles recouvreraient la
vue et les meurtries seraient guéris
ce royaume
fixe les objectifs de tout
les états respectant le droit et les
moyens
qu'ils doivent employer
car Jésus ne s'accroche pas au pouvoir
ni au statut le Roi des rois
Jésus-Christ
non pas pour être servi mais pour servir
il crée
ça et le privilège du pouvoir cela donne
le devoir de servir le service c'est
l'amour en action nous voyons l'amour
actif dans la façon dont nous traitons
les plus vulnérables
nous élevons les jeunes dont nous
conservons le monde naturel
nous avons vu ces priorités dans la vie
de devoir qu'a vécu notre roi
aujourd'hui nous avons l'honneur d'être
dans cette abbaye
[Musique]
juste à côté d'ici se trouve 400 ou plus
jeune personne
extraordinaire à Sainte Marguerite qui
vivent une vie de service partout dans
le monde dans notre commonwells il y en
a un nombre encore plus grand vous vivez
vos vies pour les autres
l'unité dont vous faites preuve
l'exemple que vous donnez c'est ce qui
nous unit tous et qui offre à la Société
un fondement aussi fort joyeux
un lourd fardeau pour nous et la gravité
de la tâche
qui vous est donné aujourd'hui Majesté
mais supportable par que par l'Esprit de
Dieu qui nous donne la force de
consacrer notre vie aux autres avec
l'onction du Saint-Esprit le roi donne
librement
un rumeur ne pourra jamais attendre par
la volonté la politique la guerre ou la
tyrannie le Saint-Esprit
nous mène à aimer en action
c'est ce qui est promis par Jésus qui a
mis de côté tous les privilèges
la première lecture Dieu donnera tout
pour notre bien par amour pour nous même
sa propre vie
son trône
était une croix
était faite d'épines
c'était les blessures qui meurtrirent
son corps
chacun d'entre nous
a servi
s'agit-il exactement dans notre vie et
bien seul chacun d'entre nous
ont décidé en choisissant savoir vers
Dieu aujourd'hui
le Roi
des rois
aujourd'hui
donne la grâce
que dans ce service je trouve la
première liberté comme l'a dit sa
Majesté tout à l'heure
c'est dans le service que l'on trouve la
liberté par cette prière pour chaque
fois chaque
dirigeant et oui chaque personne chacun
d'entre nous
nous
transformateur que Dieu AMEN
voilà nous venons d'entendre le sermon
de l'archevêque de Canterbury qui
préside cette cérémonie florentan dans
un instant nous assisterons au moment le
plus sacré et le plus important
de cette cérémonie de couronnement c'est
l'onction du roi
quand vous dites nous assisterons je ne
sais même pas si on la verra parce que
vous avez pas tout à fait ça se passe
derrière un écran enfin un paravent
justement pour préserver le côté
absolument sacré et religieux de cette
cérémonie c'est un des seuls moments qui
est dissimulé à la vue des spectateurs
c'était déjà le cas au moment de du
couronnement d'Elizabeth II il y avait
eu des bas sur le fait de savoir s'il
fallait que les caméras puissent filmer
ce moment ou non
donc il y a un mélange en fait de public
et de d'intimes et de privé dans cette
cérémonie qui est très habilement géré
parce que Aline je suis assez étonné
alors on voit très peu le public on ne
voit pas du tout d'ailleurs il n'est
jamais filmé et on voit très peu
Charlotte 3 on le voit pas à l'image
quasiment pas non c'est vrai alors pour
ce qui est de ne pas montrer les invités
je pense que c'est pour bien rappeler
que nous ne sommes pas dans un événement
mondain nous sommes pas par exemple dans
un mariage où là on verrait peut-être
davantage les invités là on est vraiment
dans quelque chose de très sacré et le
fait qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup Charles
je me demande si ce n'est pas
pour marquer une certaine distance aussi
j'aurais le droit est en train d'être
investi en tant que roi peut-être que le
fait de ne pas le filmer c'est peut-être
ça lui confère encore ce caractère
peut-être un peu sacré tout comme le
fait qu'on ne le verra pas pendant
l'onction donc c'est lui-même je crois
qui a conçu les panneaux qui le dim
simuleront aux yeux du public pendant
l'onction ça le mystère le sacré ça
inspire forcément le respect moi je
trouve aussi que ça rajoute un petit
cran de théâtralité dans cette cérémonie
qui en a déjà beaucoup mais pourquoi pas
c'est le jeu un couronnement c'est une
fois tous les on a tous les 70 ans en
l'occurrence donc autant y aller à fond
mais je pense voilà que peut-être le
fait qu'il ne soit pas beaucoup montré
pas beaucoup filmé c'est une manière de
l'investir encore davantage
médiatiquement en tant que roi
[Musique]
était derrière un écran pour son son
cours non ce qui était si une vérité
parce que à l'époque c'était télévisé me
semble-t-il ce qui était une grande
première mais néanmoins ce moment clé
à l'abri des regards oui vraiment pour
garder le mystère de l'événement puisque
dans ce règne de droit divin puisqu'il a
bien été insisté que c'était par la
grâce de Dieu si on veut que que le roi
est couronné et le
sereigne au nom de Dieu est une sorte de
une forme de mystère le roi qui est dans
un instant après ce champ se déplacera
donc de la coronation share vers la
chaise de couronnement ça me fait devoir
faire vous le voyez et
sera Rouen de l'huile sacrée et je vous
propose de continuer à écouter ce qu'il
se dit au sein de la baie de nous et
avec le temps ton seul
a été ou un par le Saint-Esprit pour
être le Christ Sauveur et serviteur de
tous par la puissance du même esprit
baigné et sanctifie cette huile afin
qu'elle soit pour ton serviteur Charles
un signe de jouets d'allégresse enfin
qu'ils connaissent comme roi l'abondance
de ta grâce et la puissance de ta
miséricorde pour que nous soyons un
sacerdoce royal une nation simple un
peuple qui t'appartiennent
béni soit Dieu
notre force et notre salut maintenant et
pour les siècles des siècles Amen
[Musique]
cette musique zadox the priest alors
sachez que pour les amateurs de football
elle a inspiré la musique de la Ligue
des Champions et je sais que les
mélomanes le reconnaîtront et donc ce
moment très important vous voyez arriver
ces paravent pour dissimuler
le regard du monde l'onction du roi
Charles III vous avez vu aussi cette
petite cette petite ampoule
en
c'est un aigle en forme d'aigle forme
d'aigle et puis tout est question de
symboles avec une cuillère du
couronnement du 12e siècle alors il sera
loin d'abord sur la tête les mains puis
la poitrine et donc nous ne voyons pas
c'est qu'il se passe derrière c'est
c'est leparavant florentin Pascaline a
raison c'est vraiment très théâtral on
assiste à un événement montré en mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que l'arbre qu'on voit sur l'un
des panneaux est encore un symbole de
l'attachement de Charles à tout ce qui
est toute la cause écologique toute la
nature je crois que les robes qui vont
porter après ce qu'on veut brodé de
beaucoup d'éléments inspirés de la
nature peut-être qu'il faut y voir
encore une référence
le plus important de la de la journée le
plus mystique le plus religieux
de ce couronnement du roi Charles III la
chanson qui est précédée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moment très important dans la vie du
Royaume-Uni ce qu'on vient de voir
absolument ce qu'on vient de ne pas voir
plutôt mais bien sûr parce que il a
maintenant
assumer tous les attributs du souverain
avec cette
cérémonie
très religieuse mais aussi d'un
symbolisme que chacun peut apprécier
indépendamment de sa forte personnelle
et donc ça ça le consacre dans dans sa
fonction dans les vous parlez de cet
écran donc si on Pascaline sachez que et
bien sûr chaque feuille sont écrits les
États du commonwealt le nom des états du
Commonwealth
le roi Charles III qui vient donc de
s'asseoir sur cette chaise la
saint-edwards cher c'est tous les
couronnements depuis 700 ans ont lieu
sur ce truc c'est exactement symbole
d'honneur et de courage
puissiez vous être un défenseur
courageux de ceux qui sont dans le
besoin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le roi qui vient d'être vêtu de la super
tunica manteau de 60 ans à manches
longues et porté après cette cérémonie
d'onction florentin moment important on
remet au roi les joyaux de la couronne
oui on lui remet après la cérémonie
d'onction qui était très religieuse on
lui remet les joyaux de la couronne et
dans quelques minutes on le verra à
recevoir justement la couronne aussi on
le verra proprement à proprement parler
pour eux
[Musique]
O
que ce soit pour vous et pour tous ceux
qui sont témoins de ces choses ainsi que
un symbole nom de jugement mais de
justice non de puissance mais de
miséricorde
[Musique]
la justice arrêtez la croissance de
l'iniquité protéger la sainte Église de
Dieu et tous les hommes de bonne volonté
et des défendez les veuves et les
orphelins restaurer les choses qui sont
tombées en décrépitude maintenez les
choses qui sont restaurées punissaient
et réformés ce qui est défectueux et
confirmé ce qui est en ordre afin qu'en
faisant ces choses vous soyez glorieuse
en toute vertu et que vous serviez si
fidèlement notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ
en cette vie que vous puissiez régner
pour toujours avec lui dans la vie à
venir AMEN
[Musique]
de la sincérité de la sagesse gage de la
protection de Dieu qui vous étreint de
toutes parts
après les éperons l'épée empireides
offrande les armées le roi reçoit little
royale et la robe royale utilisée pour
la première fois en 1821 au couronnement
de Georges 4
florentin nous n'avons jamais été aussi
proche du couronnement physique on est à
quelques minutes quelques poignées de
secondes du couronnement un moment très
solennelle on voit le roi Charles dans
cette magnifique comment vous avez dit
la robe Rome royale dans la robe
recevez cette erreur
vous revêtent de la robe de la justice
et des habits du salut
sous la croix et souvenez-vous toujours
que les royaumes de ce monde sont
devenus les royaumes de notre Seigneur
et de son Christ
l'orbe un globe de 27,5 cm sur montée
d'une croix symbolise le monde chrétien
voilà l'un des joyaux de la couronne
remis au roi et désormais c'est l'anneau
du souverain
dignité royale et signe de l'alliance
juré aujourd'hui entre Dieu et le roi le
roi et le peuple
petit changement dans les couronnements
classiques
une bague
qu'utilise qui est présentée à tous les
souverains depuis plusieurs années sauf
que depuis
trois couronnements et bien on ne passe
plus la bague au doigts elle est
seulement présentée comme vous l'avez vu
à Charles III qui enfile maintenant un
gant sur sa main droite c'est parce que
le roi Charles a de gros doigts
avec douceur et grasse confiant non pas
dans votre propre pouvoir mais en la
miséricorde de Dieu qui vous a choisi
recevez le sceptre royal signe du
pouvoir royal et de la justice
symbole de l'Alliance et de la paix que
l'Esprit du Seigneur qui a ou un Jésus
lors de son baptême reçoigne de même
aujourd'hui afin que vous exerciez
l'autorité avec sagesse et que vous
dirigiez vos conseils avec grâce et que
par votre service et votre ministère
auprès de tout votre peuple la justice
et la miséricorde soient manifestée sur
toute la terre
voilà le moment le plus important de
cette journée le couronnement de
sécurité
béni nous t'en supplions cette couronne
et sanctifie ainsi ton serviteur Charles
sur la tête duquel tu le poses
aujourd'hui tu la poses aujourd'hui en
signe de majesté Royal afin qu'il soit
couronné de ta bienveillance et ampli
d'une grâce abondante et de toutes les
vertus princières par Jésus-Christ notre
Seigneur qui avec toi et le Saint-Esprit
vie règne en maître sur toute chose un
seul Dieu dans les siècles des siècles
Amen
[Musique]
historique le roi Charles III vient
d'être couronné de la couronne Saintes
[Musique]
dans une dimension complètement à la
fois spirituelle symbolique historique
évidemment parce que en réalité le roi
Charles est déjà roi depuis que la mort
de sa mère en septembre 2022 donc et le
Royaume-Uni est un des derniers pays une
des dernières monarchies où la dernière
monarchie a procédé encore à des
couronnements donc on sent le poids du
symbole de la cérémonie et on sent
d'ailleurs sur le on voit sur le visage
du roi Charles la gravité du moment on
a l'air presque parfois ACCA de la
responsabilité bon il y a certes le
poids de la couronne mais même avant
qu'elle soit posée sur sa tête on voyait
cette gravité cette sérieux avec lequel
il subit cette cérémonie il clôt les
yeux de temps en temps pour s'imprégner
enfin on sent que il est vraiment
entièrement imprégné de l'importance de
ce de ce moment parce qu'elle est vous
avez vu on a montré trois personnes là
depuis le couronnement sa femme qui a
mis là et on a vu aussi et les deux
princes on a vu le prince William et le
Prince George moi la dimension
symbolique historique dont vous parliez
j'ajouterai une dimension ésotérique qui
peut nous paraître un peu ésotérique qui
peut nous paraître un peu lointaine à
nous Français tous ces objets comme ça
cet ordre ce sceptre il y a une pierre
de la destinée qui est placé sous le
sous le trône on se croirait un peu dans
Harry Potter des fois mais toute cette
dimension comme ça un peu mystique elle
garantit l'éternité de ce sacre la
position que là à Charles avec ses
objets dans les mains c'est la même qui
a eu sa mère c'est la même qu'on eu ses
ancêtres et dans cette dimension
souligner l'éternité de la monachie
Royale en tout cas la volonté de la
rendre éternelle le fait de montrer que
les seuls autres personnes que l'on voit
après ce moment historique ce sont le
visage des Princes Charles du prince
Georges et du prince William ça c'est
l'avenir donc il y a tout comme ça une
temporalité très impressionnante passée
présent futur qui est Montréal
et qu'il vous fasse grâce que le
Seigneur lève sur vous la lumière de son
visage
et qu'il vous donne sa paix
que le Seigneur vous protège dans toutes
vos voix et face prospérer tout vos
travaux dans son nom
que le Seigneur vous donne l'espérance
et le bonheur afin que vous puissiez
inspirer tout votre peuple dans
l'imitation de son amour immuable
et la connaissance soit stabilité de
votre temps et la crainte de l'Éternel
votre trésor
que Dieu réponde sur vous les richesses
de sa grâce vous garde dans sa sainte
crainte vous prépare à une éternité
heureuse et enfin vous reçoivent dans la
gloire immortelle
le fils et le Saint-Esprit soit avec
vous et demeure avec vous pour toujours
AMEN
Paul Thomson les différentes églises qui
prennent possession et qui sont
présentes
lors de cette cérémonie on vient de
l'entendre oui exactement
catholique de Westminster
représentant de l'Église
orthodoxe des églises dites
non-conformistes j'en remettent etc
donc cette très large
[Musique]
je travaille avec Rouvillois bonjour
merci de nous rejoindre professeur de
droit constitutionnel spécialiste de la
royauté cette image un sentiment avant
de la commenter techniquement qu'est-ce
que vous ressentez en voyant ça un
sentiment de malade de d'émotion qui
qui emprunt toute la cérémonie et qui
frappe je pense tous ceux qui qui la
regardent enfin c'est quelque chose de
même lorsqu'on toucherament l'histoire
finalement on l'a on la voit rarement se
faire devant nous et notamment cette
histoire comme vous disiez madame qui
est en fait l'histoire d'une continuité
extraordinairement longue
qui s'en racine dans le passé qui est
présente à l'instant
que nous voyons et qui va se prolonger
dans le dans l'avenir puisqu'on sait que
que William un jour fera la même chose
qu'on posera la même couronne sur sa
tête que son fils un jour qui Dieu le
veut le ferait également et ainsi de
suite c'est ça qui on est voilà on est
dans une dans l'histoire longue on l'a
quelque chose qu'on
n'a jamais l'occasion de de ressentir à
un point aussi frappant je trouve la
couronne de Saintes sur la tête de
Charles III fabriqué en 1661 pour le
couronnement de Charles II après
l'exécution de Charles II c'est un bijou
historique
444 pierres précieuses fabriquées en or
massif de rubis des saphirs des
améthystes des topazes
la valeur de cette pièce le poids de
cette pièce
2,20 kg 230 g elle vaudrait 4 millions
d'euros
voilà pour cette couronne le sceptre à
la colombe dans la main droite le
sceptre à la croix dans la main gauche
le roi Charles III et roi là il n'a plus
de doute et on continue de s'imprégner
de ce qui se passe si je puis juste une
petite toute petite chose qui va madame
dans votre sens c'est que
il y a un côté de dérisoire à essayer de
s'y trouver le prix de quelque chose
comme ça puisque oui justement ceux
qu'on assiste ça n'a pas de prix voilà
on est au-delà de tout cela
qui est le vôtre par l'autorité de Dieu
et tout puissant que ce même Dieu dont
le trône subsiste à jamais affermissent
votre trône dans la justice afin qu'il
subsiste à jamais
je serai fidèle et sincère et vous
rendrai service de fidélité et de vérité
notre souverain seigneur défenseur de la
foi et à vos éditifs héritiers et
successeurs selon le droit avec l'aide
de Dieu
moi William Guillaume prince de Galles
je vous promets loyauté fidélité vérité
et vous rendrez service de fidélité de
vérité en tant que loyal serviteur de
votre vie de votre corps avec l'aide de
Dieu
tous ceux qui le souhaitent
pendant quelques instants
par Dieu garde le roi bien si vous le
préférez vous pouvez réciter le passage
suivant je jure de prêter fidélité à
Votre Majesté et à vos hérités et
successeurs selon le droit avec l'aide
de Dieu
[Applaudissements]
en ta collant vous aviez un mot à dire
oui on a aussi un moment très important
on vient de voir le l'archevêque de
Canterbury Justin Wellby prêter serment
au roi qui vient d'être couronné ainsi
que le prince de Galles sont héritier
direct le prince William
garde le roi Dieu garde de nos rêves
le roi Charles
vive le Roi à jamais
et l'archevêque de Canterbury a
également invité tous les
téléspectateurs même ceux qui sont chez
eux derrière leur télévision s'ils le
veulent a prêté serment aussi un serment
d'allégeance au roi donc ça c'est une
nouveauté totale dans cette cérémonie on
est dans la modernité parce qu'on
s'adresse aux gens qui sont de l'autre
côté de leur téléviseur
autrefois dans la cérémonie de
couronnement tels que la vécu Elisabeth
II il y a 70 ans c'était tous les pères
du royaume les toute l'aristocratie qui
était dans l'abbaye de Westminster et
qui un à un prêtait allergence au
nouveau roi là l'archevêque de Quentin
Bury a proposé aux citoyens britanniques
qui ne sont plus officiellement des
sujets de prêter à la légende de leur
côté chez eux ce qui a suscité quelques
controverses quand même parce qu'on
s'est inquiété de du fait que en
démocratie il faille est prêtée
allégeance au roi c'est pour que il a
insisté que c'était volontaire donc
chacun
ce moment avec son fils je trouve que
c'est le moment le plus émouvant d'une
cérémonie qui en est peut-être un petit
peu dénuée je dis pas ça de manière
négatives je pense qu'on est plus dans
la solennité que vraiment dans l'émotion
en plus intime mais c'est vrai que ce
moment donc le prince William qui a
prêté serment
il a pris part à l'hommage de sang royal
qui est prévu dans la literie dans la
liturgie du sacre je crois qu'on l'a
peut-être pas vu à l'image mais la place
et ses mains dans celle de son père et
surtout se baiser à la fin
c'est quand même très symbolique je me
demande si même le prince Charles on a
pas vu la trace peut-être une petite
larme ou en tout cas quelque chose de
vraiment le passé d'une émotion très
forte sur son visage considérant ce qui
se passe avec ces deux fils avec le
prince Harry qui imparilla aujourd'hui
je pense que là c'est non seulement la
continuité de la monarchie mais quelque
chose au moment peut-être le plus intime
le couronnement du roi
[Musique]
de l'Alliance juré aujourd'hui
dans son cœur au roi de l'amour afin que
sur de ta protection elle soit couronnée
de ta gracieuse faveur par Jésus-Christ
notre Seigneur AMEN
recevez le sapre Royal
le bâton d'équité et de miséricorde
en sagesse et en grâce afin que par
votre service et votre ministère la
justice et la miséricorde soient visible
sur toute la terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous assistons donc au couronnement de
la reine reine d'Angleterre oui c'est le
terme qu'il faut utiliser la reine
d'Angleterre et justement ça couronne
qui ressemble au fond tout à fait à
celle du roi nous montre que justement
la singularité de la monarchie c'est que
c'est une au fond c'est pas un homme
seul qui est couronné c'est une famille
et cette dimension familiale qui ressort
de manière un peu spectaculaire ici
finalement
voilà elle est la reine elle est avec le
roi et ils sont
les chefs de cette famille royale qui
dirige les autres familles du royaume
qui voilà et qui se conçoit en tant que
tel de même ce qui était évidemment tout
à l'heure tout à fait intéressant c'est
justement le le fait que juste après
l'archevêque de cantobori représentant
l'église et donc Dieu
la religion la loi suprême ce soit le
fils le fils aîné le successeur qui
viennent après l'archevêque prêté
serment je pense que le comme dans tous
les rituels finalement l'ordre
le passage le la succession est
extrêmement importante finalement et
tout au fond voilà tout un sens
cette image après 70 ans de la reine et
Elizabeth II c'est donc désormais la
reine Kamila est-ce que ça vous paraît
bizarre à dire l'oreille ce n'est pas la
reine dans le même sens quand même
évidemment que tout le monde conscient
de de ça d'ailleurs se reprend
strictement technique je ne sais pas si
le terme se sont véritable titre
simplement run ou reine consort
d'ailleurs alors apparemment le mot
consort a été retiré dans dans l'usage
courant mais je me demande si
juridiquement il n'y a une subsiste pas
je n'ai pas de réponse à la question en
tout cas il y a cette dimension féminée
familiale et comme le fait gros magazine
afin ressortir hier
c'est à l'époque de Victoria qui était
reine pendant 73 ans que la dimension
familiale de le royauté a pris de
l'importance au Royaume Uni et son mari
Albert avait le titre de prince pas de
roi mais il était quand même une figure
importante
[Musique]
pour elle à titre personnel ils étaient
très très liés mais également
symboliquement donc on a quand même dans
une continuité par rapport à tout ça je
pense que on lui a donné c'est Elisabeth
qui a décidé qu'elle aura le titre de
Rennes c'était pour
renforcer la situation parce que au
départ se positionne était un peu
précaire
le dernier conjoint Marie de la reine
d'Angleterre le dernier conjoint donné
des souverains en Angleterre n'était pas
roi non
et comme je disais Prince Albert non
plus de le mari de Victoria
bonjour chroniqueur
histoire au Figaro TV
c'est la première chose que je demande à
chacun de ceux qui entrent sur ce
plateau
ce que vous ressentez devant ces images
ça c'est extraordinaire on a attendu
depuis 1953 90 % des terriens n'avaient
pas connu de sacres il n'était pas pané
au moment de ce couronnement du 2 juin
53 donc forcément c'est assez
extraordinaire c'est une date qui
entrera dans les livres d'histoire
c'est magnifique couronne aussi
[Musique]
le roi et la reine qui viennent de
s'isoler dans la chapelle-saint-édouard
le roi va se changer désormais pour
porter normalement vous le verrons dans
un instant une robe de velours violet
Frédéric on a assisté tout à l'heure
une image que nous pouvons presque pas
concevoir en France
le Premier ministre britannique qui
n'est pas chrétien a prononcer un
discours un extrait de la Bible au cours
de cette cérémonie
alors on a beaucoup parlé de l'animation
religieuse et effectivement on est en
plein dedans non seulement à cause du
lieu à cause des officiers etc mais
voilà
l'une des caractéristiques de Charles à
mon sens et ce qui fait
aussi son intérêt c'est que il est
[Musique]
c'est un roi
qui s'intéresse énormément à la
spiritualité ou religieux
c'est presque un roi philosophe à
certains égards
et il a il a dit il a écrit beaucoup de
choses déjà au sujet de cette de cette
dimension là on assistance sur le la
nécessité de dépasser le matérialisme
les
effectivement son assistance sur le fait
que les différentes religions présentes
sur le
le territoire du Royaume-Uni doivent
être représentés et
voilà elles sont effectivement là c'est
l'une des nouveautés au fond c'est
son idée c'est que
ces différentes manifestations de la
spiritualité ces différents dépassements
du matérialisme ont tous une valeur pour
autant on reste dans une dimension
chrétienne
c'est lorbe nous l'a bien montré avec la
grande surmontée par la par la Croix
voilà c'est un
il reste par ailleurs le chat de lisons
il est il est un prince il y a que
chrétien finalement
et du reste le drapeau de la
Grande-Bretagne le montre clairement
donc il y a cette double dimension il y
a la fois
le Seigneur soit avec vous et avec votre
esprit tournez vers lui vocale nous les
tournons vers le Seigneur
notre Dieu il est juste et bon de le
faire
il est juste bon et il est de notre
devoir de te rendre grâce en doutant et
en tout lieu Seigneur perçait Dieu
tout-puissant et éternel par
Jésus-Christ
confisque unique notre Seigneur
en cet instant consacré ton serviteur
Charles pour qu'il soit notre roi
qu'il soit le défenseur de ta foi et le
protecteur de ton peuple afin qu'avec
lui nous puissions apprendre les voix du
service de la compassion et de l'amour
que tu as commencé en lui aujourd'hui
soit mené à son terme au jour de
jésus-christes et avec toute la
compagnie des cieux nous louons et
magnifions ton ongle glorieux nous te
louons toujours et nous disons
[Musique]
le roi qui est donc revenu dans cette
abbaye de Westminster après cette isolée
quelques instants dans la chapelle
Saint-Grégoire poltomson est-ce que
Charles III aura un état de grâce est-ce
que pendant quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques mois sa cote de
popularité va grimper parce qu'elle est
pas très haute est-ce qu'il aura en
forme de pouvoir Dora sur le peuple
britannique pas tant que ça
je pense que la réponse courte est oui
la magnificence de cette de cette
cérémonie et son importance historique
va frapper les esprits de la plupart des
gens je pense
en ce qui concerne là où il en était
même avant le couronnement je pense que
il a quand même
je suis bien faire son travail à semer
son rôle et que il n'était pas je n'ai
pas les dernières sondages mais il a
plutôt réussi à s'installer c'est
quelqu'un qui a une capacité d'aller
vers les gens même quand il est à une
situation de foot qui parle très bien
et donc
je crois que même avant aujourd'hui sont
son règne plutôt bien bien démarré ceci
ne fera que renforcer cette tendance
nous sommes utile merci beaucoup on a vu
merci de nous avoir
accompagné pendant quelques minutes
quelques heures même lors de
ce couronnement 8 Brandon vous allez
dire quelque chose qu'on a vu la ferveur
hier avec ce bain de foule forcément
déjà il y avait quelque chose et même à
l'étranger il y a eu nombreux sondages
qui ont été réalisés ces derniers jours
notamment en France où la cote de
popularité est assez importante
à toi Dieu notre Père céleste qui
partait tendre miséricorde à donner ton
fils unique Jésus-Christ afin qu'il
souffrit la mort sur la croix pour notre
rédemption qui par cela par cette seule
offrande de lui-même a fait un sacrifice
une offrande et un témoignage plein
parfait et suffisant pour les péchés du
monde entier et en institué et dans son
sainte évangile ordonné que nous
perpétuions le souvenir de sa précieuse
mort jusqu'à son retour
exaucez-nous Père miséricordieux nous
vous en supplions très humblement et
accordez-nous par la puissance de votre
Saint-Esprit qu'en recevant ses
créatures de pain et de vins selon la
sainte institution de ton Fils Notre
Sauveur Jésus-Christ
en mémoire de sa mort et de sa passion
nous puissions avoir part à son corps et
à son sang très béni
[Musique]
dans la nuit même où il fut livré pris
du pain
et après avoir rendu grâce le rompit
et le donna à ses disciples en disant
prenez manger
donner pour vous
faites ceci en mémoire de moi
après la scène il prit la coupe après
avoir rendu grâce il leur donna à boire
en disant buvez-en tous
car ceci est mon sang le sang de la
Nouvelle Alliance répandue pour vous et
pour la multitude en rémission des
péchés
toutes les fois que vous en boirez en
mémoire de moi
Seigneur et Père céleste nous tes
humbles serviteurs nous souvenant de la
mort précieuse et de la passion de ton
cher fils de sa puissance résurrection
et de sa glorieuse ascension désirant
entièrement ta bonté maternelle de bien
vouloir accepter notre sacrifice de
louange et d'action de grâce en te
prions très humblement d'accorder à ce
sacrifice le bénéfice d'un traitement
équitable par les mérites et la mort de
ton Fils Jésus-Christ et par la foi en
son sang que nous et toutes nos église
puissions obtenir leur émission de nos
péchés et tous les autres bienfaits de
ta passion et bien que nous soyons
indignés à cause de nos multiples péchés
de t'offrir un quelconque le sacrifice
nous te supplions d'accepter notre
devoir et notre service qui nous lie
nous en soupes en le mérite mais de nos
fautes et de nous accorder à nous qui
participons à cette sainte communion
d’être comblée de ta grâce et de ta
bénédiction céleste par Jésus-Christ
notre Seigneur par qui avec qui et en
qui dans l'unité du Saint-Esprit
toute gloire Père tout-puissant dans les
siècles des siècles Amen
dans notre langue
avec confiance comme notre Sauveur nous
l'a enseigné
enfin
notre Père qui est au ciel que ton nom
soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne que
ta volonté soit faite sur la terre comme
au ciel donne-nous aujourd’hui notre
pain de ce jour pardonne-nous nos
offenses comme nous pardonnons aussi à
ceux qui nous ont offensés et ne nous
soumettent pas à la tentation mais
délivre-nous du mal
donc c'est à toi qu'appartiennent le
règne la puissance et la gloire pour les
siècles des siècles Amen
[Musique]
13h30 de nous sommes toujours en direct
pour suivre ce couronnement du roi
Charles III il a été couronné la
l'Office continue la cérémonie continue
avant que le roi ne retourne à bord de
son carrosse pour la procession du
couronnement jusqu'à Buckingham Palace
nous sommes toujours en direct avec
Brandon Noiret et avec Frédéric
robellois Frédéric une question il est
très rare de voir la religion le
christianisme entrait comme ça dans le
quotidien des gens avec autant de fastes
c'est assez rare à quel moment lorsque
un pape décède et qui a un nouveau est
nommé ou ça c'est rare là le monde
entier a les yeux sur cette religion là
et qui prend toute la place
[Musique]
la monarchie anglaise même dans sa
version moderne même dans la version
finalement très tolérante et très
ouverte aux autres spiritualités qui
qu'a voulu le roi Charles
reste une non archi chrétienne voilà
c'est
et Charles est un roi chrétien tous les
attributs du pouvoir tous les éléments
qu'on voit ici nous montre bien qu'on
est dans cette dans cette logique dans
cette tradition là dans cette identité
chrétienne voilà on glose depuis
longtemps sur la de l'identité
chrétienne de l'Union de l'Europe ou de
l'Union européenne là les choses sont
absolument claires et évidentes
la Grande-Bretagne
si accueillante soit elle pour les
autres spiritualités demeure
effectivement un royaume chrétien d'où
effectivement la la présence
voilà de à chaque ceux de chaque seconde
de cette de cette dimension et
dans chacun de ces rites dans chacun de
ces moments dans chacune de ces paroles
avec en plus effectivement le
ce souci effectivement particulier de
Charles notamment par exemple son
attachement à l'orthodoxie qu'on a
évoqué à deux trois mois par son
grand-père par sa grand-mère etc tout ça
ce sont des choses qui sont
très très très frappante
Bandon un mot oui non mais c'était
effectivement le christianisme est à
l'honneur et d'ailleurs c'est la raison
pour laquelle Winston Churchill avait
refusé que les caméras entre dans cette
dans cette abbaye en 1953 et c'est
justement Elisabeth avait un peu obligé
le le Premier ministre à l'époque et
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle les
chefs d'État étrangers n'étaient pas
présents aucun représentant de la France
était là en 1953 parce qu'on voulait que
ça reste très intime très personnel
cette cérémonie qui fait appel à
l'histoire on s'appuie sur l'histoire on
la revendique on la montre très
clairement avec toujours comme les
effets Frédéric tout à l'heure ces
symboles sur lesquels on s'appuie
effectivement et puis là on est à près
de 1000 ans après le premier
couronnement de Guillaume le Conquérant
en 1066 donc forcément il y a quelque
chose mais il se veut avant tout moderne
on le voit bien par les tenues de la
plupart des personnes présentes dans
l'abbaye donc il veut aussi casser les
codes et d'ailleurs on le voit aussi par
rapport certes le prix de cette de cette
cérémonie de secouronnement est assez
exorbitant mais par rapport à tout ce
que va embaucher le gouvernement
ça sera beaucoup moins important
[Musique]
Dieu éternel
veuille toujours nous t'en supplions
dirigé sanctifier et gouverner nos cœurs
et nos corps selon tes lois et dans
l'accomplissement de tes commandes grâce
à ta puissance de protection afin que
nous soyons préservés ici et toujours
dans notre corps et dans notre âme par
notre Seigneur et Sauveur Jésus-Christ
AMEN
notre secours est dans le nom du
Seigneur qui a fait le ciel et la terre
que le nom du Seigneur soit béni
aujourd'hui désormais et dans les
siècles des siècles
Christ notre roi
rendez-vous fidèle et forts pour faire
sa volonté afin de régner avec lui dans
la gloire et que la bénédiction de Dieu
tout-puissant le Père le Fils et le
Saint-Esprit repose sur vous et sur tous
ceux que vous servez
aujourd'hui
et tous les jours
[Musique]
juste avant que nous interrompions pour
écouter l'archevêque de Canterbury qui
préside cette cérémonie et qui donne la
bénédiction finale on s'approche de la
fin de cette cérémonie religieuse du
couronnement du roi à l'abbaye de
Westminster vous me disiez que la
monarchie
et la famille royale allait bénéficier
très largement
de cette ce qu'on voit et de ce que des
millions de personnes voient aujourd'hui
oui déjà ne serait-ce que hier juste sur
la journée d'hier il y a eu 225
l'équivalent 225 millions d'euros dans
les goodies achetés partout dans Londres
déjà rien que pour ça oui on parle de
entre 115 millions et 250 millions
environ d'argent dépensés pour la
cérémonie c'est quatre fois plus que
celle du 2 juin 53 mais on aura beaucoup
plus et d'ailleurs ça ça va continuer
j'ai vu que les sur internet les sites
exposés de vente notamment sur
différents plateformes en France ça
exposé ça se vendait un peu partout du
coup il y aura des répercussions assez
importantes et sans doute historiques
parce qu'on parle même si cette histoire
de chiffres paraissent en soi absolument
aberrantes et un peu scandaleuse mais
moi je sais qu'une élection
présidentielle française
la démocratie
j'ai entendu des économistes qui
expliquaient que ça allait rapporter
probablement autour de 9 milliards alors
correction présidentielle ça rapporte
rien sauf éventuellement au candidats
mais voilà
mais si on compte on tient compte de
l'inflation les précédents couronnements
notamment de George VI font encore
d'Edouard 7 on comptait beaucoup plus
cher
c'était sans doute le faste du faste et
la reine Victoria surtout c'est
l'équivalent je crois de 2 milliards
aujourd'hui d'euros c'est extrêmement et
surtout que nous sommes en 1838 donc
alors qu'aujourd'hui en 2023 oui ça
coûtait excessivement cher mais si on
compte bien sûr de l'inflation
nous sommes dans un
royaume un pays en crise alors toute
l'Europe est probablement en crise mais
c'est un pays l'Angleterre le
Royaume-Uni particulièrement touché par
la crise en ce moment
le roi Charles III le c ça doit être il
ne peut pas être hors-sol lors de cette
cérémonie il y a un équilibre juste
milieu à trouver entre le symbolique le
sacré montré que oui il reste le roi
dans une famille royale importante mais
qu'il comprend les gens et qu'il ne peut
pas tout se permettre
moi je pense pas je pense pas bon soit
de je pense pas que ce soit la caisse de
la raison de la relative modernisation
et modestie de la chose c'est pas une
question de popularité d'image c'est une
cérémonie qui est préparée depuis des
années des années qui voulait pas n'est
pas dans justement
je pense qu'il doit se dire voilà je
suis un bon arc âgé
on va se la jouer un petit peu dans une
relative sobriété et ça correspond au
personnage vous connaissez
on connaît les photos de du prince
Charles enfin voilà parce que ce qu'il
aime faire c'est s'occuper de ces de de
son de ses parcs de ces plans de ces
animaux fausses il va pas il va pas il
passe pas son temps effectivement de se
dans le jet privé et sur des dans des
regards si vous voulez il est pas voilà
c'est pas c'est pas c'est l'anti bling
bling ça donc je crois que c'est un peu
ça qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en
compte il est il est dans son rôle il
est dans une approche
conservatrice modérée typiquement
british finalement
bref c'est pas les miens du Qatar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
13h46 nous sommes toujours en direct
pour suivre une couronnement du roi
Charles III nous avons écouté profité
d'un moment historique 70 ans que le
monde pas seulement le Royaume-Uni le
monde n'avait pas connu ça de Brandon
noir est toujours avec Frédéric
robillois et nous sommes aussi en duplex
à distance avec Philippe Viguier
Desplats grand reporters au Figaro on
reste évidemment sur ces images de la
cérémonie mais j'ai quelques questions à
Philippe et comme à tous ceux qui sont
venus et qui interviennent dans cette
émission spéciale Philippe
quel est votre ressenti quel est votre
sentiment devant ces images
je trouve que c'est beau déjà on est
dans une société où souvent on exalte un
peu le vulgaire
et là je trouve que on est de plein pied
dans un beau spectacle dans quelque
chose qui est beau qui nous renvoie avec
une part de sacré à quelque chose d'un
peu grand un peu d'un peu inspirant
voilà et je trouve que ça c'est déjà
quelque chose de formidable après
c'est par un gars c'est drôle parce que
ça pourrait être ringard mais ça ne
l'est pas c'est juste un peu désuet mais
c'est pas ringard et je pense que c'est
dû
au fait que il y a une véritable
dimension historique comme si finalement
ces images qu'on voit aujourd'hui nous
viennent de loin de très loin de plus de
1000 ans et dans une espèce de
continuité et c'est ça qui me fait plus
rêver que tout le reste
c'est intéressant de randonne ce que dit
Philippe Viguier c'est à dire que il y a
des places c'est à dire que on pourrait
presque imaginer que cette cérémonie a
eu lieu il y a 500 ans on se dit que
c'est exactement la même chose alors
peut-être que le costume des costumes
des invités sont un peu différent mais
sinon c'est la même chose oui on peut
dire un peu ça effectivement mais je
sais pas vous mais j'ai remarqué quand
même que tout se passe bien en cette
cérémonie jusque là alors on a on a là
il faut penser quand même à l'archevêque
qui lui a une pression phénoménale parce
que tous ces prédécesseurs ont toujours
eu des problèmes quand on pense à Edward
7 avec l'archevêque Frédéric temple qui
avait fait un malaise qui était à moitié
aveugle qui n'arrivait pas à mettre la
couronne sur la tête du roi ou quand on
repense aussi à 1781 genre je crois qui
arrive en retard on avait perdu les
regalia et là il y a eu des personnes
qui faisaient des malaises un peu
partout la reine Victoria il y a aucun
aucune aucun aucune préparation aucun
test donc tous les tort il y a des
problèmes partout et justement il avait
dit dans une interview pas très
longtemps à la BBC que il a relu les
livres d'histoire et c'est bien préparé
pour ne pas faire d'erreur par rapport
c'est prédécesseurs non pas d'erreur on
a presque senti tout à l'heure je sais
pas si vous avez vu Frédéric en arrivant
le roi qui était un peu hésitant il a
demandé ce qu'il devait dire ce qu'il
devait faire
étonnant pour un homme qui comme on le
dit c'est préparé 74 ans pour ce moment
oui en même temps on fait ça qu'une fois
hein
les mots sont tellement vous avez
remarqué également que lorsque
le et le prince William ont prêté
serment ils disaient un petit papier
qu'il avait été préparé donc voilà ça
s'invente pas
oui on apprend pas par cœur ce qu'il y a
ce qu'il y a à dire mais on l'a senti
peut-être un peu stressé par cet
événement le roi Charles III Philippe
billets des places ce roi qui a
tellement attendu est-ce que c'est vrai
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il t'a attendu
pendant des années d'être roi ou bon non
il s'est contenté de son titre de prince
le temps qu'il aura fallu sans contenter
oui effectivement c'est un métier qui
qui nécessite de la patience pour
pouvoir l'atteindre moi ce qui m'amuse
aussi un petit peu c'est que je me dis
que quand on voit la manière dont il
s'installe dans cette fonction royale je
me dis que c'est successeurs vont devoir
peut-être attendre autant parce que
peut-être qu'effectivement
ce roi va
rester sur le trône jusqu'à sa mort et
peut-être que Kate et William
monteront sur le trône va plutôt William
et Kate monteront sur le trône
de de manière aussi tardive
que leur père et mon père je trouve ça
assez je trouve ça assez amusant mais
c'est effectivement la magie de ces de
ces monarchies qui sont des monarchies
divines jusqu'à la mort
parce qu'on a entendu souvent oh il ne
restera 10 ans puis il s'adresse à sa
place oui il a pas l'air d'être dans
cette optique là
non non je pense pas que ce sera Charles
le bref je pense que il va prendre goût
à la fonction vous avez un jour dans une
interview la reine de Danemark m'avait
dit c'est la fonction qui fait le roi et
je pense que je pense que c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire je pense
qu'il va s'installer dans la fonction il
va y prendre goût et ben s'inscrire dans
la durée et
imagine pas forcément démissionner et je
pense que aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
pas un jour de fête pour William et Kate
on retourne à s'imprégner de l'ambiance
et vivre ce qu'il se passe dans cette
abbaye de Westminster la cérémonie
touche à sa fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
frédéric Rouvillois est-ce que ça vous
étonne de voir si peu à l'image le roi
Charles III on le voit peu on le voit
quasiment pas vous voyez là ça fait
plusieurs minutes qu'on voit les cœurs
qu'on voit les autres représentants des
différents cultes
on ne le voit pas ouais votre question
était intéressante et
signifiante c'est ça il est il c'est
l'institution en fait qui qui importe
pas seulement
pas seulement la personne on disait tout
à l'heure apprendre la reine que au fond
c'est la famille oui au-delà de la
famille au-delà de la personne du roi
c'est l'institution c'est la couronne en
fait c'est le Crown qui est qui est
présent et qui se manifeste là
c'est ce que vous aussi vous vous
étonnez de voir aussi peu Charles III à
l'antenne à l'image
là on le voit déjà plus qu'on voyait ta
mère à l'intérieur de Westminster
il y a 70 ans je crois que une des
challenges de ce couronnement c'est de
garder aussi une partie sacrée une
partie un peu mystérieuse et de ne pas
de ne pas tout montrer tout exposé et
c'est sans doute aussi pour ça que
l'image du roi l'image du roi se fera et
puis on a les yeux que finalement on
ceux qui sont à l'intérieur de la
cathédrale de Westminster comme si le
fait d'être juste téléspectateur
n'ajoutez pas un privilège
supplémentaire mais je suis obligé de
faire écouter à nos internautes à ceux
qui nous regardent sur YouTube sur Le
Figaro.fr sa team god save the king
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sans doute c'est sans doute une
des images qui restera et qui marquera
le roi avançant avec cette nouvelle
couronne ce n'est pas la même que celle
posée tout à l'heure sur sa tête par
l'archevêque de Canterbury celle-ci
c'est la c'est la c'est la couronne
impériale des tarifs effectivement
elle est assez récente cette couronne
elle date de 1937 c'était pour le
couronnement de de George aussi
1937 et ensuite effectivement alors
assez légère je trouve que c'est un peu
plus d'un kilo oui celle-là elle est
plus légère oui beaucoup plus bon on le
voit bien avec Charles il a l'air de
bien se tenir mais beaucoup un kilo de
moins que celle de Saint-Éloi
effectivement il a aussi
porte aussi la robe de succession faut
pas la confondre avec celle du début de
la cérémonie la robe d'État c'est la
même robe que
celle que portait son grand-père George
VI lors de lors de son couronnement
d'ailleurs si cette couronne à les
porter tous les ans au mois de mai pour
l'ouverture de la session parlementaire
donc il la connaît il la connaîtra mais
alors il l'a déjà fait ce discours du
Trône sans doute pas avec la couronne
puisqu'il n'était pas roi il y a un an
de cela lorsque ça mer était malade il
avait pour la première fois prononcer ce
discours du Trône pour l'ouverture du
Parlement Philippe Viguier Desplat cette
image elle est marquante on se
souviendra à la fin de la journée
peut-être du moment où une couronne est
déposée sur la tête du roi Charles III
et là cette procession avec le god save
the king l'orbe dans la main gauche et
cette couronne impériale sur la tête
oui il y a toute la toute la monarchie
britannique qui est résumée dans cette
image effectivement il faut pas oublier
que cette couronne c'est aussi la
couronne de 14 autres pays sur lequel le
roi règne désormais c'est pas seulement
la couronne d'Angleterre et donc ça
renvoie à cette à la grandeur de
l'empire et ça c'est vraiment la force
et le génie de cette monarchie
britannique que de se rappeler au bon
souvenir de cette grandeur à travers le
commonwells alors que l'on sait que le
Royaume-Uni n'est plus aujourd'hui
une des plus grandes puissances du monde
[Musique]
on est un peu fasciné il faut le dire
effectivement des images et de l'émotion
donc
[Musique]
le roi qui va aller
je vous interroge qui va aller se faire
saluer par les représentants des autres
cultes les chefs des autres religions
au Royaume-Uni
c'est ça lui en tant que roi chrétien il
est salué mais ça c'est pas c'est pas
anodin hein ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est son choix d'intégrer toutes les
communautés même si évidemment nous
venons d'assister à deux heures de
cérémonie chrétienne absolument
de toute façon c'est un fait c'est une
part
c'est la réalité la Grande-Bretagne
contemporaine mais enfin au fond c'était
déjà la réalité de la Grande-Bretagne
d'avant enfin lent avec du temps de
l'empire du temps de ça de sa mère ou de
ses de de son grand-père ont été déjà le
cas
[Musique]
et puis
hindouedistes ils sont tous présents au
sein de l'Empire jadis si vous voulez ça
change pas et puis cette dimension
multiple effectivement qui nous est déjà
à nous un petit peu français cartésien
issus d'un système immunitaire depuis
toujours
ça a toujours été présent au fond dans
la dans l'histoire de la Grande-Bretagne
donc et de l'Angleterre
le roi qui va donc sortir de cette
abbaye de Westminster et il y est arrivé
il y a un peu plus de deux heures tu
vois il y a un peu de retard deux
minutes de retard on nous avait promis
cérémonie millimétrée bon évidemment
avec Elisabeth c'était bien plus
et donc le roi qui va donc maintenant
revenir à Buckingham Palace alors à
l'époque Brandon enfin à l'époque il y a
70 ans on avait fait un parcours
beaucoup plus long pour la reine
d'Angleterre peut-être qu'il fallait la
montrer au lendemain qu'il fallait la
montrer aux Anglais aujourd'hui tout le
monde a un écran 2 km ça suffira pour
voir Charles III oui effectivement
c'était beaucoup plus long c'était le
but effectivement de montrer à tout le
peuple de montrer l'importance de la
monarchie britannique au reste du monde
c'était le premier le premier
couronnement filmé donc forcément c'est
très important vous voyez ce alors ce
carrosse ce n'est pas le même que lors
de la procession du roi donc là nous
entrons désormais dans la procession du
couronnement
c'est le fameux gold state coach lui
c'est le carrosse emblématique Brandon
oui emblématique effectivement
historique alors on dit gold en or en
fait il est pas vraiment en or il est en
bois mais il y a un petit une petite
marque d'or dessus mais il est
extrêmement important d'ailleurs
historiquement il est il a une très
grande histoire il date de 1761 il avait
été commandé par le roi George III pour
pour le mariage avec Charlotte en 170
fin 1761 sauf que le problème il y a eu
des problèmes de de d'organisation de
création donc il l'a pas utilisé il a
utilisé un an plus tard en 1762 pour le
mariage de sa fille il a aussi ouvert la
session parlementaire avec avec ce
carrosse et le premier roi couronné avec
ce carreau ce sera en 1831 avec notre
Guillaume 4
et d'ailleurs il a marqué les esprits et
la reine Elizabeth avait dit à quelques
années elle avait repris ses mots parce
qu'il avait dit en montant dans ce
carrosse il avait l'impression de se
retrouver dans une mer agitée au fin
fond d'une tempête tellement
Elizabeth II en 53 d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle aussi il y a qu'une
partie on fait juste le retour direction
un Buckingham Palace tellement c'est
inconfortable et pour peut-être aussi le
fait que il est il n'était pas couronné
avant oui c'est ça voilà exactement une
fois couronné il a le droit au total si
je veux
ce carrosse alors vous dites mère agitée
sachez que il est orné de trophées qui
rappellent les succès maritimes
britanniques face à qui à sophro
français effectivement on a aussi des
chérubins et trois chérubins qui
représentent l'Angleterre l'Écosse
et l'Irlande et justement il y a George
VI
il s'est dit bon pour son pour sans
doute sa fille Elisabeth il a orné on va
le voir justement après il y a une sorte
de recouvrement en bois au niveau des
roues pour que ce soit un peu plus
confortable bon visiblement en 1953 des
bandes de caoutchoucs
de fer exactement le faire était
tellement inconfortable on le voit plus
de 7 mètres de long un poids de 4 tonnes
8 chevaux alors que c'était 6 pour le
carence moderne de l'allée Philippe
vivier des places vous aviez une
remarque à faire sur ce carrosse
[Applaudissements]
c'était une pensée pour nos amis les
bêtes parce que il va falloir maintenant
tirer sur deux kilomètres et 4 tonnes
avec ces 8 chevaux qui n'est pas une
masse à faire
c'est très impressionnant ce carrosse
tous les matins
il y a quelques années et justement elle
a fait une session supplémentaire ce
matin c'est plutôt pour parce qu'il y a
des problèmes de lombaire et on a on est
obligé d'avoir des séances avec un kiné
juste après tellement que que les chocs
c'est un calvaire
prenez une boîte dites-vous 1761 quand
même c'est
la servitude du pouvoir et de la
monarchie il faut souffrir votre roi
Philippe Viguier déplace on refuse
d'être moderne quand on est monarque il
pourrait prendre une belle voiture
anglaise une belle Rolls Royce non non
on continue à monter dans un carrosse
oui mais ce carrosse n'est pas seulement
à Carros c'est le véhicule de l'histoire
de la Grande-Bretagne et c'est donc
normal que le roi ils prennent place
vu comme ça vu comme ça mais avant cela
on se déplaçait pas forcément je sais
pas je me dis peut-être que il y a des
avancées et que un roi doit vivre avec
son temps bon il y a une seule personne
qui a voulu casser les codes et ne pas
utiliser ce carrosse c'est la reine
Victoria ah oui ne voulait pas d'accord
il n'y arrivait pas et c'était trop mal
au dos
nous allons suivre donc cette oui
allez-y Philippe
le roi ne se promène pas tous les jours
en carrosse c'est juste pour pour cette
cérémonie je vous rassure il a une
écurie de Rolls-Royce tout à fait
performante qu'il utilise régulièrement
c'est d'ailleurs assez rare c'est pas je
pense pas que ce soit un roi qui soit
très attaché justement au landau au
carrosse etc on verra ce sera
intéressant dans quelques jours en juin
si il participe à Hilton Paston
au mascotte au Royal Ascot t vous savez
où le souverain remonte la grande
pelouse centrale jusqu'à la tribune et
il est pas du tout dit que le roi y
participe alors que la reine Elizabeth
c'était une de ces cérémonie favori
c'est le début du de la procession du
couronnement et des 14h07 nous sommes en
direct des milliers de militaires vont
accompagner alors des trois cordes de
l'armée terre mère ils sont tous là la
Royale Neville à Royal Air Force pour
raconter le roi Charles III désormais
couronné à Buckingham Palace pour un peu
plus de 2 km de 2 km et 290 m qui
séparent cette distance qui sépare
l'abbaye de Westminster à Buckingham
Palace je vous ai lu dans le Figaro
Magazine les secrets d'un roi vous
parlez de cette famille royale qui
m'intéressait qui n'a cessé de s'adapter
de concéder pour ne pas subir
oui exactement ça c'est une part de
c'est une part de son génie elle a
toujours réussi à précéder
ce qui pouvait lui arriver par exemple
quand en 1924 le roi
nomme le Premier ministre travailleiste
de l'histoire du Royaume-Uni et bien ça
se fait d'une manière tout à fait
apaisée alors qu'au mêmement nous c'est
le Front populaire et on connaît
l'agitation qu'il s'est emparée des
institutions françaises à ce moment-là
et là c'était pas du tout le cas donc
c'est vrai que par exemple
voit l'impôt sur le revenu lui être
apposé par John Maker de croire en 1993
ben c'est pareil il y a pas de
récrimination il y a pas on s'adapte on
est deux styles et c'est une des
conditions grâce à laquelle cette
monarchie perdure est perdure aussi et
tolérer toujours dans le cœur des
Britanniques il y a d'autres royaumes
vous expliquer que la Suède par exemple
n'a pas su faire ça pendant des
monarchodon parce que les anecdotes sont
très intéressantes
parce que en Suède on a
limité le parlement suédois a limité
tous les pouvoirs du roi le roi de Suède
est un des rois qui a le moins de
pouvoir aujourd'hui
dans son royaume et pire encore quelques
années plus tard on a décidé de
rendre la succession
accessible au 1er-né que ce soit un
garçon et une fille et le l'héritier
était Karl Philippe de Suède et il a été
rétrogradé en deuxième position au
profit de sa sœur qui était née avant
lui mais qui comme était une fille
n'avait pas droit
d'être reine et donc le Parlement a
corrigé ce défaut mais la corriger en
l'appliquant rétroactivement ce qui est
quand même
excessivement humiliant alors c'est vrai
que les Britanniques eux ils sont ils
sont à l'abri de tout parce que il se
complique pas trop la vie et si on leur
impose des choses et bien
ils font le Doron et ils ont pris pour
habitude le fameux never explain never
complet de ne jamais se plaindre de ne
jamais s'expliquer et c'est comme ça que
c'est comme ça que ça marche
une association de couronnement de
Westminster à Buckingham Palace nous
avons vu le roi et la reine dans le Gold
state coach et on aperçu dans un
carrosse plus modeste quoique la
succession le prince le prince William
et son fils le Prince George les futurs
rois d'Angleterre qui suivent toujours
après on les a vu aussi entrer dans la
dans la dans la vie tout à l'heure de
Westminster après leur père après le
après le roi Philippe biguier des places
vous me dites que la monarchie s'adapte
mais quitte à perdre du pouvoir en
perdre énormément n'a plus de pouvoir
cette famille royale ou presque aussi
n'oubliez pas que le souverain et le
conseiller du gouvernement
quand il reçoit le premier ministre
chaque semaine c'est pas le premier
ministre qui vient
imposer ses vues au chef de l'État c'est
le chef de l'État qui l'écoute et qu'il
conseille donc il y a dans ce lien très
secret puisque aucun Premier ministre ne
s'est jamais penché sur ses rendez-vous
mais dans ce lien très secret il y a
effectivement tout le pouvoir que le
souverain a sur sur la sur le
gouvernement du pays et d'ailleurs on
dit que cette son gouvernement on dit
pas que c'est le gouvernement de la
Grande-Bretagne c'est son gouvernement
c'est le gouvernement du roi
ce défiler avec le décor parfait il
pleut à Londres il pleut pas trop juste
assez pour avoir le cadre un brandon ça
c'est parfait comment il y a 70 ans il
avait plu justement il pleuvait
énormément et il y a la reine Élisabeth
qui on lui avait mis une bouillotte très
chaude ah bon en dessous c'est ses
fesses dans le carrosse justement pour
la réchauffer alors je sais pas quelle
est la température alors en plus en plus
qu'ils sont inconfortables il fait froid
mais ça on verra dans quelques jours
avec les résultats de notamment dans la
presse britannique si vraiment on avait
cette bouillotte qui rappelait qui
rappelait la reine Elizabeth est-ce que
Philippe la famille royale alors qu'on
voit ici celui tout le monde et c'est
une des premières fois qu'on le filme
aussi clairement tient cette image du du
prince Harry on a vu arriver seul tout à
l'heure dans l'abbaye de Westminster pas
certain qu'on le revoit plus tard dans
la dans la dans la journée peut-être la
dernière image qu'on verra de lui
Philippe il doit pas monter au balcon
tout à l'heure pour se faire acclamer
par la foule le prince Harry
on verra si je peux pas vous le dire
mais a priori non effectivement ça reste
moi j'étais au Royaume-Uni il y a 15
jours et ça reste vraiment encore le
chéri des anglais c'est à dire que il
lui pardonne beaucoup de choses ça reste
quand même l'enfant qui a beaucoup
souffert il faut pas oublier que cette
famille royale les Anglais grandissent
avec elle vivent avec elle au quotidien
et donc le chagrin de ces deux enfants
après la mort de leur mère le remariage
de leur père toutes ces scandales qui
ont été portés aux yeux du public les
ont marqué profondément et je pense que
il reste les Anglais leur reste très
attaché ce qui n'est pas forcément le
cas pour Mégane évidemment où là les
jugements sont plus nuancés mais Harry
et Williams ça reste quand même et Harry
notamment voilà un peu l'enfant terrible
de la couronne mais c'est aussi le fils
de Diana et et là c'est quelque chose
contre lequel
on peut on peut pas grand chose assez
intéressant faudrait que le choix de la
réalisation internationale de cette de
ce couronnement on voit les deux
carrosses le carrosse royal avec le roi
et la reine le carrosse principe avec
les successeurs et tout seul cette image
de temps à autre du prince Harry qui
paraît là à la fin de cette cérémonie
sur les marches de l'abbaye de
Westminster seul oui oui mais voilà
c'est c'est là encore toute la
complexité et la magie de la chose
Philippe vieillit des places de parler
de voilà c'est ils ont l'impression
d'être que c'est des gens de leur
famille c'est ça on retrouve toujours
cette dimension familiale qui est
absolument essentielle ce qui est en
même temps complètement faux puisque la
famille et l'institution oui oui non
enfin c'est aussi leur famille parce
qu'ils ont comme effectivement ils ont
ils ont grandi avec ils ont vécu avec
ils ont
subi connu les chagrins les amours etc
et donc c'est comme une sorte de petit
frère pour beaucoup de grands frères
pour beaucoup de d'entre eux donc il est
plus dans l'institution plus tout à fait
mais il reste dans la famille il reste
quand même le effectivement le
voilà l'enfant terrible le fils prodigue
Brandon
il va disparaître progressivement
théoriquement des radars le prince Harry
en vieillissant normalement est-ce qu'il
marquera l'histoire d'une certaine
manière ou est-ce que dans 200 ans on se
souviendra pas de lui ça fera on verra
dans quelques années je sais je vous
pose une question à laquelle vous ne
pouvez pas répondre
à tout à l'heure je ne sais pas on avait
parlé dans la presse et ils disent
peut-être une surprise d'autres
personnes qui apparaîtront voilà on
verra en quelques minutes est-ce qu'il y
a déjà eu des scandales avant que la
famille royale soit médiatisée des
scandales dans famille royale
britannique est-ce que vous avez le
souvenir de ça il y a eu des scandales
notamment au balcon ça c'est oui ça on
en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure sans
doute beaucoup plus en profondeur mais
rapidement le balcon c'est assez
historique c'est la reine Victoria qui
est institué la présence au balcon lors
des travaux au milieu 19 jours cette
traîne Victoria vous savez elle a tout
inventé c'est sans doute la raison pour
laquelle elle a redonné du pouvoir à
cette monarchie notamment ses rapports
avec la France et c'est elle qui a voulu
faire ça notamment lors de l'exposition
universelle à Londres en 1851 et le j'en
parlerai plusieurs profondeur mais le
petit la petite polémique c'est 1981 le
mariage de Lady Di avec avec Charles
justement ils se sont embrassés il y a
eu ce bisou et c'était pas prévu ça va
casser un peu les codes de cette
présence au balcon où ça restait des
cérémonies très officielles notamment
liés à la guerre de Crimée liée à la
Première Guerre mondiale
des places Brandon nous parle dans
chacune de ces anecdotes depuis tout à
l'heure de la reine Victoria vous aussi
vous en parler beaucoup dans le Figaro
Magazine c'est le point de départ de
cette famille de cette famille royale
actuellement au pouvoir
alors c'est elle qui a inventé le
concept de famille royale c'est pour ça
finalement qu'elle est importante
c'est elle qui a eu l'idée finalement
d'exposer ta famille pour que les
classes moyennes notamment se
reconnaissent en elle et c'était une
fête c'était une reine qui était d'abord
très unie avec son époux un qu'elle
adorait le prince Albert qui était son
cousin et ils élevaient leurs enfants
ensemble je suis allé dans leur
propriété sur l'île de White et on voit
la nurserie on imagine très bien cette
voilà c'est aussi une monarchie un peu
bourgeoise ça correspond
aussi un peu à l'époque de
Louis-Philippe en France et et elle a
inventé cette famille à l'inventer ce
concept auparavant
le roi s'exposait mais sa famille pas
forcément et donc ça c'est vraiment le
effectivement c'est le point de départ
de la monarchie moderne qui ensuite été
amplifiée par George de 5 puis par les
monarques ceci faut pas oublier quand
même que le roi Charles est le
petit-fils du petit-fils de la reine
Victoria donc finalement c'est pas ce
qui éloigné que ça et d'ailleurs la
reine Victoria en parlant de ce qu'elle
a inventé elle a aussi inventé ce
principe de Never complet les vers
explain parce que sans son fils doit
s’était pas de se plaindre lorsqu'il
était petit et il avait 10 ans il a dit
bon il faut pas se plaindre il faut pas
s'expliquer et il a repris ça et ensuite
c'est parti c'est maintenant c'est
devenu une institution partout dans le
marché Philippe il y avait place c'est
une famille qui a changé de nom aussi
alors faire une histoire
des gens qui sont sur splater
savent tout mais expliquez à nos
internautes parce que c'est ça aussi
c'est une forme de renoncement
alors oui c'est je vous dis
ils étaient capables de tout et
notamment de changer de nom parce que
leur nom qui était celui de la dynastie
des saxo burgotha et évidemment une
dynastie allemande
sont en Allemagne et donc en 1917 à
cause de la de la soute de la Première
Guerre mondiale
beaucoup de familles dont la famille
royale décide d'engliser son nom c'est
pas les seuls il y a le donc eux
s'appelle Windsor ils prennent le nom du
château de Windsor un peu comme les
Bourbons comme si les Bourbon
s'appelaient Versailles et puis il y a
par exemple les baptêmes Berg le prince
Philippe les baptêmes bergs qui étaient
allemands deviennent Mahoud vaten
donc tout le monde en glucine de son nom
pour se différencier du germanisme qui
était plutôt inquiétant dans les années
14-18 mais le vrai élément déclencheur
surtout c'est en juin 1917 lorsque
Londres est bomb il y a eu 150 morts
notamment une vingtaine d’enfants parce
qu'un bombardier allemand s'appelait
Gotha 4 qui rappelle la famille et dans
la dans la presse et l'opinion publique
c'était extrêmement important il fallait
surtout pas donc on a changé on a changé
dynastie et c'est les Windsor qui nous
sommes arrivés toujours en direct 14h20
pour suivre la procession du
couronnement vous avez suivi tout à
l'heure aux alentours de 13h le
couronnement physique du
prince Charles devenu roi Charles III sa
femme Camila est devenue reine également
la symbolique religieuse et maintenant
la fête Frédéric toujours ces deux
notions Dieu et le peuple d'une certaine
manière oui oui tout à l'heure on a
parlé de l'anneau effectivement
l'idée que l'anneau
du roi c'est le mariage à la fois avec
avec Dieu le principe supérieur et avec
le peuple ceux qui vont être gouvernés
les sujets qui vont être voilà le musée
de l'attention du roi donc effectivement
voilà le peuple maintenant une fois que
la
cérémonie religieuse a été a été
célébrée et bien
[Musique]
le peuple est là pour dire sa joie et
pour dire son
justement son allégeance aussi par ce
biais là au nouveau roi est-ce que tout
le peuple britannique aime le roi aime
la royauté il y a des contradicteurs
désormais de plus en plus de
républicains ou en tout cas des jeunes
qui sont moquent qui ne sont pas
forcément intéressés par ça est-ce que
vous connaissez quelque chose que tout
le monde aime non sans exception non bah
voilà j'aurais aimé vous dire moi mais
je suis pas certain
donc effectivement il y a toujours il y
a toujours des rails il y a toujours des
gens qui sont qui sont contre il y a
toujours des gens qui sont pas contents
et bien voilà ça ça arrive ils sont plus
ou moins nombreux plus ou moins mais
voilà tout à l'heure on parlait de
sondages voilà j'ai
la monarchie je peux vous ayez c'est
lentillesse au foot elle a pas grand
chose à faire des sondages ni de ni de
l'instant ni de l'immédiateté et se
situe sur le temps non seulement sur le
temps long mais sur le temps très long
finalement
est-ce que la monarchie est cette
famille royale est un moment cruciale de
son histoire après la mort la
disparition d'Elizabeth II est-ce que là
il peut y avoir une forme de de
rébellion de révolte révolution
évidemment je le terme est fort est-ce
que ça peut arriver est-ce que la
monarchie peut perdre de sa superbe et
un peu plus de son pouvoir
non non je pense pas et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que souvenez-vous les
commentaires qui accompagnaient la mort
de la reine Élisabeth on disait en
quelque sorte que ça allait être la fin
de la monarchie de la même manière on
l'a dit en Espagne avec les scandales
qui ont entacher la fin du règne de Juan
Carlos et on s'aperçoit que finalement
c'est un peu je veux dire on coupe la
tête mais le corps continue à vivre et
une nouvelle tête se forme c'est une
sorte de guide historique
qui qui traverse les siècles et je ne
pense absolument pas que la monarchie
britannique soit en danger elle
transcende toute la société je pense que
les Britanniques qui sont très attachés
alors comme la très bien dit notre ami
tout à l'heure effectivement tout le
monde n'aime pas tout mais
le globalement la monarchie britannique
a de très beaux jours à de très beaux
jours de Noël elle vient de Milan vous
imaginez un pays qui depuis 1000 ans a
la même institution en France nous avons
14 régimes depuis la Révolution
française et en 250 ans à peu près nous
avons eu 14 régimes consulat empire
deuxième république Troisième République
tout ce que vous voulez là depuis 1000
ans c'est la même institution
avec des crises politiques le
Royaume-Uni est en train d'en vivre une
depuis quelques années maintenant et que
peut y faire la reine et que peut y
faire le roi c'est ça que je vous
interroge peut-être un peu par
provocation mais à quoi servent-ils
d'une certaine manière puisqu'ils ne
sont pas capables eux de régler
directement les problèmes politiques
actuels du Royaume-Uni
il y a des crises politiques vous avez
raison de le dire Thibault mais il n'y a
pas de crise institutionnelle jamais
l'Institut n'est remise en cause et la
la l'utilité du monarque c'est de donner
un sens à la nation de l'inspirer et par
exemple souvenez-vous quand il y a eu le
covid la reine Elizabeth était apparue à
la télévision et elle avait rappelé que
le que le royaume avait traversé
beaucoup d'épreuves et notamment la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et son épaisseur
elle avait donc donné un sens à tout ça
et elle elle avait créé une sorte
d'inspiration et c'est vraiment le rôle
de du souverain après la solennité du
couronnement au sein de l'abbaye de
Westminster la fête la joie lors de
cette procession du couronnement dans
les rues de Londres entre donc l'abbaye
et Buckingham Palace entre l'abbaye et
Buckingham Palace il y a qui il y a
Timothée vous êtes avec des Anglais
joyeux heureux on imagine si on ne fait
pas la fête aujourd'hui quand est-ce
qu'on l'a fait
oui des Anglais heureux joyeux et
courageux aussi parce que ils ont bravé
la pluie aujourd'hui depuis ce matin
beaucoup de monde si bien qu'on a du
s'éloigner un petit peu pour des
questions de connexion mais vous les
voyez ils sont là ils sont derrière moi
un petit peu moins de monde que ce matin
avant le début de la cérémonie parce que
il pleut depuis ce matin donc voilà
certains et bien sont repartis dans les
rues adjacentes qui elles sont encore
plein de pleine de monde sur cette place
travelgar où je où je me trouve vous
voyez donc ce sont plusieurs centaines
de personnes qui attendent désormais et
bien la suite des festivités on a vu ils
ont pu suivre cette cérémonie on les a
entendus en particulier à 13h heure
française midi ici à Londres lorsque et
bien le roi Charles III a été
officiellement couronné et bien des
gothers
authenti de depuis la foule depuis cette
depuis cette place parce que évidemment
les Anglais ont pu suivre la cérémonie
grâce aux enceintes déployées pour
l'occasion et puis nous avons pu
évidemment discuter avec certains qui
nous disent comme souvent que ils
attendent de voir le roi que cela
signifie beaucoup pour eux tout cela
dans une ambiance très festive et très
joyeuse un petit mot Thibault simplement
parce que vous parliez tout à l'heure je
vous entendais demander à l'un de vos
invités en plateau aussi et tout le
monde célébrer Charles III et bien comme
nous vous le disions ce matin il y a
également il faut bien le dire une
petite cinquantaine de de républicains
qui sont réunis juste derrière moi
peut-être voyez-vous ces drapeaux jaune
drapeau jaune sur lesquels nous pouvons
voir inscrit des slogans du type notre
making voilà ce n'est pas mon pas mon
roi avec donc quelques slogans pour ces
républicains mais en tous les cas une
ambiance très festive ici et très
fraternelle
la princesse Anne qui est elle sur le
cheval derrière elle n'est pas protégée
de la pluie elle qui est très aimée des
Britanniques Philippe Viguier des places
est-ce que la famille royale est le
meilleur soft power du Royaume-Uni parce
que ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui difficile
de faire mieux on parle du sport par
exemple des Américains qui peuvent
réunir des millions de personnes à
travers le monde devant leur super ball
ou autre là des millions de personnes
devant leur famille royale il y a
difficile de faire mieux
[Applaudissements]
ah je crois qu'on a perdu Philippe il
est pas parce que je vous la pose à vous
la question est-ce que la famille royale
est le meilleur soft power du
Royaume-Uni écoutez vous parlez de
millions ça c'est des milliards donc
dans un autre registre effectivement
est-ce que le meilleur il y en a
d'autres qui l'écran club de foot
anglais ou autre mais effectivement
c'est un autre registre si vous voulez
là encore le terme de soft power me
paraît
non un peu inapproprié par rapport à ça
on a perdu on a récupéré Philippe
Viguier des places Philippe vous
m'entendez
que il n'était pas forcément d'accord
avec ça je vous pose la question est-ce
que la famille royale est meilleur soft
power du Royaume-Uni est-ce que le mot
soft power vous paraît approprié
lorsqu'on voit ces images
je sais pas mais
honnêtement je trouve que
dans cette série
[Musique]
c'est vraiment très peur
je suis assez de notre
on va reprendre parce que pardon
Philippe de vous couper on vous entend
mal on va retrouver la la connexion et
puis on va revenir vers vous évidemment
beaucoup de chefs d'État invités on les
a très peu vus
Frédéric un peu au début lorsque le roi
n'avait pas encore fait son apparition
n'était pas sorti de Buckingham Palace
vu Emmanuel Macron entrée on a vu Jill
Biden par exemple
on les écarte venez vous êtes chez nous
mais en fait on n'est pas là pour vous
montrer non plus
ils sont là comme figurants ce sont les
invités sont pas les maîtres de maison
donc effectivement
montre qu'il y a des invités qui sont
sympathiques qui sont bien élevés etc
mais on va pas s'attarder sur eux c'est
pas
[Musique]
c'est ça que très peu vu à l'image
oui mais je pense que c'est volontaire
et c'est plutôt bien fait c'est d'abord
un événement anglais enfin un événement
de britannique et il n'a qu'un but c'est
mettre plein la vue du monde et là c'est
assez réussi parce que quel est
l'événement
de sportif qui est retransmis dans le
monde entier là on parle du monde entier
je pense qu'il y a pas un pays où il y a
pas une chaîne de télévision qui ne
retransmette les cérémonies du
couronnement c'est quand même incroyable
[Musique]
incroyable absolument d'ailleurs quel
est le poids
du roi sur la scène internationale
Frédéric escompte on peut le l'évaluer
de la reine peut-être parce que elle
elle avait un poids j'imagine qu'elle
était très écoutée de par son expérience
de par sa longévité le roi il aura
peut-être plus de mal à être écouté être
entendu à peser peut-être sur certaines
décisions mondiales ou pas forcément
écoutez je crois que la différence
peut-être
corrigerait sans doute mais entre elle
et lui entre le la mer et son fils c'est
que
lui a vraiment effectivement des je
pense une construction intellectuelle
plus affirmée des idées des convictions
des peut-être des
peut-être des projets notamment voilà il
s'est en tant que Prince de Galles
longtemps présenté comme le prince vert
finalement le prince soucieux de
l'environnement de l'écologie de du
développement durable avec tout un
discours là-dessus voilà
donc il aura peut-être une fête de tir
de ce point de vue là importante et qui
n'intéressait pas ou que n'avait pas
forcément la reine Elizabeth donc au
fond si vous voulez le
tout dépend les circonstances il est
possible que étant donné ce qu'il est ce
qu'il pense
laisser conscience soit finalement
propice à une
certaine intervention dans cet ordre là
selon vous votre avis quel est le poids
international du roi Charles III est-ce
qu'il peut peser sur certaines décisions
mondiales ou pas tant que ça
je pense pas tant que ça c'est un poids
fait honorifique
d'ailleurs c'était également la même
chose pour que sa mère
quand il pèse ça se fait discrètement
peut-être secrètement mais
publiquement
ils n'ont pas un rôle international de
poids
merci beaucoup Philippe Viguier des
places d'être venu
à distance sur notre plateau pour
pouvoir commenter avec nous cette
journée de couronnement je rappelle
qu'on peut vous lire dans Le Figaro
Magazine c'est un je le montre les
secrets d'un roi c'est vous qui avez
fait ce grand dossier ce week-end merci
beaucoup oui la reine d'Angleterre elle
était
pas de pouvoir en tant que tel sur la
personne a été très écoutée il y a plein
d'anecdotes parce que elle avait tout
connu elle avait rencontré tout le monde
et j'imagine que les chefs d'État qui
rencontraient la reine d'Angleterre
était ravi peut-être plus que de
rencontrer à terme sur le prince Charles
ce qui est intéressant en quantité
prince pardon il donnait beaucoup son
avis et ça ça gênait déjà la Couronne
britannique des gens en France quand il
était venu rencontrer François
Mitterrand parce qu'il était extrêmement
passionné par l'histoire française par
l'architecture française francophile
francophone effectivement la reine aussi
avec un bel accent et justement quand il
venait il avait parlé de la construction
européenne en 1992 ça a fait polémique
parce qu'il avait donné son avis il
défendait aussi beaucoup le fromage
français et pour la reine pour la reine
elle est belle
est-ce que le crottin de Chavignol
pourra encore exister c'est ce qu'il
disait au moment des réglementations
européennes dans les années 90 il
défendent aussi beaucoup le bruit de
mots et on a la reine la reine
d'Angleterre elle adorait
particulièrement la France et les chefs
d'État avec François Mitterrand c'était
assez extraordinaire l'histoire parce
que c'était le seul président de la
République française qui connaissait
toutes les dynasties britanniques et ça
elle adoré et même lui d'ailleurs il a
pleuré lors de lors des obsèques de
François Mitterrand le 11 janvier 1996
il était présent à Notre-Dame de Paris
il a pleuré c'est assez rare de voir
quand même un roi un prince quelqu'un de
la monarchie britannique qui pleure ça
c'est assez extraordinaire le Gold state
coach ce fameux carrosse historique qui
vient d'entrer dans dans Buckingham
Palace ça veut dire que
ce couronnement cette grande fête touche
à sa fin il y a encore un grand moment
que tout le monde attend c'est le balcon
évidemment lorsque toute la famille
royale sera au balcon la grande question
Harry il sera t-il
les bookmakers anglais mettent pas une
grosse pièce dessus mais c'est ton
jamais l'autre carross alors celui-ci
j'ai pas le nom le carrosse principe
puisque dans celui-ci on y trouve le
prince William et son fils le Prince
George avec la femme sa femme femme du
Prince William Kate et trois enfants
évidemment qui lui aussi entre dans dans
Buckingham Palace Buckingham
emblématique Brandon oui emblématique et
forcément évidemment là-bas c'était un
hôtel particulier et c'est encore une
fois la reine Victoria qui a choisi
comme a encore oui encore comme
résidence principale dans 150 ans on
dira dans 100 ans on dira c'est la reine
Elizabeth on dirait que c'est la Reine
des Neiges c'est assez incroyable ce
lieu mais le problème de Buckingham
Palace bon là encore aujourd'hui assez
particulier mais ces questions de sa
sécurité il y a eu beaucoup de personnes
qui ont réussi à entrer il y a même une
histoire dans les années 80 où il y a un
homme qui a permis dans la chambre de la
Reine Elizabeth elle s'est réveillée il
y avait un homme à ses côtés et pour
dire à quel point c'est pas du tout un
bunker comme on peut le croire la
sécurité est très mal et très mal placée
et bon évidemment par rapport
aujourd'hui c'est très différent mais il
y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes de
sécurité une dizaine de personnes par an
qui réussissent à pénétrer dans bucking
Impala on essaiera l'année prochaine
Brandon j'y suis allé avec Indian Palace
il y a trois ans
non on peut visiter l'été juillet aoûté
en 2018 je crois et ça sert
extraordinaire notamment les salons
d'apparats on pouvait pas visiter la
chambre de la reine mais c'est assez
incroyable visiblement le cortège a un
peu d'avance peut-être que ce
couronnement aura été plus rapide que
prévu c'est aller vite entre entre
cette famille royale qui va descendre
240 en imagine et qui va monter au
balcon tout à l'heure on retrouve
Timothée Delam Timothée vous êtes dans
la foule au milieu de Londres ah j'ai
l'impression que ça se vide un peu
derrière vous
ouais je vous confirme tout à fait
Thibault ça se vide à vue d’œil cette
cette place alors que les cloches
continuent de retentir en ce jour ce
jour de fête vous le voyez donc les
Londoniens qui sont en train petit à
petit et bien de repartir dans dans le
calme certains restent malgré tout alors
on a dû voilà s'éloigner un peu mais
vous voyez le long des des barrières et
bien on essaye d'apercevoir on reste là
pour profiter de cet instant pour
profiter de ces moments de fête et puis
également pour attendre essayer
d'apercevoir depuis
cet avenue du mal datant et bien on
essaie d'apercevoir la famille royale
qui doit apparaître tout à l'heure en
haut du du balcon ou d'où elle pourra
assister à ce défiler aérien l'objectif
ici pour les plus téméraires et bien
c'est de tenter de pouvoir pénétrer sur
cette avenue 7 avenue du mal qui est qui
est bouclé faute pour pour a pas de
raison de d'affluence voilà on va
essayer de se diriger vers cet avenue du
mal qui est juste juste ici et puis
peut-être également d'apercevoir le roi
le roi Charles III qui doit maintenant
d'ici quelques minutes apparaître
apparaître pour les auprès des des
Londoniens mais vous le voyez en tout
cas il continue d'être ici de de
profiter de ce de ce moment alors que la
pluie vous lisiez continuer de s'abattre
même si c'est assez calme et puis vous
parliez aussi de la température tout à
l'heure 14 15 degrés donc il fait tout
de même assez frais dans les rues de
Londres aujourd'hui
c'est merci Timothée oui essayez de
d'apercevoir profitez-en d'apercevoir le
roi au balcon de Buckingham Palace
beaucoup de militaires aujourd'hui 4000
militaires lors de cette procession dans
les rues de Londres 7000 à travers le
pays ce ne sont pas les forces de
l'ordre là ce sont des militaires
vraiment pour le défilé pour la
cérémonie
ils sont très présents on le voit ici
c'est eux qui finissent une certaine
manière qui clôture d'une certaine
manière le spectacle de cette procession
du couronnement je vous propose qu'on
écoute les cornemuses le défilé des
gardes comment les appelle déjà les gars
devant donne avec le chapeau les oui
bien sûr j'ai plus de nom mais tout le
monde c'est ça
vous avez raison exactement chercher le
nom merci beaucoup vous avez vu un
spécialiste qui a répondu
on écoute en Suisse qui se passe sur
cette place devant Buckingham Palace on
va dans un instant bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était agréable de profiter de
ces cornemuse et de
cette armée britannique c'est notre
pensée au 14 juillet ça auprès on s'en
approchant un peu bonus aussi
le 14 juillet sauf que voilà comme on
disait il y a une fois tous les 70 ans
il fait non
bien sûr non non je compare pas
un petit point sur le moment l'instant
évidemment on va retrouver timothélène
Timothée vous êtes toujours dans dans la
foule dans et on le retrouve pas tout de
suite on ira juste après
cette cérémonie
[Musique]
cet historique à tout point de vue
est-ce que ça va perdurer est-ce que ça
battra les records de vue année après
année ou non non c'était un moment
historique en 53 et ensuite il n'y aura
plus le même engouement c'était un
monument historique évidemment en 1953
forcément aussi parce que c'était la
première fois que ça ça passait à la
télévision d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
grâce à au couronnement de la reine
Elizabeth en 53 qui a une explosion de
vente de télévision en France et ça a
commencé à exploser à ce moment-là il
avait 100 000 seulement avant 53 on l'a
regardé au niveau des différents
magasins ou les différents théâtres et
cinéma non non c'est évidemment que
c'était historique je sais pas aussi en
terme d'audience si on aura quelque
chose d'assez extraordinaire notamment
pour le mariage de Lady Di ou encore de
4000 c'est ça sera encore historique
évidemment vu que ça arrive très
rarement mais ça ne battra pas les
audiences de l'époque il n'y aura pas
autant de monde dans les rues d'ailleurs
je me rappelle bien je me rappelle
rétrospectivement évidemment la reine
Victoria avait payé les gens pour venir
dans les rues de Londres parce que les
personnes qui voulaient à l'époque ça ne
marchait pas ces histoires de d'assister
à des couronnements non s'intéressait
pas à ça et on a dû payer faire venir du
monde un peu partout d'Angleterre et 400
000 personnes dans les rues alors qu'on
en comptait 10000 ou 20000 environ et
donc elle a dû faire revenir parce que
forcément c'était un couronnement
extrêmement important aux yeux du monde
entier donc il fallait qu'il y ait du
monde dans les rues les chiffres
officiels c'est comme en France lors des
manifestations les chiffres officiels et
puis les chiffres des syndicats est-ce
que c'est la CGT va dire pour les
personnes
est-ce que c'est anachronique ce que
nous voyons là ça va être est-ce que
c'est un peu chose le tard un peu
ringard
c'est ni ringard comme le disait
Philippe tout à l'heure ni anachronique
parce que on est hors du temps si vous
voulez voilà et on dirait que c'est
acronyk en quelque sorte pourquoi
pourquoi il n'est pas possible de
évidemment que les symboles
[Musique]
tout le monde se posait pas la question
on construisait comme c'était la règle à
ce moment là on se disait pas il faut
perpétuer des traditions qui ont vous
voyez ce que je veux dire pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi dans cette époque
aujourd'hui en 2023 nous sommes obligés
de faire comme avant et de ne pas
moderniser les choses mais pourquoi
faire c'est quoi l'intérêt
voilà pour entrer cette monarchie dans
ce qui est dans cette période dans cette
année 2023 et pas
danser la preuve c'est qu'effectivement
il y a trois ou quatre ou cinq millions
de personnes qui regardent ce qui se
passent que ça intéresse que ça émeut
que et d'autre part dans un monde où
tout bouge tout le temps si je si en
permanence
ou le l'instant
un instant on chasse un autre où on a
tellement le CP d'impatience qui est
encore
démultiplié par Internet avoir quelque
chose qui qui bouge peu qui est lent qui
ouais cette cérémonie c'est
extraordinaire cette espèce de lenteur
ces gestes c'est
ça paraît totalement inutile et vins à
une époque effectivement il suffit de de
cliquer pour parler avec l'autre bout du
monde mais voilà c'est dans ce moment à
la magie mais aussi l'intérêt de la
chose c'est ça nous rappelle que le
temps c'est quelque chose quitte à en
faire une sorte de fait Disneyland vous
voyez ce que je veux dire vous savez
dans ces cas-là tout tout pas tout
apparaît fait Disneyland je veux dire
quelqu'un qui n'est pas chrétien et qui
va dans une messe va trouver sa truc
c'est une fête Disneyland
le roi sort dans le jardin de Buckingham
semble-t-il il n'est pas encore au
balcon l'image du roi qu'on n'avait pas
forcément prévu voilà fabrique
voilà c'est dans l'ordre politique enfin
l'ordre politique que juste toujours
leur religieux qu'on soit d'ailleurs
dans une monarchie dans une démocratie
dans n'importe quoi
et donc voilà on est
écoutant ce qu'il se passe à Buckingham
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le salut du roi aux armées ou le salut
de l'armée au roi Frédéric Frédéric très
impressionnant
[Musique]
ça n'a pas changé depuis 1953 mais ça
restera sans doute encore très longtemps
comme ça mais oui c'est assez
extraordinaire quand même nous sommes en
direct en visio avec Daniel de
Monplaisir bonjour Daniel historien
spécialiste des monarchies nous étions
en pleine discussion sur presque en
débat avec Frédéric williat pour savoir
si cette monarchie devait se moderniser
comme exemple pourquoi ne pas faire le
trajet entre l'abbaye de Westminster et
Buckingham avec une voiture une
Rolls-Royce pourquoi ce besoin de
sancter dans le passé
bonjour alors cette question de la
modernisation du cérémonie
allemonarchique et les élégantielle déjà
Louis XVII 1114 avait renaclé à l'idée
d'un sac parce qu'il avait peur que la
cérémonie soit un peu trop ringarde et
rattache la monarchie à une époque
ancienne
dans le cas présent pour l'exemple de la
voiture et du carreau je vous dirais que
le roi de Charles III étant très attaché
à l'écologie il est assez logique qu'il
soit accompli par une voiture à cheval
plutôt que par une voiture plus tardante
non seulement un grand nombre de litres
de carburant
oui finalement c'est peut-être ça
peut-être que c'est moderne de venir en
carrosse
avec une gamme Daniel de Monplaisir vous
êtes au Canada parce que le roi Charles
III n'est pas que roi d'Angleterre c'est
presque un abus de langage il est roi de
du Commonwealth aujourd'hui
et il est aussi roi du Canada d'ailleurs
lors des cérémonies de naturalisation de
citoyenneté pour devenir citoyen
canadien nous devons prêter serment au
roi ou à la reine d'Angleterre
c'est une tradition qui se maintient
auquel les Canadiens
alors c'est l'une des questions les
Australiens par exemple voudraient
sortir du commonol soit en tout cas ne
plus avoir
Charles III comme roi est-ce que c'est
l'une des inquiétudes est-ce que ça
pourrait arriver au Canada notamment
est-ce que un jour certains pays peuvent
avoir la volonté de quitter le
commonweil c'est en tout cas de ne plus
dépendre du roi
alors il y a effectivement au Canada
Mouvement Républicain c'est un peu
inévitable démocratie
des idées sont sans réparties le Canada
a un problème particulier c'est que
étant divisé entre francophones et
anglophone bon grosso modo les Québécois
seraient plutôt partisans d'une
République alors que la majorité des
anglophones souhaite rester sous la
couronne britannique mais aujourd'hui la
majorité du Canada je crois est assez
fier d'avoir un roi plutôt qu'un
président de la République
Daniel de montazar on revient vers vous
très vite au Canada mais d'abord on va à
Londres Timothée delhem vous êtes sur le
mal vous avez réussi à accéder est-ce
que vous voyez au loin le balcon de
Buckingham au loin au très loin
peut-être
alors écoutez ça c'est l'objectif de
plusieurs centaines plusieurs milliers
de personnes autour de moi c'est
effectivement d'apercevoir ce balcon et
d'apercevoir le roi là ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'en fait cette avenue du
mal était bouclée par les forces de
l'ordre interdits
à ce stade en tout cas par ce que et
bien forte influence il a et bien
l'avenue vient tout juste d'être ouverte
c'est la raison pour laquelle et vous le
voyez derrière moi et bien la foule est
en train de quitter parce qu'en réalité
je suis encore sur cette place travelgar
parce que voilà cette avenue du mal
était bouclée là l'avenue vient d'être
ouverte et donc vous le voyez les
Londoniens qui espèrent apercevoir de
nouveau le roi sont en train de regagner
cette avenue 7 avenue du mal et vous le
voyez donc juste ici ils sont en train
d'emprunter cette avenue laquelle donne
sur Buckingham voilà ici beaucoup de
gens sont rentrés chez eux mais beaucoup
beaucoup de gens restent encore ici pour
profiter du moment et puis pour
apercevoir
endroit en haut du balcon et puis
évidemment profiter de ce défiler aérien
nous voyons ces images justement de
cette foule qui se masse et qui
s'approche presque en courant de
Buckingham Palace où il doit y avoir un
défilé aérien avec une soixantaine
d'avions au vu de la météo il y a
toujours eu une incertitude sur sur ce
défilé aérien je retourne au Canada
Daniel de Monplaisir historien
spécialiste des monarchies alors on
disait tout au long de cette ce
couronnement que le roi n'avait pas
beaucoup de pouvoir il en a peut-être
encore moins au Canada ou non au final
il est important il est sur les billets
par exemple
alors le rôle du roi c'est vrai dans
toutes les monarchies modernes et de
régner qui n'est pas de gouverner
ceci étant le trône n'est pas pour
autant un fauteuil vide l'euro incarne
la continuité historique des peuples il
incarne l'Union nationale et il
constitue une espèce d'ombre du thé vert
en psychanalyse on dirait que le roi
c'est le père du père son rôle n'est pas
d'intervenir mais son rôle est d'être là
en cas de gros incidents alors c'est
vrai que c'est plus vrai davantage vrai
pardon de l'Angleterre ou le roi est
présent que du Canada où il est vrai
pour de la propagé depuis longtemps nous
n'avons pas vu depuis longtemps parce
que Elisabeth II qui a pourtant fait une
trentaine de voyages au Canada quand
elle était un peu vieillissante c'est
vrai qu'elle a fait moins de voyages
donc aujourd'hui au Canada comme dans
d'autres pays du commonweiss nous
attendons impatiemment la visite de
Charles III le commonweel à quoi ça sert
est-ce que commonweal ça a une réelle
influence est-ce qu'il aide certains
petits pays est-ce qu'il permet au
Royaume-Uni d'avoir une influence sur
tous les continents à quoi ça sert le
Commonwealth à quoi ça sert au roi et à
la royauté
alors le coma well c'est plutôt une
autorité morale que une autorité
politique autorité politique il en a
aucune tous ces pays ont une politique
étrangère tout à fait indépendante mais
il garde entre un lien un lien moral un
lien de souvenirs et également il se
conserve assez régulièrement pour
l'adoption de position commune
concernant l'avenir de leur propre pays
et l'avenir de la planète c'est plus un
club à l'anglaise je vais les Anglais
beaucoup les clubs nous les Français
nous sommes moins sensibles à cette à ce
genre de formule le commonwell c'est un
peu un Club un club ça ne sert pas à
diriger ça sert à ce concert et à
vérifier un certain nombre de choses à
échanger des idées voir à aider à bâtir
des projets communs ou des projets
spécifiques
même à Buckingham tous ces drapeaux
évidemment l'Union Jack à la primeur
mais on voit sur les différents pylônes
on les voit ici d'ailleurs on voit le
drapeau du Canada à gauche de
l'Australie me semble-t-il à droite des
bases à jamais etc etc et on voit cette
foule au loin qui semble remonter le mal
pour atteindre Buckingham merci beaucoup
Daniel de Monplaisir de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce qu'elle commonweal c'est
sûr
ce couronnement du roi qui n'est pas que
le roi d'Angleterre on retourne à
Londres Timothée delhem il y a des
Anglais il y a aussi des Français autour
de vous
tout à fait Thibault je suis avec
Alexandre 14 ans Alexandre qui s'est
levé tôt ce matin à 6 ou 7 heures du
matin vous me disiez 6h du matin c'est
ça et vous avez assisté à cette
festivités exactement alors qu'est-ce
que vous avez vous avez vu vous me
disiez vous étiez du côté du Big Ben
vous c'est ça exactement j'étais à côté
de Big Ben du coup j'ai tout vu et
c'était super il y a le roi qui est
passé et on a attendu pendant à peu près
5 heures 6 heures quelque chose comme
cela et après il a fait le couronnement
et il est revenu à peu près deux heures
après voilà c'était super on a pu voir
toute la famille royale repasser une
deuxième fois et voilà alors vous vous
habitez à Londres c'est ça vous êtes
venus en famille avec des amis
aujourd'hui alors non je suis venu tout
seul car j'habite juste à côté
je vais pas dire l'adresse mais j'habite
en face de l'abbaye donc malheureusement
il y a toutes les portes qui étaient
fermées donc j'ai dû contourner toute le
toute la Tamise afin de pouvoir accéder
à
la cérémonie donc pourquoi est-ce que
c'était important pour vous en tant que
Français de venir assister à cette assez
participé avec en quelque sorte assez
festivités et d'apercevoir le roi
Charles III pour le jour de son
couronnement car pour moi c'est comme un
peu comme rentrer dans l'histoire de
l'Angleterre et j'ai aussi assisté
au funérailles de la reine la dernière
fois donc voilà j'ai fait à peu près 16
heures de queue donc pour moi c'est
comme les funérailles de la c'est comme
une suite pour moi je voulais vraiment y
rester ça me tenait à cœur donc voilà
quel était l'ambiance l'atmosphère là où
vous vous trouviez c'est-à-dire du côté
du Big Ben on imagine beaucoup de monde
on imagine aussi beaucoup
d'effervescence oui c'est vrai c'était
vraiment festif et on pouvait se faire
beaucoup d'amis autour de nous c'était
super que que vous disais les gens
c'était pas très bavard mais j'étais
sympathique il faisait des blagues il
partageait la nourriture on parlait etc
c'est assez sympa vous allez faire comme
des milliers d'autres là essayer d'aller
apercevoir là aussi à nouveau le roi
Charles III au balcon de Buckingham ah
oui bien sûr je vais d'abord rentrer
chez moi puis après j'irai à Buckingham
pour voir le le show aérien puis le roi
à la fenêtre ce défilé aérien
effectivement alors c'est pas seulement
la cérémonie religieuse de ce matin
c'est également ce week-end de
festivités un certain nombre de fêtes
qui sont organisés dans dans tout le
pays il y a également cette journée de
solidarité lundi vous allez y participer
aussi à votre manière oui à ma manière
je vais être avec mes parents qui
reviennent de voyage et on va essayer de
d'organiser quelque chose voilà voilà
pour cette ceague cette réaction de ce
de ce jeune Français 14 ans Alexandre
pour qui s'était important d'être là
aujourd'hui
merci merci Timothée Delam oui étonnant
cette passion étonnant vous m'avez dit
qu'il y avait une passion française pour
la monarchie là vous en avez la
confirmation
oui enfin une passion mondiale d'abord
parce que si on parle de 5 milliards de
3 milliards de personnes qui vont qui
assistent à cela c'est pas que la France
mais voilà
cette espèce de cérémonie à laquelle on
a assisté cette voilà c'était
d'enracinement effectivement dans le
plus profond de notre histoire commune
de la sacralité enfin toutes ces
choses-là font que voilà ça explique ça
explique cette notamment cette image
incroyable de la foule là qui est qui
arrive et
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas mais la presse
britannique on a parlé cette semaine si
la foule présente à Londres et les
téléspectateurs vont réussir à battre le
record de des funérailles de Lady Di 3
milliards et demi ce qui était
extraordinaire personne a fait mieux
dans l'histoire à part les compétitions
sportives on ne sait pas ça on verra
dans quelques jours et surtout que c'est
comme c'est pas c'est pas les
funérailles d'une star bélier
etc c'est que un rythme religieux ce
sont des choses qui normalement
effectivement assez peu les gens or là
effectivement comme nous ils sont ils
sont fascinés et merci beaucoup Frédéric
merci de nous avoir accompagné pour
suivre ce couronnement avec cette image
très impressionnante en France on est
capable de faire ça pour Johnny Hallyday
ou une coupe du monde de foot pour
Jacques Chirac aussi beaucoup de monde
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de monde
dans les rues oui il y avait du monde il
y avait du monde aux Invalides
on n'est pas comme
image comme ceci mais oui je vois ce que
vous voulez dire Brandon tiens
d'ailleurs ces images on en profit
ensemble on met un peu d'ambiance romain
River
vont vous faire vivre ça évidemment
revient parce qu'on ne veut surtout pas
rater le dernier événement de ce
couronnement toute la famille royale au
balcon Harry sera-t-il là oui ou non la
réponse dans quelques instants on
revient tout de suite et on vit ces
images dans l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette foule cette foule qui avance vers
Buckingham Palace sur the mâle cette
longue avenue qui mène au palais du roi
Charles III à couronné tout à l'heure le
dernier grand moment de cette journée de
couronnement c'est évidemment la venue
au balcon de toute la famille royale
toutes peut-être pas Harry ne devrait
pas y être le fils le deuxième fils du
roi Charles et qui sait nous ne sommes
pas à l'abri d'une d'une surprise nous
sommes en direct avec Frédéric brun
bonjour Frédéric journaliste spécialiste
de la de la Grande-Bretagne ce que vous
m'entendez
oui très bien merci comme à tous c'est
tous les invités qui sont venus sur ce
plateau et en visio pour commenter ce
couronnement votre sentiment avec les
images que vous avez vu aujourd'hui tout
à l'heure aux alentours de midi 13h
lorsque le roi a été couronné et
maintenant avec cette foule qui avance
dans l'ombre
l'impression c'est une impression d'une
réussite éclatante bien entendu une
réussite pour la monarchie britannique
et puis c'est une grande joie une grande
ferveur et surtout ce qui est très
frappant cette c'est le cette chose
merveilleuse qui est l'union parfaite
entre les âges les plus anciens les plus
anciens entre les institutions les plus
pérennes et la modernité avec les temps
d'aujourd'hui avec l'esprit du temps
avec l'humour du moment avec les
inquiétudes du moment qui
transparaissent sans être pesante et
c'est cette symbiose finalement de ce de
ce peuple britannique est aussi d'un
tiers des habitants de la planète grâce
au commonweets
je vous ai lu dans le Figaro Magazine
secret d'un roi vous livrez quelques
secrets parlons-nous un peu de Charles
III qui est-il ça fait des années 74 ans
que le monde entier le connaît mais il
reste toujours assez mystérieux il est
pas très rock par exemple le roi Charles
II est-il et comment va-t-il gouverner
je dirais c'est il y a 74 ans que la
planète le voit le sculpte le regard
mais ne le connais pas vraiment
ce roi Charles III il y a d'abord ce
sont les deux pieds les deux faces d'une
même médaille il y a le visage public
qui est ce visage cérémonieux vous avez
vu qu'aujourd'hui il est impeccablement
rompu à l'exercice il y a pas le moins
de faux pas il est d'un calme on ne sait
pas ce qui bouillonne en lui parce que
quand il faisait du théâtre il en a
énormément fait quand il était étudiant
à Cambridge et puis ensuite au Pays de
Galles c'était c'était quelqu'un de très
drôle et on disait qu'il masquait son
trac derrière son humour et donc
peut-être masque-t-il aujourd'hui son
trac derrière 70 ans de pratique 70 ans
d'entraînement il est probablement le
souverain le plus entraîné le mieux
préparé à monter sur le trône depuis des
siècles et des siècles
et mais derrière l'autre côté de l'autre
face de la médaille c'est que c'est un
homme extrêmement sensible c'est un
homme extrêmement travailleur c'est un
bourre de travail c'est un homme engagé
c'est un homme qui a une personnalité
très affirmée une personnalité qui la
réussite à révéler qu'il a réussi à
forger parce que bien entendu il est il
marche dans les pattes sa mère il est
sous l'ombre tutélaire il a été
longtemps de son père de son grand-père
de son arrière-grand-père de ses oncles
et arrière-grandon puisque il bien
entendu il y a toutes sortes de drames
dans cette famille y compris un roi qui
n'a pas été couronné
lui-même il y a eu des rumeurs à toutes
sortes de se demander s'il serait
couronné si la reine ferait un autre
choix alors qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
choix possibles institutionnellement et
aujourd'hui et bien j'espère qu'il
savoure avec toute la sensibilité toute
la poésie qui est la sienne et avec le
sens des responsabilités j'espère qu'il
savoure aujourd'hui ce moment alors
c'est un homme aux multiples facettes le
roi Charles III cette c'est un homme
très joyeux pas tellement rock mais il a
une passion pardon qui est la danse il
adore danser alors bien sûr les danses
de salon il sait danser les danses
écossaises quand il est à balle moral il
s'est lancé la valse au palais de kinger
mais et le cadry s'il le faut à
sandringer mais il aime le rock il aime
il a dansé déjà du reggae du zouk il
connaît nombre de coutumes et de danse
des pays du commonweal c'est surtout il
aime terriblement ça les nombreuses
cavalières qui ont pu danser avec
Charles à l'époque où il n'était pas
encore le roi disent que c'est un
excellent danseur et surtout qu'il n'est
pas le même comme quand il danse il se
il se libère terriblement donc il est un
peu plus rock qu'on le dit il est un peu
à l'image de finalement de cette
Grande-Bretagne dont nous Français
aimons ce mélange de
de sensualité de légères petites touches
de kitsch quand il le faut et puis bien
entendu de temps en temps d'impertinence
et il sait en avoir c'est un homme qui a
beaucoup d'humour qui est très très
drôle en privé un humour très grinçant
par île et donc c'est un homme passionné
c'est un homme qui aime conduire
conduire sa voiture c'est un homme qui
est évidemment le jardinage qui est
proche de la nature qui prône un certain
nombre de valeurs du retour à la nature
depuis plus de 50 ans et on l'a vu
pendant très longtemps comme un baba
cool il faut relire la presse des années
60 et 70 où on le traitait de Prince
hippies de Prince des babakouls on le
voyait avec une une pâquerette sur
l'oreille parce que il disait qu'il
fallait arroser son jardin avec l'autre
sa baignoire et récupérer le la pluie
qui tombait des toitures pour pour ne
pas perdre de l'eau à l'époque ça
faisait terriblement sourire
heureusement ou malheureusement
malheureusement je ne sais pas comment
il faut le regarder
l'époque la rattrapé il est notamment
l'un des instigateurs du premier
discours qui a eu lieu dénonçant et
metent en garde contre le réchauffement
climatique ça n'est pas lui qui l'a
prononcé c'est Margaret Thatcher mais
dans ces mémoires
dit notamment que c'est conversations
avec le prince de Galles à l'époque des
19778 long long éveillé entre autres
conversations à cette conscience du
réchauffement climatique donc c'est bien
avant le fameux discours notre maison
brûle etc cette la dame de fer de ses
conversations avec le prince Charles qui
ont pris la mesure des choses dès la fin
des années 70 qui était très novateur à
l'époque donc c'est un homme étonnant à
bien des égards et puis c'est un
francophone et un francophile beaucoup
de Français ont encore en mémoire son
discours sous la coupole de l'Académie
française lorsqu'il avait défendu les
fromages français qu'il connaît fort
bien et qu'il aime parce que c'est un
gourmand même s'il ne déjeune pas il a
été dit qu'aujourd'hui la famille royale
aurait qu'un un déjeuner très frugal
c'est son habitude il aime travailler
les journalistes qui ont pu
l'accompagner dans des voyages savent
que il vaut mieux avoir quelques fruits
secs au fond de ses poches ou je ne sais
quoi parce que dès que dès qu'il le peut
il monte dans sa voiture entre deux
trajets il ouvre des dossiers il n'y a
pas de déjeuner il ne perd pas de temps
en revanche le titaille à 5h à
l'anglaise notamment avec l'arrêt du
consort Camilla c'est un moment
privilégié pour lui et le soir il est
connu comme étant un gourmand et un
gourmet donc c'est pas toujours l'image
qu'on a de lui il a parfois une image un
peu austère un peu éloignée un peu
réservé ça a été ça a été un enfant très
timide c'est un enfant qui a qui a
souffert d'une éducation rigoureuse qui
a aussi peut-être ce qui a trouvé
beaucoup d'affections chez sa grand-mère
c'est que les Français surnommaient
Queen même avec beaucoup d'affection
parce que son père qui était avant tout
un officier de marine était plus rude et
plus viril il n'y trouverait pas cette
tendresse à ce moment-là et bien et bien
ce sont toutes ces facettes de Charles
III qui aujourd'hui
sont une couronnée d'une certaine
manière à la fois le le souverain
héritier d'une des plus anciennes
monarchies d'Europe je vous coupe en
instant pour l'homme d'aujourd'hui
l'homme du 21e siècle Frédéric un
instant pour signaler que vous le voyez
sur les images on les commente la foule
arrive au Mémorial Victoria devant
Buckingham Palace en haut du the mâle
cette longue avenue qui mène à
Buckingham Palace la foule est libérée
pour s'approcher au plus près du balcon
ou viendra se présenter le roi Charles
III accompagné de sa famille accompagné
des Princes où William et Georges et
peut-être du prince Harry c'est pas
certain Brandon Noiret c'est un moment
important ce balcon oui c'est vraiment
très très important donc on le disait
tout à l'heure c'est la reine Victoria
qui l'a amené mais on pense souvent
quand on parle de balcon on pense
souvent couronnement mais il était
surtout important pour les moments
historiques notamment durant la Première
Guerre mondiale lorsque le roi George V
a voulu parler au peuple londonien en
peuple l'anglais il était présent donc
quelques jours avant le début de la
Première Guerre mondiale et la seconde
fois où il apparaît au balcon c'est le
lendemain de la Première Guerre mondiale
il sera présent il y a aussi quelque
chose d'assez extraordinaire c'est le 8
mai 1945 le balcon avec Winston
Churchill qui n'était plus Premier
ministre et Clément Akli mais il était
présent on a voulu le voir et la reine
Elizabeth était déjà là aussi
Winston Churchill est monté au balcon de
polémique aussi parce qu'on considérait
que c'était seulement la famille royale
le 8 mai 45 et animagistorique où il est
là on le voit la face au peuple
londonien il est présent avec la famille
on a aussi des images des Princes
souvent qui font la tête qui boude qui
se bouche les oreilles on pense
notamment au Prince George lors du
dernier défilé avec ses avions qui
étaient passés au-dessus de Buckingham
ça faisait trop de bruit pour ces
petites oreilles nous verrons donc dans
quelques instants cette image que le
monde entier attend d'une certaine
manière que les Britanniques attendent
et d'ailleurs Timothée delaime je crois
qu'il est avec nous Timothée vous êtes
sur the mâle et vous avez vu cette foule
avancée progressivement vers Buckingham
tout à fait Thibault nous avons vu cette
foule avancée comme un un gros paquebot
qui a avancé lentement mais sûrement
vers ce palais de Buckingham et
maintenant voilà que cette avenue du mal
qui donne sur le palais de Buckingham et
maintenant noir de monde une avenue
d'environ 1 km vous imaginez le monde
que cela fait et donc il se trouve
derrière moi maintenant les Britanniques
qui attendent un patiemment l'apparition
de la famille royale et en particulier
du roi Charles III il continue plus de
pleuvoir sur Londres c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous voyez peut-être
derrière moi certaines personnes qui
sont en train de quitter les lieux il
faut dire que cela fait bien longtemps
qu'ils se sont levés pour pour certains
en tout cas
les mines sont toujours aussi joyeuses
ici on sent que c'est véritablement un
jour de fête à l'image peut-être de
cette grande banderole que j'ai juste en
face de moi happy and glorious heureux
et glorieux vous savez c'est paroles du
god save the King et qui résume
finalement très bien et cette journée
cet état d'esprit en tout cas dans
lesquels se trouvent les Britanniques
aujourd'hui
merci merci Timothée si de vous
approcher encore un peu pour vivre au
mieux cette ce moment à Buckingham
Palace avec cette famille royale au
balcon de ce de ce palais et vous voyez
que sous les fenêtres de ce palais de
Buckingham arrive la population le
peuple britannique qui s'est massé le
long du cortège pour voir le carrosse de
Charles III à l'allée au retour et
maintenant qui essaie de s'approcher
progressivement de bucking à Moran merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau bon on parlera sûrement
de ce moment dans les livres d'histoire
exactement c'est certain une grande
chance retourne avec avec Frédéric brun
qui est toujours avec nous en visio ce
moment du balcon c'est toujours
intéressant parce que c'est un peu
people aussi ce qu'on va voir là dans
quelques minutes
plus que people c'est le premier acte
politique du roi ce que nous avons vu
jusqu'à présent c'était des actes
d'ordre métaphysique c'est un jeu
couronnement le moment où le souverain
reçoit l'onction et devient l'émissaire
de Dieu sur la terre donc c'est un
moment extrêmement spirituel une
spiritualité que le roi Charles III voit
comme quelque chose de très ouvert
puisque les représentants des religions
les plus diverses représentées dans le
Royaume-Uni dans le commonwell sont là
donc ce n'est pas c'est une vision tout
à fait ouverte et moderne des questions
spirituelles la scène du balcon
évidemment elle est cruciale c'est comme
dans Roméo et Juliette mais c'est le
premier acte politique du roi parce que
c'est là que l'on va voir quelle
importance il donne à la famille royale
le périmètre il définit est-ce que c'est
ce qu'on appelle simplement les signaux
members c'est-à-dire le noyau dur de la
famille royale comme vous le disiez
évidemment en France il y a une petite
attente qui est sur l'un de ses fils
nous allons le je ne fais pas de
pronostics à ce moment là mais ce sera
aussi l'occasion peut-être de voir des
personnages qui sont un peu moins connus
du grand public en France comme le duc
de bluester le duc de Kent qui sont des
personnages extrêmement importants parce
que ce sont les cousins directs du roi
donc c'est sa famille la plus proche ce
sont des noms et des personnages aussi
qui le relient à une histoire immédiate
vous évoquiez la présence de Winston
Churchill sur ce balcon le vainqueur de
d'Hitler qui était venu saluer la foule
donc les images quand on voit les images
de Churchill au balcon elles sont à peu
près la même que celle que l'on voit là
sauf qu'elles sont en noir et blanc et
bien le duc de blooster ou le duc de Ken
ce sont aussi des personnages qui
relient Charles III à cette histoire
glorieuse du Royaume-Uni dans les
siècles récents dans les périodes
récentes la couronne de Saint-Édouard
qu'il a reçu et bien le lit
immanquablement à une histoire
millénaire mais les membres de sa
famille sont ceux qui rappellent que
si le monde entier libre aujourd'hui du
nazisme c'est à la Grande-Bretagne qui
le droit puisque c'est le courage des
Britanniques de résister à Hitler qui
ensuite a entraîné la décision des
Américains et autres bien entendu le
général de Gaulle était en exil la
France était en exiles à Londres mais
c'est cette petite île qui a redonné la
liberté au monde c'est sur cette petite
île qui est née la démocratie
parlementaire qui était aujourd'hui le
standard que nous acceptons le mieux et
l'envoyer tout à l'heure la présidente
de la Chambre des communes donnait
l'épée d'État au souverain donc la
question de la modernité de cette
institution ne se pose même pas
puisqu'elle s'incarne dans cette dame
qui préside la chambre parlementaire et
elle montre que c'est sur cette petite
île qui est née l'idée d'un monarque qui
incarne la dignité qui incarne la
pérennité des institutions qui peut être
un monarque sympathique le roi Charles
III va beaucoup plus au contact sert
beaucoup plus de mains que ne le faisait
sa mère parce qu'il y a un décalage de
génération parce que Charles III c'est à
mener d'innombrables actions charité et
permis à des milliers de personnes de se
réinsérer donc il est il est un peu plus
proche de manière moderne de la
population mais il reste dans le droit
fil de cette coutume et de cette
tradition qui font l'ADN de cette nation
d'une certaine manière et puis la scène
du balcon nous allons voir dans quelques
instants avec cette foule compacte que
les éléments n'écarte pas que la pluie
ne refroidit jamais de toute façon les
Britanniques considèrent qu'il y a pas
de mauvais temps il y a seulement des
gens mal habillés et mal équipé donc
c'est pas un problème et ça ferveur et
voici cet instant que vous attend donc
et ce premier geste politique c'est qui
va être là c'est un geste politique plus
que people merci Frédéric bravo restez
avec nous on suit en direct la foule qui
acclame le roi et la reine et nous
regardons attentivement les membres de
la famille royale qui se présentent
derrière eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous entendez la foule qui acclame le
roi Charles III et la reine Kamila vous
voyez les membres de la famille royale
qui se présente au balcon devant cette
foule Macé devant Buckingham Palace pour
acclamer ce roi qui a été sacré tout à
l'heure à l'abbaye de Westminster la
dernière grande image le dernier grand
moment de ce couronnement il me semble
que Harry prince Harry n'est pas au
balcon ce n'est pas une surprise
Timothée delaime vous êtes dans la foule
au pied de ce balcon racontez-moi ce
qu'il se passe
n'est pas avec nous pour l'instant je
demande à Frédéric brun Frédéric cette
image avec cette foule qui acclame son
roi mâche toujours très impressionnante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc nous avons trois générations droits
d'Angleterre sur ce balcon aujourd'hui
ce qui est aussi un événement
la famille royale
je commande juste
ce qu'il se passe
la parade aérienne de la Royal Air Force
mais aussi j'ai lu ce que le roi avait
demandé à ce qu'il n'y ait pas seulement
des aéronef militaires mais il y a aussi
des hélicoptères de secours il y a
notamment ayant un petit clin d'oeil
c'est qu'il y a deux des hélicoptères
qui vont survoler le palais l'un et de
la formation du régiment dans lequel le
l'actuel prince de Galles William a
servi comme secouriste secouriste en mer
prenons à la suite de son père et il y a
également un hélicoptère d'une unité
particulière qui est l'unité dans
laquelle le prince Harry a servi en
Afghanistan donc il y a quand même un
certain nombre de clins d’œil qui sont
faits à tous les membres de la famille y
compris tous les enfants du nouveau roi
Charles III et un hommage qui est rendu
car personne n'enlève les mérites du
prince Harry lors du conflit
d'Afghanistan comme je ne vois pas sur
ce balcon en ce moment dans les images
que l'on nous montre le frère du roi le
prince Andrew le duc d'York qui
aujourd'hui ne porte plus d'uniformes
militaire à cause de ces mises
en cause juridique mais qui a été un
très grand soldat dans la dans la guerre
de libération des Malouines il s'est
montré un officier de marine extrêmement
courageux allons au front était blessés
et une des unités de l'année vie qui
représentait dans ce couronnement et
celle dans laquelle a servi le prince
Andrew donc il y a des symboles
familiaux qui existent néanmoins dans
tout cela et puis c'est les Français ne
connaissent peut-être pas le monsieur
qui est derrière qui vient de prendre
des photos qui s'appelle Chris Jackson
et c'est un personnage extraordinaire
sympathique parce qu'il suit le roi et
la reine consort depuis presque 15 ans
dans tous les voyages et alors les il
est lui détenteur d'archives visuelle
absolument unique donc il a même lui
apparaît d'une certaine manière sur ce
balcon c'est très important visiblement
de montrer toutes les générations on
voit beaucoup le roi c'est lui qui est
sorti en premier l'image est restée
longtemps sur lui au côté de sa femme et
depuis il y a une vraie alternance on
montre beaucoup voilà c'est deux hommes
cet homme et ce petit garçon ça c'est
très important qu'il soit là qu'on les
voit et que ce soit très clair dans
l'esprit des Britanniques que ce sera ce
seront eux qui prendront la succession
et qui seront à jour à la place de
Charles
le message est très clair c'est pour les
150 prochaines années tout est organisé
avec des rites qui changeront sûrement
vous savez quand a été enterré quand il
est funérailles d'Elizabeth II on s'est
mis à sa comparer en disant est-ce qu'on
va il y a un protocole extrêmement
rigide extrêmement établi en fait pour
les 5 derniers souverains aucune des
funérailles royales n'a été la même à
chaque fois ça s'est adapté à l'air du
temps les 8 derniers couronnements n'ont
pas suivi le même la même cérémonie la
cérémonie religieuse elle oui bien
entendu mais pour tout le reste tout est
mobile et c'est cette extraordinaire
capacité des Britanniques à être
pragmatique à s'adapter au moment qui
fait aussi leur leur durée dans le temps
ils sont
capables de rebondir sur les événements
magnifiquement cette scène du balcon
nous le montre et puis il y a toutes
sortes de petits symboles on note que le
plus jeune des enfants du de l'actuel
prince de Galles et bien et dans ce
petit uniforme noir qui n'est pas
l'uniforme rouge que porte son frère
George mais qui est l'uniforme des
gardes Gallois donc il y a aussi le pays
de Galles on sait est à une terre ou de
nombreux Gallois se sentent par moments
assez indépendants ou indépendantistes
et bien nous entendre le god save the
king le dernier de la journée peut-être
le dernier officiel en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
roi qui s'attarde encore quelques
instants il sera sans doute le dernier
sur ce balcon vous le voyez toute la
famille royale et entrée une image
intéressante et je ne suis pas serpent
que ce soit tout à fait dans le
protocole de rester comme ça jusqu'au
dernier moment il a l'air de vouloir
profiter Frédéric brain
la théorie c'est même qu'il aurait dû
théorie quitter le balcon le premier
mais et même ce signe qu'il vient de
faire ce grand signe de la main très
chaleureux avec ce sourire et bien c'est
aussi la marque du roi c'est-à-dire que
le protocole est là pour guider le
protocole et là pour accompagner mais le
roi est souverain c'est la moindre des
choses et visiblement il savoure aussi
cet instant et puis il est en communion
avec son peuple et aussi pour leur dire
que quel que soit les difficultés
actuelles la Grande-Bretagne en a connu
d'autres les surmontera et c'est un
message d'espoir un message de paix qui
donne envie de pavoiser quand on est
britannique on retrouve Timothée delhem
sur place maintenant que les les
fenêtres du balcon Royal se sont
refermés Timothée vous avez vécu un
moment d'histoire est-ce que vous avez
senti la foule vibrer parce que nous en
plateau on l'entendu cette foule crier
pour son roi
on a toujours pas réussi à retrouver
Timothée les petits problèmes de
connexion c'est souvent le cas émotionne
une vraie ferveur allez-y allez-y
Timothée on a retrouvé votre voilà
super on y va voilà je vous disais c'est
vrai gros moment d'émotion on a senti
voilà que c'était vraiment un moment
important qu'il était en train de se
passer évidemment toutes les personnes
sur cette avenue du Mac que je suis en
train de remonter et vous le voyez sur
ces images et bien toutes les personnes
ne voyaient pas de leur propre yeux et
bien le roi Charles III et puis la reine
consort et puis le reste de la famille
royale au balcon mais ils les ont vu sur
des écrans géants qui ont été disposés
tout du long de cette avenue et voilà
que maintenant et bien il y a eu
également ce défilé aérien que vous avez
pu voir également et puis voilà que que
maintenant le défi est terminé et bien
certains beaucoup en tout cas font comme
moi c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont en train de
[Applaudissements]
nous ne savons pas ce que ce que vous
faites avec les autres britanniques
allez-y on vous a récupéré Timothée vous
pouvez continuer
oui j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des
petits problèmes de connexion c'est
parce que voilà il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de monde sur cette avenue du mal je
voulais simplement conclure Thibault en
vous disant qu'on a le sentiment que
même si la cérémonie a proprement parler
les festivités à proprement parler son
son terminé et bien les Britanniques
sont là simplement pour profiter pour
prendre du bon temps ils sont là
beaucoup de familles beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup d'enfants et ils continuent de
profiter de cette journée de cette
journée de fête ici à Londres
sont en direct visiblement on va me dire
dans dans l'oreillette je crois que le
roi est ressorti sur le balcon avec la
reine caninale vous me confirmez
Frédéric brun
mais oui absolument ils s'offre une
sorte de bain de fou la distance en
quelque sorte avec la reine Kamila voilà
il salue il est visiblement heureux
chaleureux
et comme pour les Beatles c'est il faut
aussi peut-être imaginer la joie
chaleureuse qui est la sienne et plus de
70 ans qu'il attend ce moment il n'est
pas un jeune prince de 20 ans qui a peur
de tout cela c'est la la millième fois
qu'il vient sur ce balcon il y a été
avec ses grands-parents avec ses parents
il est rompu il est rompu et l'exercice
et espérons qu'il savourent ce moment
dernière question puisque nous
approchons de la fin de ce couronnement
et soleil on a vu quand même sur ce
balcon un écart vous voyez la reine et
le roi était au centre il y avait cette
colonne entre eux et le reste de la
famille Royale le prince alors oui on
disait il faut les montrer il faut bien
expliquer que comme vous me le disiez
les 150 prochaines années sont sous
contrôle mais quand même le roi c'est
Charles
très clairement c'est vous savez le
surnom de Elizabeth II c'était pas ça
elle était la patronne à partir de
maintenant cellule patron
on sait que c'est un très grand
travailleur qui l'aime s'emparer de ses
dossiers donc il ne là pour les
prochaines années il faut pas imaginer
qu'il se contentera de l'exercice de la
tasse de thé et du petit gâteau comme
disait je Pompidou il prend les choses
en main aujourd'hui c'est son genre de
gloire c'est son genre de Triomphe et
c'est aussi je crois sa mère lui a
appris que le temps est un très grand
maître et que aujourd'hui la temporalité
elle est la sienne il maîtrise cette
temporalité et effectivement sa famille
est autour de lui sa famille la plus
jeune sa famille la plus ancienne mais
mais c'est lui qui est au centre de
l'attention avec sa avec son épouse avec
la reine consort c'est vraiment un
couple qui était au centre entouré de
ses petits pages de ses petits enfants
qui sont évidemment là pour l'appareil
et pour la beauté de la jeunesse qui est
autour de lui parce que bien entendu
il n'est pas il n'est pas un très jeune
homme donc il a besoin aussi de montrer
qu'il s'appuie sur de jeunes générations
mais très clairement c'est l'huile de
patron
merci beaucoup Frédéric Brown de nous
avoir accompagné nous avoir fait vivre
d'avoir vécu avec nous parce que vous
aussi vous avez vu ce moment à vous
sortez oui vous êtes
complètement fans
merci beaucoup Frédéric brun et on vous
lit dans le Figaro Magazine de ce
week-end des secrets d'un roi il nous
les a longuement à expliquer les secrets
de ce roi vous pouvez lire comme avec
grand retour une dernière fois dans
l'ombre avec Timothée delham Timothée
une foule heureuse autour de vous ça y
est ce couronnement tant attendu depuis
des années ou en tout cas des mois
depuis le décès de la Reine Elizabeth a
eu lieu et il s'achève comme ceci par
cette famille royale au balcon
[Musique]
tout à fait Tibo il s'achève par cette
famille royale le balcon il s'agève
également par ces images de ces
londoniens pas que des Londoniens
d'ailleurs on l'a dit un tout au long de
cette émission
des personnes qui viennent de toute
l'Angleterre de tout le Royaume-Uni de
tout le Commonwealths qui sont en train
de continuer d'avancer vers Buckingham
Palace peut-être expertise que le roi
Charles III est bien va s'adonner un
bain de foule peut-être comme il l'avait
fait après le décès de sa mère Elisabeth
II au mois de septembre dernier
peut-être espère-t-il simplement
continuer de de profiter de de ces
instances qui est sûr c'est que vous le
voyez cette avenue du mal est encore
bien remplie l'avant en tout cas de
l'avenue est noir de monde nous nous
trouvons au milieu de ce monde voilà je
vais vous montrer un petit peu ça c'est
derrière nous voilà avec le Trafalgar
Square et puis
ici devant l'avenue voilà ici c'est donc
le palais de de Buckingham vers lequel
nous sommes en train de nous diriger une
chose est sûre Thibault c'est que comme
nous le disions tout à l'heure la
cérémonie à proprement parler et terminé
mais la fête ici est loin d'être fini en
témoigne et bien par le nombre de
personnes qui sont encore bien présentes
sur place
merci beaucoup merci Timothée delhem de
nous avoir fait vivre ce couronnement
depuis Londres merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi nous nous souviendrons de
ces images évidemment de cette couronne
déposée sur la tête de Charles III de ce
roi marchand avec l'orbe dans la main
gauche un sceptre dans la main droite
vers son destin emmené par cette team le
god save the queen et puis cette
dernière image avec le roi au balcon de
Buckingham Palace aux côtés de sa femme
Camila et qui a aussi été sacré
aujourd'hui Rennes d'Angleterre toute la
famille royale réunie pour saluer cette
foule masser devant devant le palais
vous continuez à suivre tout ce qu'il
s'est passé tout ce qu'il se passera
encore lors de ce couronnement vous
suivez ça sur Figaro.fr sur le
figarolive je remercie Alban boy qui
était en régie aujourd'hui Virginie le
trioner à la programmation de cette
émission et puis Riad Becker et Romain
riro qui était au malade technique merci
de nous avoir suivi on reste un peu avec
ces personnage quand même pas vous les
couper comme ça ces images très
impressionnantes de Londres merci de
nous avoir suivi vous continuez à
regarder la foule anglaise sur le Figaro
live merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]